In this course Revon will teach you how to build a
full stack. Amazon clone, featuring an admin panel
using fluter and no JS let's get started
In this e-commerce app, we will learn about email,
password, authentication, state persistence,
searching products, filtering them based on the
category, rating them based on which we will be
able to see deal of the day, adding them to cut,
checking out with Google or apple pay and viewing
the details of past orders and the status.
On the admin side, we will be able to add
products, delete them, see total earnings and
view the graph of sales. Based on the category.
We will also be able to view the orders and mark
them as pending completed, or received to follow
along with this video, all you need to know is the
basics of flatter and dot. There's absolutely no
need of knowing anything about no JS express or
even Java script. If you're familiar with Java
script, it's great. But even if you're not,
don't worry, it's pretty similar to dot.
I'll explain the differences as we move ahead in
the tutorial, repeatedly follow similar processes
of crude. Those are also give some exercise as we
create certain APIs, which you can check with the
solution. I type after following this tutorial,
you'll have the capability as well as confidence
to build your own complex app with this
technology. All right. So the very first thing we
need to do is open up a terminal and in your run,
the flatter create command. But before that, I'm
going show you the flatter version we'd be using
throughout this tutorial. So we are using flatter
two point 10.5 and that version two point 16.2.
After that, we can turn the flatter create
command. I'm gonna call my project name,
Amazon clone tutorial, because I already have
a project named flatter Amazon clone not to get
confused with it. After that is done, we can
migrate to this folder and open it in vs code.
I will open it in vs code using code for stop.
And then it opens up in vs code. That's great.
After that, we can go in the live folder in
the main door dot file. And before removing
any boiler plate code, what I'm going to do
is select IO simulator. If you're not on Macs,
then IO simulator will not appear because it's
only for Mac. So if you're on windows or Linux,
you can always use the Android simulator, make
sure that you have Android studio install. After
that, we are going to go over here in the
run and run without debugging. You can keep
this, uh, shortcut in mind, which is present here,
which will help you debug your apps faster while
this is being loaded. What we can do is remove
this my homepage class that we have. We don't need
that and make sure to not save it otherwise, you
know, it'll give some errors while debugging away.
So you'll think that the problem is coming from
the default app project, but it's because you've
saved. So make sure it's unsaved away after that.
We can make sure and check, uh, change the title,
which will be Amazon clone and remove the theme
data. We are going to modify it in just a bit,
but you can see our app has launched so we can
see how it's looking. It's functional. That
means our default project is great. So we don't
need to worry about that. We can remove all the
comments and you replace the text with this text,
which will just give us a very bad output, which
looks something like this. Great. That's what we
expected. Now let's change the theme data, where
to change the theme data. We need some colors.
So for colors, what we're going to do is in the
lip folder, create a folder called constant.
In this folder, we will have all the constant
files that we have, for example, global variables
or any utility files like functions that are being
repeated again and again. So yeah, we are
going to create global variables.dot file.
After that is created, we can call this global
variables as a class. We're not going to create
any stateless or stateful budget. This class is
going to contain all the static variables that
we have because their value isn't going to change
ever to get the colors. What you're going to do is
go to this website. I'll mention the link in
the description below. This is my repository on,
get up. Then you can copy all the colors that
you can see if you want. You can also copy the
static images and the category images that we
are going to copy on later on. But for now,
let's just copy all these colors
that we can see and paste it away.
After that, what we need to do is go to the top
and import material dot and alls go away. Then
we can go in the main dot file and you change the
theme data. But before changing the theme data,
what I'm going to do is wrap my text widget with
a scaffold widget, just to demonstrate what we
are going to change. And we can see that in action
real time. So here, I'm going to mention the body
as this text, and then obviously wrap it with the
center widget so that everything comes in center
here. I'm going to press command full stop and add
a cons modifier, wherever it asks me to. And over
here as well, I'll add a cons modifier, Ania cone,
modifier, and all our errors go away and just add
trailing comma so that it forms your document.
After that we can come here and you can see, we
are seeing a blank scaffold with just flatter demo
home page showing away, which is this text. Also,
let's just add an app bar, which will be nothing
but a simple app bar with the title that says
Text, hello, and then remove the constant from
your, and put it for the center text. Great,
and put a constant over your as well, and then
just save it. So here we have the, uh, blue app
bar. So the very first thing we need to do is cha
change this background color. I don't think we
need to change it, but just, let's just specify
in case you want to switch teams for your app,
or you wanna make it look a bit different. You
can do that using the scaffold background color
and use global variables dot back variables, not
background color. So you can see if we go to the
global variables class, we have background color
there, which is white, but in case you want to
change it to black, then you can change it over
your and save it. You can see it change to black,
but in this case, we just want it to be white.
So yeah, we have it white. After that,
we need to add an app bar theme. So the
app bar theme is going look, something like
elevation set to zero because all our AB bars
are not going to show any elevation. You can see
there's some elevation here. We don't want any of
that. And we want ICAN theme to be ICAN theme data
whose color will be black. So all our I icons
that show up will be turned to black color. And
we want that because in case we change the
app by color, which we are going to change
to something gradient. Then we want the, I can
theme data to remain a constant there, which
will be a black color, no matter what. And let's
just put a cons conveyor so that all our warnings
fade it in case you're wondering what, why am
I getting these errors side by side, like this,
I'm using a visual studio code
extension for this named lens.
So if you go over your, in the
extension tab and search lens,
you can see error lens showing up. And this is the
word, the thing that I'm using, it's really great.
I would highly recommend using this. Great. So
our icons are now black. Next thing we want to do
is make sure that if we add any button, it shows
up as a golden color or something like that.
So what we can do is just to demonstrate what
I'm going to do is wrap this centered widget
with a column widget and then add a button
away. So I'm gonna call it elevated button
on press will be nothing. And the child
will be a simple text saying, click
and we'll ignore the arrow warning for our
warning. And now we save it. You can see this
is the blue color showing up. We don't want
that. So what we are going to do instead is
In the theme data, add a color scheme with this.
We are going to specify that the color scheme
is the light color. So we have color scheme dot
light. And then we want to pass in the
primary color, which will be global variables
dot second secondary color, which is almost like
a golden color. And with this, our AB bar and
our button both have changed to golden color. So
that's great. But we are obviously going to change
the AB bar color continuously, and we are not
changing the AB bar color. You are in the color,
something like this over here, because
if we specify something like that,
it takes in a color argument and we don't
want to pass in a color argument. We want
to pass in a linear gradient. If you go to the
global variables, you can see this is a AB bar
gradient, and it doesn't accept any gradient.
There is no way for us to pass in an ABAR theme,
which is of the gradient color. So we'll have
to do it manually every time we use an a bar.
So that's why I've not mentioned anything
here, but this color will make sure that
literally everything that shows up except the text
and all of that stuff shows up as a golden color.
And that's exactly what we want having the color
set in place and the team looking great. What we
need to do now is in the left folder, I'll show
you the folder structure that we are going to use.
So we are going to have a features folder where
we are going to have all the features that we
have. For example, we have account, we have card,
We have homepage, we have order detailed screen.
We have product detailed screen. We have search,
we have address everything that is there is going
go in. This features folder. So for now we
are going to have a screen because that's the
first thing we are going to work on. And in this a
feature, we are going to have three folders again,
which is screen, which is all the screens that the
O is going to have, which is just the odd screen.
But in case we have many screens. For example,
you want to divide the O screen into login and
sign up screen differently. You can add both of
them in this screen's folder. Then the next thing
we want is widgets. So the reusable components
in our odd screen, and just to divide the screen
into simpler parts, we're going to have widgets.
And then finally, we are going to have services.
This is going to contain all the business
logic that we have, like going to the server,
connecting with our server, fetching some data,
sending some API calls, all of that is going to
be done in services. And now in the O screen,
we are going to go there and create O screen,
do dot file. You, we are going to import material
dot, then create a stateful widget. And then we
are going to have odd screen, pretty simple. So
we have the stateful widget ready? Yeah. We are
going to return a scaffold. And now there's
the main thing of our app, which is routes.
So how are we going to navigate between pages
and our application? We can use that using,
you know, something like you can use something
like navigator, right? So V navigator dot
Push, and then we need to pass in material
page, route. That's a lot of boiler plate
code to write. And considering we have so
many screens, it's a lot of code to write
again and again. So instead what we are going to
use is named routes. So named routes are something
like navigator push named, and then we pass in the
context and the route name that we specify now,
what is the problem with named routes? Yeah, we
have to go in the main.dot file, set up the routes
and that, that all isn't the problem. The problem
is what if you want to pass in some arguments,
right? So your, if you pass in some arguments
and then just to accept that argument, we have
to write so much of boiler plate code again,
and that will be a lot of work to do. Instead,
what we are going to do is go in the main door
dot file and use something known as on gen route.
So yeah, I'm going to pass
in the property on gen route.
This on gen route will run every time we use push
name route or any other named routes that we have,
and it'll run the call back and it'll run,
whatever is specified to it. So that we'll
have to go to the left folder and your create a
route, not create a folder. Actually let's create
a file called router.dot, where we are going
to have a function, which will return a route,
which will be dynamic. And let's just import route
here. So let's import material package and then
create a function called generate route. We
are just creating this file so that it just
is a needer way to look at it. I mean, there's
no need of doing it, but it just looks neater.
And here we are going to receive route settings
and route settings will give us any data
that is useful in, uh, constructing a route.
You'll see that when we use that, and then over
here, we are going to have a switch and a case
statements because we are going to have so many
routes in our application. We need to match each
and every route with the route that we pass
in. If you don't understand, don't worry.
So you're in the switch. We want to pass in
settings.name. So if anything, and settings
is not showing up away, so let's just take route
settings. So we are going to match route settings
name, which will be the name of the route that
we specify. We need to match it with any of the
cases that we are. So first case we are going to
have is the odd screen. So we have odd screen,
but we need to pass in the name, right? Because
this is the type string. This is not a string.
This is a widget. So what we can do is pass
in slash offscreen away. Now that's a good
way to do it, but even better way to do
it is just go to just copy this line,
go to the offscreen and create a static variable
away at the top called static, constant string,
route name equal to, and then
passing the odd screen route.
And now we can use odd screen, route name
everywhere so we can have odd screen, route name.
That's a cleaner way to do it. Now we don't have
to write, uh, slash offscreen everywhere in our
application instead just use offscreen or routing
name, thus reducing our errors overall, after
that, what are we going to do? Well, we wanna
return a material page, route. That's simple,
right? We already know about material page, route,
and then in the material page route, we want to
pass in a builder, which will not do anything
for us, whatever context that it gives us.
It's no use for us. And then we are going to
return the odd screen and yeah, we have it.
That's all that we need to do. And in case
you want to pass in the settings as well,
you can just pass in route settings. And in case
you want to remove this error, what you can do
is pass in default aware. So this will run
whenever any of the routes that we have aware
that the name that we have do do doesn't match any
of the cases that we have. So I'll just copy this.
And instead of actually, let's remove this.
And instead of showing the odd screen, what
I'm going to do is create my own custom error.
So here, what I'm going to have is a scaffold,
which will have a body centered
saying that the screen does not exist
or wrong page error, 4, 0, 4.
You can style it according to your visa and needs,
but I'm just going to go with this. I'm not going
to spend much time on that. After that we have
the on generat route property done. So here, I'm
going to take settings, which will be received by
the on gen route, which will be given actually.
And then we are going to use generate route,
make sure to import this package, route.dot,
and then pass in the settings that we receive.
And there we have it. Now, if I take this
elevator button and use navigator dot push name,
and then pass in the route name, which is earth
screen, route name, and now let's just restart
the application. And if I click over here and
we don't get transitioned to the next page,
and that's simply because we have this error
saying that the context used to push up or route
from the navigator must be that of a widget.
That is a descendent of the navigator widget.
Basically what we need to do now is just
grab the elevated button with the builder
and that should do the task for us. So if I
restart the application, click on click and
you can see we transition to the router, sorry
to the off screen.dot file screen file because
we haven't specified anything. Great. So that now
that it works, let's just remove this home thing
because we don't want that. It's just for
demo purposes. So I'm gonna remove that.
And instead passing offscreen, obviously
we are going to have some logic in the home
later on when we have the home screen ready as
well, just to post the state of our application.
But we look into that later one step at a time.
Now let's just click close the router dot file
and the global variables and go to the off screen.
Now let's design this empty screen with the login
UI that we want all. So now with me, I have the
screenshot of the app that you're going to build.
So this is just a home screen layout. Let's
break it down and then build the UI for this.
So, first of all, the first thing to notice is
that they are in a column widget because there's a
welcome text. Let me just take this away. We have
the welcome text. Then we have a radio button,
which is this button. We have the radio button
aware, which will, which when click will give
us the form that we have with the name, email,
and password. If we click on sign in aware, it
will give us a form that will tell us that this is
a, uh, name, email, and password that's required.
So let's build it out. Very first thing to notice
should be that we are not putting welcome over
here. So we are using a safe area widget. So
let's go to the scaffold and in the body person
safe area. Now it'll not our welcome texture
is not going to appear somewhere away.
It's going to appear somewhere away. We have
eliminated that UI bug. So to say, after that,
we are going to have a column <affirmative>
And then we are going to have children in
that. And the first child that we have is a
text, which will just say welcome. So let's
create a welcome text and it's going to be a
constant. We already know that because it's just
Because it's just a text saying that, yeah, it's
welcome. And it's static. Nothing is changing over
here. So after creating that, let's see if you're
outputting very good. And you can see there's some
padding constantly over here in this side. So
let's wrap our column with the padding widget.
So we have padding and we'll just put eight. That
looks good. Great. Now you will also notice that
the color over here is somewhat grayish and
in the form that it's selected, it's going
to show up white. So let's pass in the background
color as global variables dot background, color,
gray background color, sorry. And yep. This
looks great. Knowledge just increases font size
of welcome style, not stretch style style, which
will be textile of font size 22 and font, weight
of font, weight dot w 500. You can test out
all the values and then come to the conclusion,
whatever you want. But yeah, we have this
welcome text showing up. Now let's create this
radio button kind of looking thing, which
is this widget. And then if it's selected,
then we are going to show this. So let's
first of all, create these two radio buttons.
So to create these two radio buttons, what
we're going to have in the text widget is
a list style, pretty simple, a list
style, which will have a title saying
constant text, create account eight account
With a style of textile
font weight. Do we're not going to increase any,
uh, font size because it's looking good to me.
And we are the create account. Now let's add
the radio button. So in the left style widget,
we are going to pass in the leading property,
which will be radio. And here we are going to
have an active color. So let's pass in global
variables dot secondary color. Then we have the
value and here we are going to create an enum
for the value. So let's go right at the top
Outside of the stateful widget class that
we have. And here we are going to create
an enum which will be called O and here
we'll pass and sign in and sign up.
Basically this enum will keep track
of the radio button that we are on
and we'll give the value to our radio button. So
here we'll have O dot sign up as a value because
whenever we click this radio button, we want
the value to be signup. And the group value
is of the type. So let's go at the top and
initialize this enum. So we'll call equal to dot
signup with this. We are basically telling that
this is the instance of our enum, which will be
the group value and the signup Orthodox signup
will basically tell that, yeah, this is the
default value that we want. So whenever we land on
this page, we want the signup screen to show up.
If you want, you can pass this as assignment,
but it wouldn't make sense for a new user
and then pass in group value as an instance,
variable of the class or the, or en I'm sorry.
Then we wanna pass in an unchanged property,
which will give us a value of type oath, and
let's just call it value. Great. Now this data
type is because we've passed in the group value
and the value as Orthodox signup in case we
change any of them, this value will also change.
And here, what I'm going to do is set state and
set a global variable that is a equal to the value
that's given and just passing a semicolon. But you
can see, uh, let's just keep it in valve because
this is the parameter. And you can see a value
of type O can't be assigned to variable of type
O. So we just need to make sure that it can never
be Nu great. So we have this list style ready.
Now, if we go by this list, style shows
up and it's selected as well, because
we have passed in odds, sign up as a value in case
you want to change. We can just pass in odds dot,
sign in and restart the application, and you can
see it's not selected. Now let's change it back
now, after having that, let's
just copy this list style
And paste it again. And this will be the
sign in part. So we'll call this sign
in. You can see that's the name of,
and with a full stop. Yep. And then we need to
scroll down and in the radio button, change the
value to T sign in and save it. Now we have the
sign-in app already as well, and it's showing
checked away because we are changed and we are not
restarted the application. So let's just restart
it. And yep. We have create account showing up.
Now we need to show the form that we have now,
how do we show the form? Let's work on the
form part first, and then we can change the
color and stuff. So whenever we click on this
create account, we need to make sure this is
visible. Otherwise, this is visible. And we are
going to make use of this variable that we are.
So what are we going to do is in the
left style here, we are going to check if
OUM variable is equal to O dot signup,
then we want to show something. So what is that?
Something going to be well is going to be a form
which will have a key. So let's pass in a key
with this form. We are going to make validations
in our application. So if the user clicks on
signup, it'll give us proper errors. That,
yeah, name is not entered. Email is not entered.
Password is not entered and any other validations
that you want to perform. So this form is a great
widget. So we want to pass in a key and we have
to create a global key right at the top to use
it. So here we can come and create final sign up
form key, and this will be equal to the global
key, which will be of the generic type form state.
And that's it. And as we are right at the top
here, let's create one for signin form key as
well, because we're gonna do something similar
for sign-in. So let's create that and key. Now
we can copy this, go by here, pass in the
sign form key. And now we need a child.
Now, what is a child going to be? Well,
that's pretty simple, right? A column widget,
which all with all these text field inputs.
So we are going to pass in column and yeah,
we are going to have three fields. So instead of
just reusing the widget again and again, I mean,
writing the code for one text field, then
again, writing then copying it and pasting it
for another. We are going to create a widget for
it, which will be reusable. You can put it in this
widgets folder, but I know that in future, we are
going to use this text field input everywhere in
our application. So what I'm going to do is in
the lip folder, create a folder called common,
which will describe all the common things
that we have. And let me just rename it.
So we have common and this common will have
widgets. It will contain anything that you want,
which is common. Like, you know, some other view
or some other widget, anything, then it'll have
custom text, field or dot. Yeah. It will
import material dot, create a stateless widget,
call it custom text field, and your return, a
text form field. Why are we using text form fill
instead of this text, field widget, because we are
going to use validator with this validator. We're
going to make validations. And if any of the error
that gets thrown, it'll be called by the form.
And it'll throw that error on the screen,
which is great. After that, we need to pass
in a controller. So we have to accept that from
the constructor. Then I'll accept it later on.
Then we have to pass in some decoration. And
how is it going to look like? So we want some
borders to show up. So in the decoration, we are
gonna have input decoration. Then we have border
equal to constant outline input border, because
we want the border to show up as the outline.
Then we want a border side which will be border
side, and let's give a custom color for it. Let's
say, say colors.black. And you can pick any shade
that you want. I'm just going to go with 38. It,
Then I can copy this border
Pass in the enabled border. And this is
going to be the same thing as this one.
And then we need to pass in validate. So we have
the validator here. We're going to get a value.
And then we are going to return something. We'll
put the validations later on. Let's just accept
the controller from now, for now. So we have five
text editing controller taking the controller,
accept it from the construction. Now let's
just take this controller, paste it over here,
and I'm not going to resolve any of the
warnings that I see where, because I know
later on, we want this to be constant
because this is going to change.
And let's just put a custom text feel over here.
Let's have it. And we are not able to type because
we will have to pass in that in children. So
we now have custom text field and pass in the
controller. Let's create a controller right at
the top. So we have final text editing controller.
So what controllers do we need? Well,
first of all, we need email controller,
which will be equal to text editing controller.
And the thing to note here is that this email
controller and the password controller are
going to be used in both sign up and sign in,
because you'll see that later on, I'll
show your demo of why we're doing that.
Then we have password controller and
then we have the name controller,
All right. Now having that, let's just create
the disposed method right itself so that we
don't have any memory leaks and you know, all that
sort of things. So we have this and dispose this
controller, and I'm going to do that two more
times for password and name controller. Great.
Now we can go down and pass in the controller. So
the very first controller that we want to pass in
is the email controller, because we want to pass
an email. So we have that and we see that away.
Now only thing that is different here
is that the name is showing up here.
So that is the hint text. So we can go away here,
take the hint text from the input decoration. And
this he text is going to be from the construc as
well. So we have final string, he text. And now in
case you don't want to type it again and again,
you can click on this, be I and allow, actually
be by and then click on generate construc,
constructor pass in the he text. Great.
Now we'll pass in. He text here and the he text,
what is the he text going be? Well,
it's just going to be emailed.
Great. If I restart this, let's restart the
application. You can see email showing up. Now,
if I click over here, you can see our
validation. Logic is also working. I mean,
switching the radio buttons because when I
change this form, doesn't show up. Now let's
create one more, which is for the
name one. So I'll create it at
top and we'll have name pass in the controller
as the name controller and also a sized box.
And the high wheel specify is 10. Again,
we'll take this and past it down here
for passwords. So we have password and pass in
password controller looks great. Now let's add
a bit of padding over here because you can
see it's way too outside and we want just,
and we want it to be a little bit inside. So what
I'm going to do is wrap this with a container
and why are we doing container and not padding
widget? Because we want specify the color as well,
because you can see that the color here is
just like the background color, but earth
it's white color. So what are we going to have?
Well, a PAing widget, which will be constant
Agent sets all eight. Then we want pass
in a color and the color is going to
be global variables, background color,
because we want it to be white. Right?
And yeah, we have it. Now, this looks very bad
compared to this. And that's mainly because
This color that we have, you can see this is
also white, but this is not white. And we'll
do that logic later on. But for now let's create
the signup button. So for signup button, again,
we are going to create a custom button because
you're going to use that button again and again,
throughout our application and not just in oath
section, we're going to import material dot, take
a stateless widget, call it custom button. And
then we are going to return and elevated button.
Now, how is this elevated button going to be
like, well, first it will have a child of text
saying, yeah, we want to pass in some
text, which we accept from the constructor.
Then we want an on tap actually on pressed
over here. And then we want that from the
constructor as well. And then the style,
how is this going to look like? Well,
it's going to have certain size because
If we put it now it'll not have a correct
size. It'll just be very small. So what
are we going to do? Elevated button.style
from pass in the minimum size, which is
going to be of the type size pass. First,
we need to pass in the width. So the width
is going to be double infinity, whatever,
and how much ever space we get. And then 50,
which is the height. It is going to be a constant
because this is a height 50. Now let's accept
some things from the constructor. So what are
we gonna have? Well, first of all, a final string
text, then avoid callback, which will be on tap.
And then finally, yep. That's it. And
now let's take this bell. I, or alarm
bell bike. Sorry, take this on. Press
pass in the on tap and yep. <inaudible>,
let's take this custom button go to the
off screen pass and a size box. Again.
It's always PA good to pass in a size box instead
of a container, because it can be a constant
container. Can never be a constant. And with this
constant, it makes sure that the widget doesn't
rebuild. So a height doesn't rebuild. It doesn't
affect the performance of the app too much,
but it's increasing it. Uh, which is good. Then
we can take this custom button pass in the text.
So we want the text to be sign up and let me
put it in the string sign up. And the on tap
is going to consist of the validation logic again,
meaning calling the form key, using the form key,
which is a layer and then performing all the
validation, insert in the text field. Great.
Now, if you go layer the other
sign up button and it looks,
and it looks great. Now let's change
the color. So let's go at the top.
And here in the left side, you're going to pass
in the tile color. Now, what do we want? Whenever
this button is selected, we want to show
as white. Otherwise we want to show it
as this gray background color. If
you take this example, you can see
since this part is selected, everything over here
is white, but everything over here is gray. So
yeah, we are going to check if O is equal to oth
dot signup. So if the variable that we have, which
we are changing every time we are, is equal to
sign up, then we want to use global variables, do
background color. Otherwise we are going to
use global variables, gray background color.
Now, if you go where UNC it's looking great. Now
only thing is let's just shift this welcome text
over here. So in the column, you're going to have
cross access alignment as cross access, alignment
dot start and save it. Now it looks similar to
this. Awesome. Now let's just do the same thing
for sign in. You can see when we click away, we
see nothing. What we need to do is just copy this
container that we have created. We can copy that
and paste it down in the list below the list.
And here let's go over and we'll have oth signin.
The container is not going to have any property
name, name. So let's remove that. We are
going to have email and password and the
controllers are going to remain same. We're
not gonna change the controllers for email
and password because see, in case if
user is logging in, but by mistakes,
doesn't see this create account and passes
in some email, like test other age.com,
pass in the password as test 1, 2, 3,
then decides, oh yeah, I changed it.
I mean, I want to sign in. Then we can click on
sign in and directly. This text field will have
the values that we passed in earlier in this
create account. So that's what we're going to
do. So we will have sign in. We're not passing
in on tap for any of that. We'll perform that
logic later on, but for now we have a basic
understanding of what's happening here. Also,
let's just go at the top, copy the list, style,
color, property, and pass in for the, uh,
signin block. And you change it to T signin. Yeah.
Now let's restart our application and see how it's
looking. We are the create account. If I click
over, I have the signin showing up. Suppose I pass
in test other gmail.com pass and test 1, 2, 3,
and then I decide, oh, sorry. I need to sign in.
And we have all the test, all the properties that
we passed in over here, the same as your great.
Now the next thing is, whenever we click over
your, we want to send the data to server. I mean,
of course we are going to perform some
validations, but before that, we, but after that,
we are going to send some data to our server. Now,
how are we going to create a server? We're gonna
use node GS for this. The most common question
for big nurse is what is node GS and why should
we use it? Well before node JavaScript could not
be used as a general purpose programming language.
It was limited to what the browser allowed to do.
This means JavaScript only worked on the client
side and could not be used to make something like
a web server with introduction of no GS. This
completely changed using JavaScript.
Developers could write code for server,
even command line prompts, but you're not
going to talk about them in this tutorial.
No GS is built on top of the V8 engine. The
same JavaScript engine that is used in Chrome.
It's mainly red in C plus plus does
it's pretty fast and used in production.
Let's go to their official website. No js.org link
is mentioned in the description below. Check it
out. The JavaScript environment provides access
to builtin libraries and objects so that it can
interact and make our code work. All right,
now let's just install no JS in our system.
So here we have two options. And if you're on
windows, it'll show windows over here. If you're
on different version of Mac, it will show you
something else, not X 64. So here it shows us
two options to install it. Either we can use the
LTS version, which stands for long-term support,
or we can use the current version. We are going
to use the current version, which is 18.1 0.0.
If you're seeing this in the future, then there
are chances of this getting increase and you,
and you're good to follow along with this
tutorial. As long as you have 18.1 0.0 or higher
on your machine, now let's install this and wait
for it to get installed, to assist you. All right?
So the installation has gotten over. And if I see
over here, it's mentioned in the downloads. I just
have to double click on this and yet it will ask
me certain stuff. I'll just click on. Continue,
continue. Agree to it again, continue then click
on install. And here I need to enter my password.
After entering the password, it is validating all
the packages and it has installed no JS version
18.1 and N PM. We'll talk about N PM later, but
here we have it installed. All right. Now, having
that in place, make sure to keep this in mind.
Uh, you can just save it somewhere because if it's
not installed, then you have to manually install
this in your path. And then the node JS will be
installed. Now let's move this installer to bin
and close this and go to a terminal. And yeah,
just to verify if it's, if it has been
installed, we can type no do no dash
version. And here you can see version 18.1 0.0.
If it's not showing the current version, that
means node have not been installed. You have to
do some path configurations, make sure to do that.
And then it'll show up this version. All right,
after having that in place, we need to go to our
project and here to get no GS, what
are we going to do? Well, first of all,
let's close this lip folder and here we are
going to create a separate folder called server.
Let me just rename it. And this server folder, we
are going to do all of our tasks. So I'll right,
click on this and open it and integrated terminal
via the server folder here and make sure to always
keep this terminal open so that we can migrate
and do our task quickly. So now to initialize
no J in our project, this is a flood project. And
in year we have created a server folder, which
will contain all the server files that we need.
So here, what we need to do just to initialize
node in our project, in the server folder, we can
run NPM in it. And after we do that, NPM stands
for node package manager. We look into that in a
second, but while we initialize this, you can see
it asks us for certain stuff. We don't have
to enter any of this unless you want to change
package name, which you're already familiar with.
Even in fluter, you're familiar with package
names. For example, if you go to the Android
manifest file, you'll find the package name of our
project aware. So we're familiar with that. So we
want nothing different than the package name. It
provides us by a default. So I'm just going
to click on enter without entering anything.
Then the version is going to be one I'm going
to manually type enter. Then the description.
I won't want to add any description I
can click on enter. And the entry point,
this is going to be index GS file. So entry
point is basically whenever we start the server,
it'll start by running this file, which
is index GS, which we will have to create.
I can click on enter because that's what I want.
And then finally, I can click on enter for this,
this, this, this, and this. And if this is
okay for us, then we should type in nothing,
but just press enter. And we have no installed
in our, uh, server folder. And if we click away,
you can see package Jason file. So what is this
package or Jason file? This package do, Jason file
is similar to the pop spec DOL file.
It contains all the information about our
application, like the name of it, the version, the
description, the main, or the entry point of our
project. Then the scripts we are going to
make sure that we change it a bit, but this
scripts will ensure that we can run terminal
commands from here just to get this over started
author license. And there's other
thing called dependencies. When we
install one of the dependencies, just
like we do in spec do file over here.
We have dependencies and we install
them like HTTP module. Similar to that,
we are going to install pair, package, uh,
dependencies and package adjacent file Jason file.
And we are going to have dev dependencies as
well. Just like we have in pec do file. If you
want to do integration testing or widget testing,
you have to add dev dependencies. You have to add
package adjacent, any developer dependencies that
you need. And we are going to install dependencies
with no package manager. As I said, we look into
that in a bit, but for now, let's just write the
first script in no JS. So here I'm going to create
index or JS file. And in case you don't wanna
name this index or JS file and change the entry
point of your file, you can just edit it over
and it'll make sure that this index or JS file
doesn't run. But instead, what you've entered runs
after having that, what we can do is
just write console dot log, hello word.
So this is the very first script that
you're going to write. HelloWorld and
console dot log basically means we are printing
it out on the terminal. So this is similar to
print HelloWorld in dot. So after saving it, what
you need to do is run node. And then you can just
pause in a full stop just to run this whole folder
or otherwise you can mention the file you want
to run. So no index Rogers, and you can see it
prints out HelloWorld. So this is a very first
script that we've written out and we are going
to write much, much bigger scripts than this.
All right, now you can see over your,
we are using extension of GS. As I said,
node is not a programming language.
It is just a JavaScript environment
and we are using JavaScript to write our code.
All of the code is going to be in JavaScript, but
you don't need to know any syntax for JavaScript.
You just need to be clear with certain concepts,
which is covered in dot. All right. Now,
having understood how to write the very first
script. NORS let's understand something about
dependencies. So what are dependencies in NORS
in fluter or in any other programming
languages? Well, software dependency is an
external standalone library that can be organized
into packages to perform specific tasks.
If you see over here, it's written search packages
and the full form of MPM is not package manager.
Not this, it keeps on changing. So with this NPM
website, if you go on this link is mentioned in
the description below. If you go over here, you'll
see that we can search for packages and we'll
install any of them. Just like we have pop.dev.
You can see, we have NPM js.com with this.
We can install any node package and over we can
install any dot of letter package that we want.
So you're, we are going to type in some packages
that we are going to use. Well, first of all,
let's just type in HTTP. You can see it gives us
results of multiple HTTP packages. So here we have
HTTP. This is the one we are going to use, and
it gives a whole document of what is HTTP. Well,
it is LA. It has published two years ago. It
is public. This is a description. And then
we, uh, it tells us how we can install this. So we
have to do NPM I, which stands for install HTTP.
Then it is a get repository. If you click over
here, this is a code, then this is a homepage.
Then these are the weekly downloads. So
right now it is on one 46,000 and you
can try and run it on rank it, but you're
not going to do that. So to install this,
so we are going to install HTTP later on, but
for now, let's just ignore it. And now let's go
to the another package that you're going to use,
which is express. If you click over here, we have
express. Now what is express? It's a, this is the
package that our whole app is going to rely on.
And you can see it is published nine days ago.
We can install it using this. And there are these
many weekly downloads, which is 21 million weekly
downloads. And you can see the graph as well.
So express is just a prebuilt, no, just framework
that will help us in creating server side,
web applications faster and even smarter.
It's very simple and minimal. And since
it's a package, it's going to reduce our workload
and it's going to be really helpful for us. We are
going to install this other package that we are
going to use is mongoose. What is Mongo? Well,
Mongo is a Mongo object modeling tool designed
to work in an asynchronous environment.
It provides both promises and callbacks. What now,
before understanding what this means, we need to
understand what are promises. Promises is a very
complex topic in JavaScript for some people,
but promises are basically like futures in data,
nothing. I mean, there's a bit of difference, but
the main idea is that it has to wait before. It
can. The main idea for both of them, the promises
and futures is that they don't have to wait for
the asynchronous code to work and instead make
other part of the code work so that
there's no deal in the application.
And this user doesn't face any difficulties.
And we are going to use MongoDB. Now,
what is MongoDB? Basically, it's a database.
It is going to store all the data that we need.
It's not like fire base. I mean, there are many,
many more features and fire base as a whole,
but it can be compared to fire based fire store.
So we are gonna install that. So let's quickly
install all of these three dependencies. So we'll
do NPM install. Even this can work and even NPM,
I can work. And then we need to install HTTP,
express, and Mongo. You can write all of them
in a single line without the need of comas,
just a space and it'll install it. You don't
have to go to the package, Jason, like you do
in pop file and just add dependency tag over and
pass in something like this.
We don't need to do that.
We just need to run this command and it will
install for us. So if I click on enter, now
you can see it has been installed again. If you
don't have node, it won't work for you because
it won't identify NPM kind of terminal input.
And now if you go packaged adjacent, you can see
dependencies over. There is express, HTTP and
Mongos installed with the latest versions that
you can see, which is 6.3 0.2. You Haveit then for
express, you'll find the same in case you want to
install dependencies with the same version
you can do. What you can do is NPM install
Mongo, for example, at 6.3 0.2, and it'll make
sure Mongo is installed at that particular
version. Now I've told to you about express,
but now let me show you a quick syntax of
express and how are we going to do that?
So now after writing a first script node JS,
let's quickly write a first API in node JS. So let
me just quickly type in a comment for creating an
API. And now, as I said, we are going to create
an API and we are going to use node JS for
it. Uh, and we're going to use express for it.
So here I'm going to have constant express,
which is equal to require express. Now, since
this is an external package installed from a
another website, which is NPM GS, usually you
only need that. So we have required express.
If you don't understand this text, it's similar
to import line and flutter. Like we have import,
let's say package express, express dot, dot.
This is similar to this line in fluter all right,
and you can name this. Anything you don't
necessarily have to name it, express.
If you want, you can just write your ABC and it'll
require express for you in the form of ABC. Now
you can use ABC to use express anywhere in your
application, but since we are using express,
and if the app gets larger, it'll be a problem.
So let's write the correct names for it. Now we
can take this express and now let's initialize
express and save it in a variable. So we will have
constant, let's say app, which will be equal to
express. We are basically just initializing this
and saving it in the app. Variable, nothing really
great. And this is constant constant, meaning that
the variable is never going to change because it's
a constant. Now we can use this app and do app
dot listen. So this app dot listen, basically
binds itself with the host that we are going to
specify and listen for any other connections. So
now we have to pass in, first of all, the port.
So let's create a variable right at the top so
that, you know, it's visible to us. And in case
we want to change it, we don't have to scroll
down as, and when our app gets bigger. So you
have constant port equal to 3000. You can mention
any number, but 3000 is sort of like a convention.
So we can just take that and we'll have port.
Now, if we don't specify any other host name,
aware, for example, any IP address. So it will
access something known as local host, and we can
access our own API using local host. Now, what
is local host? So suppose you call an IP address
on your computer. IP address is basically some
random string that you'll find like 1 9, 2 0.991,
something like that. You have seen that
number on your computer multiple times. So
whenever you call an IP address, you're trying to
compute contact another computer on the internet.
But when you call the IP address,
like one twenty seven 0.0 0.0 0.1,
then you're communicating with the local host.
It means that the computer is talking to itself.
So if we don't specify anything, it'll take in
local host. Now we are going to specify an IP
address, which is 0.0 0.0 0.0, which stands for it
can be accessed from anywhere. So this is 0.0 0.0,
and we need, and the reason we need to specify
this IP address is because on Android simulators
or even on Android devices, if we use local host,
it won't work on, I simulators. It does work,
but for some reason, Android is not able to
take an local host. And instead we need to work
using our own IP addresses just for debugging.
When you deploy it to a website, then it'll
make sure to give you a URL, which you can use.
But for now, we are just going to pass in 0.0 0.0.
After that we need a callback function. We are
pretty familiar with the callback functions,
and this is how we would create it. That because
this is a Syntaxin do, but in JavaScript either
you can have function over here because
essentially it's a call back function
or otherwise you can remove this and make it like
an add or function. So this is also a function in
do in Java script. Sorry. So you, you can do this
or pass in function over, but not both at the same
time. Otherwise it'll give you an error. And now
just to see if it's connected to a port, what we
can do is again, print it out, using console dot
log. And then we can say connected at port plus
whatever port that we have.
And now this will work fine.
So if I just run it again, using node index
dos, you can see the server has started. It
has printed out hello world, and it's listening to
any connection requests that we will get now, as
this works. Well, I don't want to, you know, have
a plus sign where anywhere in my application, it's
a pretty bad way of doing it in that we use string
interation. So, you know, we have port like this
and we, then we don't have to pass in the plus.
Now you can't do this in do in JavaScript. Sorry.
So to do it in JavaScript, what you need to do
is enter back takeover, which is present below
the escape key. And even here, now we have
it. Now we can use this, but still it's not
highlighting it to highlight it. You just need
to pass in curly brackets. And there you have it.
It's connected at port and it is going to return
the same output. But now it's, it just looks
cleaner. Now, if I exit my listen command and node
index or, and run the index Rogers file again,
you can see hello world and connected at port
3000. Now let's create our first API request. But
before doing that, I want to introduce you with
another dependency, which is a dev dependency.
As you can see, after making some changes, I
have to restart my whole server. So for example,
I have to terminate this again, run it again,
terminate this again, run it. So it's a lot
of effort for us. What if we just make a minor
change? For example, I want to add a space here
and then maybe type in hello then just for
this change, I have to run my terminal again.
So instead of doing that, what we can do is add
another dev dependency, which is <inaudible>.
If I click over your and pass in node one, you
can see your have node. One has published 10 days
ago with 4 million weekly downloads. So we are
going to install this. So we are going to have
node one, sorry, NPM, install
node one. And now we want this.
I want it as a dev dependency. It's not
anywhere in my application. For example,
We are going to use express in our
code, but you're not going to use
node one anywhere in our code.
It's just for our benefit
as a developer. So what I'm going
to do is pass in dash dash, save dev
with this. It'll save it as a developer
dependency. And now if I click on enter
It, installs it for us. If you go to package
adjacent, you can see, we have as a dev dependency
node one, now that we have package Jason install,
what we can do is node one. Instead of running
node index JS, we are going to run node one
index JS, and you can see when we run it,
it is saying on node found node one. This is
because we have to add an additional script
for it. Node was installed in our system files,
Norman isn't. So now what we need to do is go
in the scripts and add a script. Well, the
first script we are going to add is a dev
dev script. And here we are going to pass
in node dot slash index GS. Basically
when we run this command dev, which is
short for NPM run dev, which is your,
when we, whenever we run NPM run dev, it'll
make sure to run this command instead,
and then it'll run the app for us.
So I'm going to save this much and now run NPM
run dev, and you can see. So I started and it's
saying node one with the version number
to restart anytime, enter RS. So if I just
enter RS, it'll restart. But even if I make
certain changes, for example, I type hello,
and I save, you can see without me typing RS,
whenever the file is saved, it'll make sure to
restart our whole server. And now it'll also print
the correct thing like hello. Now we don't have to
manually exit the terminal and restart our server.
And now, since you have added dev dependency,
let's add for a start dependency. So whenever
we run something like, let me close a terminal,
something like NPM start. Then we need to
make sure that we run node slash index JS.
We are not going to need this during development
or debugging, but during installation,
but during deployment to the server,
this is going to be of a great use.
So let's exit this. And if I click on NPM start,
you can see it has started node, but it has not
started node more. I'll exit this clear of the
terminal and run NPM run dev. Now we are listening
to everything. So let's create an API finally.
So we to create an API. Well, you might know that
APIs have get request, put request, post request,
delete and update, which is basically crude.
Create, write,
Create, read, update, delete. So let's
create an API, forget request nothing much.
We are going to look after post delete and update
as well. But for now, let's look at get, because
for post, there are certain things that we need
to provide in case we want to see a great output.
But now for now, what I want to do is whatever API
that I create, I want to go there. It'll provide
me with a link. I mean, the link will be our
own IP address. So whenever we go to that link,
since it's a get request, it's going to give
us something right, because it is going to
fetch some data. So whenever I go to that
link, I need to see, let's say hello world
again. So now what I'm going to do is app dot
get, and that's it. That's how easy it is now,
app dot get. And then we need to specify what
path should it be? For example, how is our API
going to look like? So for example, this is going
to be HTTP, colon slash slash, then our IP address
then slash now, if we do this much, you
know, it'll create a slash API get request,
but what do I want? I just want to have a
part name of let's say hello world. So now
I have to type in hello, world over,
and then obviously a call function.
And again, just to remind you, this is how
we create functions in JavaScript. Otherwise
you can just use the function keyword and remove
this arrow symbol. And now this callback function
is going to run. Whenever we reach this path
on this IP address that we enter. So for now,
let's just say, and here we are going
to have request result. So with request,
we can access anything that the user provides
us with, for example, body or anything,
but in get request, I don't think there's any
body, but we have result. So what do we want to
output on the screen? What do we want to send
as a result? So what do we need to do? Well,
we are going to send dress dot and you can see it
provides us with a bunch of options for now. Let's
use rest dot send. Otherwise you can use rest.
Jason, the difference is that sends send will
send it in a basic text format and Jason is
going to send adjacent response, nothing new.
We are going to use rest Jason throughout our
application, but for now, just to demonstrate,
I can use rest dot send and then pass in somebody.
So for the body, what I'm going pass in. Hello?
Well, and now this will give me an error because,
well, we need to pass in something, right? It's
not a number. We can send a number, but we're not
passing in a number. We are passing in a string.
And as we know it, just to pass in a string, we
need to pass in double quotes or a single quote,
anything. And now if I save this, you see it
has been converted to double tick or double
inverted comma. And that's because of the prettier
format, prettier formatter in via code extension.
So if you go to the extension
tab and find prettier,
you can see prettier code formatter and it'll
format all our code. So you can install that. Now
our API first ever API is created.
It's not giving us any error. There
are no syntax errors as of now. So what
we can do is test our application, but to
test our application, we have to specify our IP
address, which we will do later on. But for now,
since you're not testing on any simulator, I
can just remove this IP address. We are going
to add it back. Don't worry. But for now, just
to demonstrate, I am going to go to the website
with local host. So here I'm going to open
Google Chrome and I'm going have local host
and then pass in the port name, local host
port name with a colon local host 3000 slash.
Now, if I just do this much, you can see, cannot
get slash. Now this is actually a great indication
because it has finally said that it cannot get
any slash request. That means a server is running.
It is listening to API calls, but we
have not created an API call for slash.
Now let's specify the path name that we had
hello world. And now if we do this much,
it gives us hello word. And just to see
what we will get. If we pass in Jason,
then we need to pass in an object away. And what
is the object going to be? Well, it's going to be
named something like let's say hi, and we're going
to call it. Hello word. Now, if I restart this,
you can see, we are getting adjacent format with
high as a key and hello world as a parameter.
And I'm getting this formatted because of an
extension that I'm using. If you click over here,
I have the adjacent format at extension.
You can download it. If you're on Chrome,
I'm using the adjacent format extension. And
that is why it's coming as a formatted string.
Great. Now this is working now, what I want you to
do as an exercise is create a get slash request.
So without having to look at this code,
just try to write it on your own with
whatever you've understood. So this is your
exercise. You can create a get request,
giving adjacent response with key of name and
value of your name. Basically, I want the format
adjacent to look something like slash
with the key as the name and the value
as R for me, it's R because it's my name.
You can pass in any name that you have.
So I want you to have this kind of
response. Were you able to do it? If
not, then no problem. But if yes, congratulations,
you've created your own re request or API on your
own. So now just to demonstrate quickly, we
are going to create an app dot, get which
slash as a path and then a callback function,
which would be request response. Then I'm just
going to type in not console dot log, press dot
Jason. And then the name is going to be Reon
and save this much. Now, if I restart the browser,
I'm getting Revan with the name property away.
Great. Now let me remove the comments quickly.
You can already see the problem over your
as, and when we have more and more API requests,
you can see with two, it feels clouded to me.
So as, and when we get more and more API requests,
for example, you have so many features in our
application like authentication, admin sided
features, products, user the home screen that
we want to see the product details that we want
to screen. The product that we want to add. There
are going to be so many requests and all, and it's
going to be very congested to put them in a single
file. So to put them in different files, what are
we going to do just to make our code look neater?
And when there are multiple people working on
it, it'll be a great relief for them. Nobody
likes to see, you know, like a hundreds, like
a hundred thousand line of code put together.
And I'm not saying you're going to have that
much code, but as if you want to extend this app,
it go to that extent. So now what are we
going to do well before doing that? Let's
just remove all the unnecessary things. Now
we are familiar with everything. Let me also
remove these two get requests because we don't
need that. And now our app is working great.
So now how do we manage different requests? Now we
can take this express, take this app, create this
again, use this app dot listen in every file that
we use. Now, this is going to be pretty hectic,
and we need to run those files individually. We
don't want that. We want, we just want to run this
index or JS file, which will trigger, trigger
all the other files. So for that, first of all,
let's go to the server, create a routes folder
where all our routes are going to be set up.
Then we are going to create
a file called let's say.gs,
which is a very first file. And the functionality
we are going to add in just five minutes or so.
First of all, let's ex require express. I mean,
that's the first thing we need to do,
but we don't need any of this. All right,
no, no express initialization or listening to
anything. We are already listening it away.
Now we are going to create a router. Now
with this router, we'll be able to use that
instead of this app instance or the express
instance saved an app. So what I'm seeing is
we are going to create an router. Let's name
it, that, and we are going to require it from,
and what is this router going to be? Well, we
are going to use express for it, but we are not
going to initialize it using express.
Otherwise we'll have to listen. It,
what we need to do is express router and this,
with this, we have access to the express router
and we can use or router now, instead of app.
Now, instead of doing app dot a app looks better.
So now, if I do app router dot get, you can see
we're not getting any suggestions for it because
dot router shouldn't be initialized
like this. It's going to be a function.
Your, we are just touring the address of this
router in out router. We don't want that. We want
to use the functionality ofout router. That's
why we are going to now have parameters passed
away here. So we are going to have app router
dot get, and now we also get the auto complete.
And after using throughout, do we
can, let's say pass in slash user.
Now we are, again, going to have request
response. All of this doesn't change,
and we are going to return, let's
say, rest dot Jason message.
And that's it. Now, if we go to slash user, we are
not going to get anything. For example, if I via
and pass in slash user, you can see, cannot
get slash user. Even though we created a router
away because this index or JS file doesn't
know what this GS is or what it's doing,
because we have not required it from
anywhere. Index JS, basically doesn't
even know its existence. So what do we need
to do? Well, make sure it knows its existence,
right? So what are we going to do require this
all router? So what are we going to do? Well,
let me add some comments, just to tell you this
part is going to consist of all the imports
from packages here. We are going
to have imports from other files,
and this is all the initializations
I'm going to pass in as in it.
So this is going to consist
of all the initializations.
Now let's import from other files. So we
have constant or router equal to require.
And now we are going to do relative importing,
just like in fluter. We have to directly do
fluter. Let's say package fluter
slash we have let's say screens
slash T dot file. We have to do something similar
to this, but in case you've noticed one thing in
flat you, what you can do, alternatively, is
if you're in the lip folder, and let's say
you're in the main door dot file, and you want
to get S screen dot. What you can do is import
dot slash features slash slash screens slash
screen.dot. This is called relative importing. So
you have to import, according to where you are in
your project, we are going to do something similar
in this because no J doesn't have the
other type of importing or even JavaScript.
So now we are going to have require,
and we are going to require from,
let me close the lift folder. And where are we?
We are in the index or JS file. We want to get
to the S file. So what are we going to do? Do
slash route slash O and then you can pass in JS,
but it's not mandatory. You can pass in as O and
it'll recognize that you want the JS extension,
and then we can save this much. Let's remove
this comment, and now we have it now, still,
we won't be able to access it. You can see, and
it's not giving us any error, but this author
router doesn't even exist for us because these
are all private. You can consider them as private
there. They can be used. This
variable can be used only
in this file, not outside this file to access it
outside this file, we need to export this file
or this variable to export this variable.
What we need to do is module dot exports
equal to or outer with this. Basically, you are
telling that yeah, author outer is not just a
private file. I mean, not a private variable.
It can be used anywhere in the application
So we can save this much. And now
we have author outer, existing.
I mean, still the API won't work because
we need to do other configurations as well.
We need to add something known as middleware
now to understand the concept of middleware.
Well, we need to understand what exactly are
we going to achieve? Well, we have our client
side, which is flatter. And from client side,
they're going to send data to server side.
And then with that server is going to return
something to client side, because we are going to
send rest Jason somewhere. So it's going to return
something from the server side as well. And again,
going to the client side and there it stops. It's
not continuous listening because if you want to
use continuous listening, we are going to use
socket tile for that. It's not in this tutorial.
You can check out my other tutorials, where I've
used sock tile, which is real time communication.
So here, as I was explaining, we have
client and we're sending data to server.
But what if I want to manipulate the data that we
are sending? Suppose we send some data. We have a
very large team and some person send some data. He
doesn't know what format do we have to send it in?
Well, we can specify that format using middleware.
So this middleware is going to come in over your
client, sends data to server, but this middleware
is going to come in middle of client and server.
And we can use anything that we
want. So here we are going to have
a middleware of app dot use. This is how
you use middleware in no J applications.
So what are we going to use or router? And now
our, our index, JSR no JS application knows about
the existence of, or router or this a JS file as
a whole, because we are using or router everywhere
in case you use something else. It won't know. And
it won't use any of that, but we are going to use
all router because that's what we are exporting
you. In case you want to export multiple things,
you have to create an object or a map in dart.
So you, you have to create an object and then
you have to pass in something else as that
else that you want to access. For example,
you want to pass in your name so you
can pass a name like this and pass in R
If you're wondering why we don't have to mention
colon that's because it's a shorthand syntax.
If I type away your or router, it'll do the same
thing that it did earlier, but this is just the
same way. If your key and your value variable
is matching, you can use this shorthand syntax,
but over, we don't have both of them matching. In
case I stored this sort one in another variable,
then this name can be used like this, but since
we don't have this external variable, it won't
do anything. All right, now let's just remove this
object. And instead use all outer. We are going to
use objects in somewhere in our application, but
for not, we are just going to have all router.
All right. Now, if I restart, you can see
this site cannot be reached because we are,
we are getting an error where cannot
access app before initialization,
as the error suggests, we have app initialization
over here, but we are using middleware over here.
So let's take this in it and put it
at the top. And now connected at 3000,
we are not getting any error and now let's
restart the application. And here we have it
message Ivan. Now after understanding
middleware and all of that stuff, finally,
we can dive in T JS file and create our sign
up and login functionalities. So now let's just
remove this or route or get request because we
don't need that. And now create a post request.
We need to add post because we need to post to our
database. We are sending a post request from our
client side so that we can sign up. So we have the
slash API slash sign up route. It's good to have
slash API over because we're going to have admin
panel in our application as well. So whenever we
use admin, admin functionality is going to be like
slash admin slash whatever feature that we have
or whatever API that we are creating.
So we are putting slash API aware so
that it's, you know, better to read on
later on. Now I'm going to have Rick re
and then create a callback function. We have
done that already multiple times. After that,
let's decide, what do we want to do? Well, first
of all, we want to get the data from the client,
right? Because we want the username, email,
password, all of that. Then we need to
post that data in database. If you look at it from
top, these are the two things that we need to do.
And then finally, the third thing is
just to return that data to the user
so that we can save that data in the client side
as well, so that we don't have to, you know,
manually do something or let the user know
that yeah, we have successfully done our job.
So now we need to get the data from the
client. Now, how do we get data from client
to get the data from the client? It's
pretty simple just to demonstrate,
I'm going to print this out. What
you need to do is wreck dot body.
As you might have seen in the client side as well.
Whenever you want to pass data in a post request,
you pass in a body and now to get the body we
have to pass in direct dot body. If this isn't
clear to you, when we go to the client side
and pass in the body, you'll understand what
this wreck dot body is. And I'll explain it to you
again, later on. But basically from now for your,
what we are telling is to get some data from
direct dot body. And now, what do we want to
do? We want to access certain things from reg dot
body. Well, what is it going to be name, email,
and password, because that's what we need to
accept while signing up, right? We created those
text fields. Now let's get them now, whatever we
pass in reg dot body is going to be a map because
let me just show it to you now itself. Otherwise
it'll be impossible for me to explain it to you.
So your, whenever we pass in the body from the
client side, we are going to have something
like name and then the name variable,
or the name editing controller, text,
whatever the function that we have. So we have to
pass this name and let's put an inverted comma.
This is what we are sending from the client side.
And similar to that, we are going to have email
And password given out as well. These are
the three things that we are going to send.
So now to access this map that we're
going to send, we are using red dot body,
but with red dot body, we are going to get this
object. Now, this object, or a map in dart,
we need to accept one of these, you know, uh,
properties. So like we want names separately in a
different variable email, in a different variable
map password in a different variable. So now
a shorthand for that in Java script is
using cons, which is just a modifier.
And then we pass in the curly brackets and then
pass in whatever properties that we have name,
email, and password. These are the properties
and we pass in the same thing. So we have name,
email, password equal to reg dot body. And now we
have access to all of them, but make sure whenever
we use this variable, we need to make sure these
are matching with these keys or properties in our
object. Otherwise it'll give us an error. So with
this, we have access to name, email, and password.
Now we got the data from the client. So let's
remove that comment. Next thing is post that
data and database. So for that, we need to, uh,
get, we need to make connection to our database
now to make connection to our database. Again,
we'll have to go to index and here use mongoose
with mongoose. As I told, it's going to help us
with MongoDB functions. So let's just require this
and then use that. So now
we have to make some connections. So
now here I can just type in connections
and then I can have Mongo dot connect, and then
it'll accept Ari, which we have to connect to
our database. When we go there, we'll find that
out. And then finally, we have to pass in a then
function because as you can see, because this is
a promise or a future, so we need to pass in dot.
Then you have seen the syntax in dot and it's
similar to that. Otherwise you can just use
a weight as well, but since
you are not in any function,
any none of the function is asynchronous
because you're not in any function we have
to use dot then, and it'll give us some value.
And then we need to make sure that we type it
connection successful. And if you think there is
any error anymore, you can just pass in catch,
and then we can have E and then we can just
print that out as well. So we have console log E
if you want, you can just ignore this,
but no problem. And here you can see,
we are already getting an error. The I
power meter to open your must be a string,
got undefined and undefined.
So undefined in Java script
is basically the no value is assigned to
any variable or an object before using it.
So you, we have not assigned anything. That's
why we are not getting any, uh, you know,
we are getting this error. Now we need the URL
and for URL, we need to go to the MongoDB website.
So now let's go, go over there in our
browser, we need to type in mongodb.com.
Then we need to click on sign in, or you can
click on drive free. Since I already have an
account created, I'm not going to create it.
The steps are fairly straightforward. It won't
be much of an issue. So yeah, what we need to do
is you can click on, sign up and then sign up with
Google. The steps I had up already straightforward
as I third. So no need to worry about it. I'm just
going to click on login with Google and up
and see you on the dashboard. All right.
So here I am in my dashboard. After signing up,
you should be on the same screen. Now, what we
need to do is click over here on this dropdown and
click on new project. And now we need to name a
project for the project name. We are going to name
it something like let's say, flatter, Amazon cl,
and I'm just going to type tutorial as well so
that I don't get confused later on. After that,
if you want to add any member set permissions,
you can do that. You can edit this later on as
well. And now click create project. After that, we
come to this page and after coming to this page,
we need to click on build a database. And if you
want, you can just pay it, but I'm just going
to go with free option, then click on create, and
then select the shared cluster, select the default
things that it provides us with.
And then click on create cluster
after that. How would you like to authenticate
your connection? So to authenticate a connection
and while passing in the that we want aware we
have to pass in some URL with the username and
the password. So this is a very important step. So
here, I'm going to pass in the username as Ivan,
and then I'm not going to use the default that
<inaudible> gives, but instead use my own password
and then click on create user, make sure that
whatever you pass in, you remember it later on,
after that, we need to scroll down and
you're enter the IP address that we want
because you're not using local host anymore.
We are using IP addresses. So we can just pass
in 0.0 0.0 0.0. That means allow access
from anywhere, then click on, add entry
and then finish and close.
And now we will go to our database,
which is currently being created after which
we will be able to get our URL. So let's wait
for it to get completed. All right, so now our
cluster is ready, aware. Let's click on connect,
and then you can see the options
here. Connect with MongoDB, shell,
connect your application using Mongo DB's native
drivers or using MongoDB compass. We are going to
use Mongo DB's native drivers, and we don't have
to install anything for that because no GS has
been installed already in our systems. After that,
it gives us a connection string. We can copy this,
make sure to not use mine, because I'm
going to any ways disable this project
and then click on close and then use this URL
elevator. So now I'm going to create a separate
URL at the top in the, in it comment. And here I'm
gonna have DB equal to, and then pass in the URL.
After that here you can see there's my
username. And then it asks me to enter
my password. Let's remove this password
and enter my own password. Instead. Also
make sure to remove this angle brackets. It has
caused multiple issues with me some many times.
So here I'm going to pass. And 1, 2, 3, which
was my password. Again, make sure to not copy
this URL as I'm going to disable my project
very soon after that, we can take this DB and
pass it in over here, and then click on save
here. You can see connected at port 3000 and
connection successful. That means connection to
our Mongo. DB has been made successfully. Great.
Now let's just go to our cluster and in the
database. So if you want to view the data,
you have to go to this collections tab and
here you can see since we don't have any data,
it's not ask, it's not showing us any data, but
you can see, we can load a sample data set or add
my own data. We are going to do that dynamically
using our code. So now let's get started with it.
So whenever we are signing up, what are the
validations that we need to do? You always have
to keep that in mind. What validations can you
perform before posting that data in the database?
What other things that do we have to care about?
For example, if you're fi using fire base,
you can see fire base authentication, handles
everything for us, be it that your password
is six characters. So it'll give you an error
like V password. And then it'll tell you that
your password should at least be six characters.
Then you don't need to worry about same account
with email, same account with email password,
something like this. You don't need to worry
about them since at least authentication handles
everything for us, but here we have to do all
on our own manually. So we are introducing same
account with email and password, that validation.
So what do we need to check? Well, we wanna check
if INR collections, if there is any user with the
same email as ours, they can have the same name.
They can have the same password as it, but they
cannot have the same email. So to check that,
first of all, we need to create our own model.
If even if you're using flatter, it's
always recommended to build your own models,
right? In no JS. And while connecting to MongoDB,
we always use Mongo. I mean, most of the people
use mongoose. There are some people who do
it manually, but I feel it's a, a great time
saver for us. So here, I'm going to create a new
folder called models. And I'm going to call this
model. Let's say user dot JS, because that's a
user model that we are creating. And here we are
going to import Mongo and we don't need to require
express or anything aware because we directly are
creating a model lawyer. We are, we are having no
interactions with express or with no, just APIs,
just a structure of our code. So the very first
thing we need to do is create a schema. Schema is
basically like a structure of our application
or the user model that we are going to have.
So to create a new schema or a structure,
we are going to do mongoose dot
schema and then add a parent thesis
after which we need to pass in an object
like this. After that, we need to define some
properties that are going to be in this model.
And unlike dot, we don't have to specify types
anywhere as you might have already seen. You're
using cons everywhere. Even if, uh, we don't have
to specify anything like string and all of that,
because JavaScript is not a static type
language. It's a dynamically type language.
So let's define some properties. So we need
name, and that's not how we are going to do
it. Name comma. That's not how it's done. We
need to specify more properties inside of this
name. So we have the name property in the user
model, but what is this name going to be like?
What is, what is its type? So they're going to
pass in a type as string. So even if the user
enters name as some number, then we are able
to identify, oh, he has entered a wrong thing.
And as I said, Java script
is a statically is a dynamic
Java script is a dynamically type language.
So here we are just passing in a type string
for Mongo. We're not doing this for Java
script or anything. This is all by Mongo
because you can see, we are using Mongo schema.
After that, we need to make sure that the user
always enter their name. So we are to set name
to true, and we can also set trim two. True.
And you already know what trim means. If the
user enters something like Reon, then it'll
make sure to give us an output. Like Revan
removing all the leading and trailing spaces.
So we need to make that cleaning form formation,
something like that. Then we need to pass in an
email and you're again, you're going to have
required. True type is going to be of the type
spring. Again, trim will be set to true. And then
there's additional property that we are going to
add in email, which is validate or validate in
this validate. As you might have seen in text
form field. If you just go there custom text
field, we have not added any validation here,
but you can see that it validates everything.
Even here, we are going to validate and for email,
what are we going to validate? Well, we are
just going to validate if it's matching with all
criteria, like there's at the rate there's dot
com. There's something like that. You know?
So now how to validate, well, in the
validate property, we need to pass in
validate, which will return to us some value,
obviously, and then it's going to be a function
it's similar to the, this line
is pretty similar to this line,
but just in the same text of JavaScript.
And then we need to ma match certain criterias.
So what do we need to validate even custom text,
form field. We are going to do something similar,
not the, the validation logic that we are going
to perform here, but something similar. So what
do we need to validate? Well, as I said, you need
to need to pass and add rate.com, everything like
that. So for this, we are going to use something
like rejects. So what is rejects? Rejects is going
to be used somewhere in our application.
Again, I'll point it out when we use it,
but expression or RegX is a sequence of characters
that specify a search pattern in a text. So
if you go to this website, workflow.com, I've,
I'll mention the link in the description below.
And if you want, you can just search on Google
validation for email address in JavaScript.
And then it'll point out this website where
you can copy this rejects. And if you don't
even understand this, then it's no
problem. You can just copy this,
have constant R equal to
whatever this is. All right,
And you don't have to pass it in string
because it's a REDX, it's not a string.
And then you have to use value, which is this
value. That is your, and we need to match this
with the REDX. So if you just see over here,
it says that matches, this function matches
a string with a regular expression and returns
an add containing the results of that search.
So what this does is basically whatever value
that you enter. Suppose I passed in Ravana,
the gmail.com, then it'll match that value with
the rejects that we specify. And if any of the
criterias get filled, it'll return to us an
a, so that's what we want to do. So we'll just
do re re and then return this value
because it needs to be returned. And now
after that, we have another property where called
message. And then this message property will be
run whenever this validator is falls.
That means only if the value over here,
whatever we enter matches. Thiss, it'll tell us
that this email is valid, and if it's not valid,
then it'll return to us an error. And we'll
say, please enter a valid email address.
After that, we need to specify more properties.
So we have email after that, we have password
and we need to store password along with us,
because this is not five base authentication.
So for password, we are going to require it
as true, and then pass in the type as string.
Then we need address. We are just toing it right
now. So address is going to be of the type string,
but when we sign the user up, we are
not going to store any address for them,
right? So what are we going to do? Well,
default it to an empty string address is not a
required field. Whenever we create a user model,
We don't want to pass in any address because we
don't have an address at that point. And it's
pretty stupid to, again and again, just type
in an empty string. Instead, we can specify
default layer and set it to an empty string.
After that, we are going to specify the user type
and this user type can be a seller or an admin.
And in this app, it'll only be admin since we will
be including only admin feature. We don't have any
seller, but after following this tutorial, when
you have enough knowledge, you can create the
seller part of the app as well. So you're, I'm
gonna have a type of string. And by default,
we are going to set it to user because we
don't want everyone to become an admin,
right? So whenever the user just signs up,
we don't want them to become a U an admin.
So that's why we are specifying user aware with
this type. We are going to perform multiple logic,
uh, validations while transitioning to another
screen. That's great. After that, we're going
to have a property called card. And we look into
that when we get to the card side of the things,
but for now, let's not pass anything at all.
Great. So after this user schema is done,
obviously we need to export it because, well,
first of all, this is a user schema, not a model.
This is just a structure of how a user is going
to look like we have not created a model yet.
So to create a model, we need to first shave it
in a variable, and we'll do mongoose dot model.
With the help of model, we are able to specify
the model name, which is user and then pass in
the schema for our model, which is user schema.
And after that, as we know, Java script will keep
all these variables in one particular file,
which can be used in one particular file.
So we just use module dot exports equal to
user great. After having that, we can go over.
So here we are going to use user let's import
that you can see constant user equal to require
models slash user. And you can see double dots
away. These double dots are basically like we are
in this route slash art folder. So we need to get
out of here. So we are in the main server folder.
So we use double dot slash and then we go to the
models folder, and then in the user file. Great.
Now we have the user model available
with us. So we just need to use user dot,
find one. This is a property by Mongo itself. So
here we are basically telling that we need to find
a user, but which user do we need to find?
Right? So here we are going to specify the
properties. Well, we need to specify email
property. So we need to do email email,
but we know the shorthand, certain tax for this in
JavaScript. So we can just remove this and we are,
have user dot, find one email. So we have gone
to our user collection. We are checking to find
any one document in our user collection with the
same email property. If it is there, then it will
return to us an existing user. That means we need
to stop our app execution right now and just tell,
yeah, this email already exists. So one thing
to note earlier is that find one is a promise.
So, because we are using user dot, find one,
it's going to the MongoDB database and then
finding one document and it's going to take a lot
of time. So it's going be an asynchronous process.
So we have to mark this function, asynchronous,
first of all, so that we can use a weight layer
similar to data, right? So here we
can pass in asynchronous over here
in case you're using function, then you have
some syntax like this, so you can use a secure
as well. Both are fine. So we are gonna
just make this asynchronous like this.
And now we can use a weight to find one user.
Otherwise it'll return to other promise,
just like in that, if we don't use a weight,
it'll return to, as a type of future right here,
we would've gotten a, a promise
and we can't access promise values.
We need to update for us to, for it to return
some value to us. So here we are going to have,
if there's an existing user, now this will not
give us a bullion value, but in JavaScript,
it basically means that if existing user is
already existing with this, we are just checking
that if existing user is there, if this object
that is going to return consists of anything.
So here we are just checking. If existing user
is there, then we are going to return Jason,
and then pass in a message saying
that the user would same email
Already exists.
Sweet. So it works. But now the problem is,
and I can't show it to you right now, but just
believe me for some time, as I'm saying this,
you can see, we return rest. Jason value with
the message user with same email already exists.
Now, what is the problem over here? Even
if we are getting an error over here,
it'll return to us a status code of 200. So now
the first question would be what are status codes?
So if you go to this website, developer Moza
link is mentioned in the description below.
You can check all the status codes that, uh,
occur when we use HTTP. So whenever we
send an API request, these are the possible
status codes that we can get. And
since we are creating our own API,
we have the ability to pass status codes like
200. So if we go by your successful responses,
200 means, okay, that,
yeah, the request succeeded.
So if you have get, it will just say the
resource has been fetched and transmitted
in the message body, but you're using post. That
means the resource describing the result of action
is transmitted in the message body. These are
the parameters when 200 or okay, status is given.
So your, if we don't specify anything by default,
it'll think that, yeah, we have 200 status code,
but that's not the case, right? Everything
did not went well in our API. So here,
what do we need to do is mention a
status. So here we are gonna have status
passed in. And then with this, we are going
to change the status code that you're going to
send. If we don't send any, it'll be 200, but we
don't want to send 200. So that's why we are going
to specify some other status. So just let's find
out what status code is required. So you can see
your, we have client error responses, or we have
server error responses. Now, what is this message
user with same email already exists. If the
user with the same email is already existing,
that means it's a client error, right?
It's not anything that happened on the server.
We are not responsible for it. That means we have
to use something like 400. Now, what is this 400
request? It says bad request. The server cannot
or will not process the request due to something
that is perceived to be a client error. That's
exactly the case. It's not 4 0 1. That means
that the HTTP standard specify unauthorized.
There's nothing like that. Even 4, 0, 2, even 4,
0 3. You can find out again and again, we have
4, 0 4 as well, which is the most famous one.
So we are going to use 400. So let's
specify 400 away. And there we have it.
That's all that we need just to specify
this and make sure to pass and return away.
Because if we just specify something like
this, it'll continue to execute the app
further. We don't want to execute the app further.
If the user has not already provided us with the
email, then we just want to stop the app execution
away, or the server execution away. That's why we
are using return. And it'll return this status on
this message. After that, if everything went well,
that means our validation has completed. We
don't need any other validation. For example,
if password is six letters week, and if you
want to add that, you can go and user.gs model
and your pass in a validator. So your, you can
just copy whatever we have done in email and make
your own logic aware so that you can perform some
validations. So for example, if you copy this,
paste it away and then remove this rejects
because we don't need rejects for this. And
it's not mandatory to obviously put in validators
again and again, I mean rejects again and again.
So your, what do you need to check? Well, we
just need to check if return value length.
So whatever string that we're getting over here,
it's obviously going to be of the type string
since password is of the type string say value dot
length is greater than six. So if value dot length
is greater than six, that means it has been done
successfully. Otherwise we need to specify that we
need to enter a long password, right? But now I'm
not going to validate this. And it's your exercise
just to perform validations on any object that
you think is really useful for you. So here, I'm
now going to create a user model. So just like in
that we will specify it. So we have user and then
we have to use that and pass in an object. Now, as
I'm using objects again and again, you'll be like,
what the hell is he doing again? And again,
objects. Well, it's like that only JavaScript is
all objects. Everything in all, uh, Java script is
an object. For example, spring is also an object.
Everything that you can think of is an object
in Java script. That's why I'm using object term
continuously, just like in Florida, everything is
a widget. Your everything is an object. Whatever
you can think of is an object. So here, what
are we going to specify? Well, first of all,
you just can't create a user like this. You
need to specify a new keyboard. So with this,
we are creating a new user model and
obviously we need to save it. So we will have
constant user equal to new user. But later
on, we are going to change this user's value
with whatever data the MongoDB gave gives us
after saving that. So what I I'm going to do,
I'm going to make this let with let
or VR. This is a keyword in.as well,
but we're going to use lead because of
some scope problems or scope functionality.
So I'm going to use lead for this. You can even
use VAR. It won't matter, but I'm more used to
using lead. If you wanna know the differences,
I'll mention the link in the description below.
You can check it out in detail. So your, since
I'm going to change this value, I'm sweating a
tool letter. And now I have to specify some
properties. So we need to specify email,
then password and then name. It doesn't
matter what order you pass it in.
You just need to specify the required arguments.
And for us, if we go to the user model, you can
see name is required. Email is required. Password
is required. Rest of the things are not required.
Great. Now we have the user model. So what we
need to do well, we will just use user equal to
user do. You can see we have save wire, but now
the problem is, again, we are using MongoDB to
save it. So we are going to use a ware and now
it looks great. So whenever we save some data,
you might have seen that we are storing these
three data along with some default, like
empty address and empty type or user
type. It'll give us more, two fields for
version and ID ID is going to be the unique ID of
your document, which is pretty cool. Even in fire
based fire store, we have our unique identifier
for every document that we create and version is
the number of times we are going to edit that
file. And how many times have we done that?
It's not really useful for
us, but it gives us that.
And then we need to make sure that we send
the data to the client side so we can just
pass in user. And we're not PA passing
in something like this, because user
is again the same thing that I told you. You can
either specify like this, or you can just specify
user. And now we don't need to worry about the
status code away. Just like we did aware because
my default is going to be 200 and we want to send
200, right? Because the user has been created. All
of our tasks have been doing successfully.
Now let's test our application. So now
you to test our APIs, we can use something
known as postman. So if you go to this website,
postman.com, you'll see that we can test APIs,
debug them. And over 20 million developers are
already using postman it's and it's a
great tool for, uh, people building big,
big application. It's always recommended to use
postal, but what I'm going to do in this tutorial
is use a built in vs code extension known as
thunder client. So we have thunder client,
you can see lightweight rest API client for vs
code. It's similar to postman, but postman has
a lot more features and it's very organized
for big projects. But what I like to do is
just have a built in thing in vs code. Again, it's
similar to that. So if you want, uh, it's similar
to thunder client. So if you want, you can just
install that I would highly recommend using this.
It's a very great tool, but for the, this tutorial
and for the simplicity of it, I'm just going
to use thunder client. So install it. I already
have it installed. So after installing it, you'll
see this tab over, which is this thunder client
extension. Now you can click on new request over
and then you can see it opens up a new file
for us. And here we can pass in something. So
we have the type of the request that we want to
send. And by type I'll explain to you what I mean
in just a bit, but over here, you can see,
we have 30 parameters that we can pass in
headers or anything, body. We are going to
use this extensively and any tests that we
wanna perform, we're not going to use this or this
anywhere in our application for testing APIs, but
you can do that. Postman has a lot more features
than this. So if you want, you just download it.
So now let me go to my file again.
And you're in odd Rogers. We have this
slash API slash signup. Now let's
pass in the URL. So we have HTTP
colon slash slash, and then we can pass in local
host for now later on, we're going to use our
own API or our own IP address. Sorry. So we are
going to replace this with IP address everywhere,
local host. Instead of that, we are going to
specify our own IP address by fetching that,
but only in the client side, in the server
side, we are always going to use local host
because I don't want to show you my IP. And
it'll be difficult for me to blur this out as
when I scroll it up. So here I need to pass in the
parts. So we have slash API slash signup. And then
if we click on, send, it should give us an error.
And it has given us an error cannot get slash API
slash signup. Now, the thing about the type of
the request is that get request on this same URL
is different from the post request on this
URL. So you can have two URLs. For example,
you can have two APIs created of the same URL
URL, but just the difference in get request.
So if you have getaway it's different
from this router post API, that's the
thing I needed to mention. If you get any kind of
error like this, and you've already created your
API, first of all, make sure that you've
exported that and used it in the middleware,
and then make sure that the correct type is
given your, and your sweet. Now, if I send this,
you can see connection was possibly closed by a
peer. Again, we are going to click on send, and
you can see connection was refused by the server.
Now in the body, we need to pass in some Jason
content. You can use example, text anything,
but you know, we are going to use Jason because
that's pretty easy. And if you don't know, Jason
stands for JavaScript object notation, which is
just a data exchange format to use text, to store
and transmit objects. So now I'm going to pass in
email and if you use single ware, it is definitely
going to give you an error. So what do you need to
do is use double inverted comas. If you use double
inverted, it won't give you any error, but if you
use single text. It'll give you an error. So
here we need to pass in name and then pass in
a test claim for now. So let's say R then pass in
an email and again, pass in an email, let's say R
and I'm going pass in R for now, just to see if
ours in our user or JS file is working or not.
After that, we need to click over here again
and then pass in a password. And now we have
test 1, 2, 3, and now when I click on send,
you can see, we are getting this error,
cannot destructure property name of reg dot
body as it is undefined. And now this error
is mainly because you can see where in the order
just we have used destructuring. This is called
destructuring that we are continuously using,
and this destructuring can only be used on,
on objects. So just your resolve,
this error. What we need to do is
add another middleware. So you can use app
dot use and then pass and express dot Jason.
With this, you can see it returns a middleware
that only passes Jason and only looks at
request where the content type head matches a type
option. If you don't understand this, it basically
passes incoming requests with Jason payloads.
That's all it does here in file. Now, if I,
we have restarted the server,
so now let me just quickly
save the file and again, restart
it. And here. Now, if I send it,
you can see we, if you're getting an error and
this error is because you can see user validation
has failed. That means our email properties is now
working, but you can see it gives kind of a very
bad error to us, you know, and if your client,
we don't want to see any of that. So what I'm
going to do is wrap it with a, try a catch block,
and that's exactly what we should do whenever we
use any asynchronous calls in our code. So
let me quickly take this. I'll remove this
from here, because we have posted the data and got
the data as well, and now use a catch block away
And send it over. So now res dot,
we need to specify some status.
And now for the sta the status for this is going
to be 500. So if you go to that website again,
you can see over here that server error responses
are from 500 to 5 99. If I click over your, you
can see 500 means an internal server error. That
means that the server has encountered a situation.
It does not know how to handle 5, 0 1 means not
implemented, and you can see all of that. But for
this tutorial, we are always going to use 500
for this catch error and just passing do Jason.
And then we are passing an error over year, along
with E dot message. Now, you might have noticed
I've used message over year and error over here,
and that's plainly because whenever we have some
validation issue, we are going to use message
for that, for that. And whenever we have some
server error, then we're going to
use error for that. It'll be a lot,
much easier when we go on the client
side and see why we are using what we
are using over here. For example, when
we have error via we using error over.
So now if I click on new request again and click
on send, you can see we have an error that the
user validation fail email, please enter a
valid email address. Great. That's exactly
what we needed. So now I'm going, I can enter
an email of dev gmail.com and then click send.
You can see we are getting this data, and this is
the data that we get away here. User is equal to
avoid user dot say, and then we are sending
it away. So we have this status 200, okay.
And here we have the name, email password
address type, and the ID of the user,
which is symbolized using underscore ID.
And then we have the version with dot, with
underscore underscore version, which is zero for
now. But if we update this, it'll become one, then
two, then three. And so on. Now, if we go to the
MongoDB website and just click on refresh away,
you can see my first database has now a
user and the user is <inaudible> with email,
password address and type, but still, you can
see that the password away is plainly word over
here is plainly plainly.
Given what if my password,
what if my database account or my database data is
getting hacked? So the user will get the password
plainly and all of our users will lose their data
and thus, it will get some errors. And that's not
a pretty good thing. So here, what are we going
to do is before saving the data to MongoDB,
we are going to save this password. So how are
we going to go about making sure that it's more
secure? Well, we are just going to take this
password and hash it. We are going to encrypt
that password so that even if the data gets
stolen by mistake, or, you know, there's some
error from our side and then the hacker just gets
used of the password. It'll be useful for him
because the password is encrypted. So exactly
for this purpose, we are going to make use of a
package called B JS.
So if you come to the NPM js.com website,
you have B JS. And now if you're wondering,
why aren't we doing this and five base and
all of that fire base handles all of it within
itself. And it doesn't give us that complexity,
but aware we need to everything on our own,
because this is our server. So we, we have BCR
and we don't want BCR. We want BCR JS. So
let's again, type it. Now we have BCR JS.
So this is optimized, BCR and JavaScript with
zero dependencies. And it has 1.2 million weekly
downloads. And you can read more about it, aware
all of that is given away. If you can read that
and implement your own hashing, then it's pretty
good. I would advise you to do that. And if you're
not able to do it, at least try it. And if you're
not able to do it, then you can follow along.
So now let's just copy this
command, stop our server
page, this command, and then click on enter.
Let's get rid of this request for now and your,
we have the password. So this is where we need to
implement. So now first things first, we need to
import, we can import BCR JS. So we
have B GS, which is equal to require B
JS. Now we can take this BCR JS and what do we
need to do? Well, we need to hash our password. So
we have B JS dot hash. You can see this function
error. You can explore multiple functions in your
own playground file or anything like that. But
we have, we are going to use hash with the help
of the hash function. We are going to basically
convert whatever string that we pass in a wire,
which is the password string, and we are going
to hash it. And then we are going to hash it.
And then we need to provide a salt wire, which is
it. Now, what is salt? Salt is a random string.
And when we hash a text,
for example, this password,
we add a salt to it. And with this salt, the hash
algorithms output is no longer predictable to us
just to get your doubts. Cleared. Eight is not
the link of the string that it should have.
It's going to be much bigger than this.
So the same password with no longer yield,
the same hash, the salt that we pass away gets
automatically included with our strings so that
we don't have to store that salt in our, in our
database as well via. So here, we just need to
use the password that this hash functions
give us. You can see it's a promise
of the type string again. So what we can do
is avoid this and store it in a new variable.
And for that, we're going to use hashed password.
And it's going to be a constant because you're not
going to change these hashed passwords anytime.
And now we have to pass that instead of hash
password. So yeah, we could have passed in like
this, but that means we are using something like
this of a notation. And if you see in our user
model and just scroll it up, this other type
password, not hashed password. So instead of
hash passing in hashed password, what you need
to pass in is a password. Something like this.
Now we have hashed a password. So let me start
the server again. We are using a get request,
so let's change it to post again, enter a body.
I think I deleted my previous request, so
we need to type it. You can use it again,
but yeah, we have, let's do a different name this
time as to Naman. Then we have email, as let's
say, Naman, gmail.com, then we can use password.
And the password is going to be test 1, 2, 3,
and you can also not add this trailing
adjacent format. So let's just remove this.
And now if you click on send, you can see it got
sent, but now the password is very different.
It has hashed this password and
it's more secure. So even if
some hacker gets in between and steal that data,
he will get a password that he won't understand.
Great. So we have our sign of proud
created with all the validation and logic.
This was our sign of proud. Let's go to our client
side now and connect this sign up API request
with our client side. But before doing that,
we again need to make sure that we pass in
the IP address as 0.0 0.0 0.0 via. All right,
because I forgot to remove that. I mean,
obviously you can use local host with
this IP address passed in as well,
but it's usually nice when you have this IP
address and you're using the IP address. Basically
you can use local host no matter what, having
created the API. Now let's go to the odd screen
and now connect this API to our UI part so that
we can start accessing it here. I'm going to
work in the services folder so that our business
logic is separated from a UI files and all that
related stuff. So here I'm going to create
service dot file. Then create a class for it
called odd service. And now we are going to
create a function for signing up the user.
Since in this odd service, we are going to
have another feature or another function for
signing up the user for getting user data. All
of the authentication part services are going
to be in this. So the very first function
that we're going to create is sign up user.
Now this isn't going to return anything.
So I'll just put an avoid and then call it,
sign up user. Now we want to require
certain things which is email
Password, and then the name, these are the
three things that we want. And later on,
I think we, we will also need the build function
because not build function, sorry, we will need
the build context so that if there is any error,
we can show the error in the form of a snag bar
or something for now. Let's just give that. And
now this is going to be an asynchronous process.
We already know that because we are going to make
some HTTP calls and HTTP will give us future.
Now we are the TRICA block. And now
in the tri block, well, first of all,
let's create a user for this. So now we are going
to create a model for the model. We are going to
go in the lip folder and here create a model's
Folder and then call the file user dot file.
This user dot file is containing the structure of
our user. Just like we had something with Mongo,
we are going to have this user model. So that
later on, we can create a provider based on this
user, because we'll be using state. Uh, we'll
be using provider as a state management tool.
If you're using any other state management tool,
you can obviously go along with it,
as long as you know how to convert
provider to any other, you know, state management
tool, whatever I'm doing right now. Sweet. So now
let's create a class user and it's going to
have the same properties as this user file.
So let's create this class user, we'll make all
the variables final. So we'll have final string
ID and this ID, we don't have it in the user JS
file or the user JS schema. And that's mainly
because Mongo or MongoDB auto generates it for us,
but here we are going to have an ID. After that,
we will have a name. Then we're going to have
a password. Then <affirmative> then an address,
Then a type, which is a type of the user we've
already created that you can see over here. And
I think that's all that we need for now. Actually,
we will need another type as well, which we will
discuss about in just a while when we go to the
sign and route. So let's create it right now,
which is token and the card property that I told
in the user dot file as well. We have this card
comment. We'll add that later on, but for now,
let's have all these things token you can just
ignore for. Now. We will jump into that in a
bit. So now I'm clicking on this bell I icon,
or the be VI and then calling generate
construction. After this, I can again,
click on this bell VI and generate Jason
serialization. We have all of this stuff
after that, over here, you can see ID is
map ID, but whenever we store the user,
for example, let me go to my request over here.
I'll send one and you can see user with same
email address existed. Let's create one more and
you can see, we have ID with underscore ID as the
name over and with this from map, we are basically
giving it a map later on. We will give it a map,
which will be the object that we get
in this request. We'll pass in this
using user dot from map. And when we use this,
it'll take in map at ID. Now map at ID is not
available because this is of the type underscore
ID it. For example, we have name aware, so it'll
get this name. We have email. So we will get this
email password, this password, but for ID, we have
underscore ID. So let's put an underscore ID for
you. If we put underscore ID over here, that would
mean that this property is private in this class.
We can't do do that in flutter, right? That's
why we are using map underscore idea. I think
these many functions are fine for now. So let's
save this much, go via and create a user model.
So we'll call this user. Let's import it at the
top as well. So we have user user equal to user,
and then we need to pass in all of this stuff,
but we don't have any of this. I mean, except
name, password, and email, we don't have anything.
So we can just put them as an empty string.
We'll fill that later on for address as well,
type as well. You can pass a user. Also. It
doesn't really matter. And for token as well,
now we can save this much after this. What we need
to do is use HTTP. And this is the plugin HTTP.
You can use that it's by
provided by Google itself.
So we can just copy this using our dot
dependency. We can just add this. And if
you specify like this, also, it's not a thing it
will just add in, but I'll just type in like this.
So our flatter pub get is running great.
Now we have access to HTTP module. So let's
right at the top, we will have import HTTP,
http.as HTTP, and as the name suggests,
it will allow us to make API request to
this URL. And now we have, we are using
all of the functions at HTTP dot provides us
with using the prefix HTTP. If we don't use HTTP,
prefix, it'll cost confusions like this. If I
just do get, you can see, we are getting the
get request, which is from HTTP dot, but it's
really confusing. So we are going to use the as
HTTP prefix. Now we can use this HTTP and now
we have http.post because this URL, if we just
go over here, we have the post URL that we have
created, and then we need to pass in the URL.
Now for URL, as I told, local OS 3000 will work on
is simulators, but not on Android once. So now to
make this work for Android, what we have to do is
go to our global variable and here just above the
class of global variables, because if we put it
in class, we'll have to make it static and then
use global variables everywhere. I don't want that
to happen. So I'm just creating a global variable
called URL. So here I'm gonna string equal to
this, and now is going to consist of our IP
address with the port. So instead of having local
host this, so let's just copy this. Instead of
having local host of, we are just going to replace
this with our IP address, to get your IP address
on Mac, you can run the command if net
config, or you can just search up on net.
If you're on any other operating system, you can
just find it on your own and then add it away.
I'm going to paste mine because I
don't want to show you the IP address.
And it's always good to protect your IP addresses
and not show it to everyone. Uh, so I've added my
own IP address, make sure it's correct. And you
know, it will work later on if it's not working,
then there's some issue over there. So make sure
it's correct. So having that, I can just use URI,
which I'll import from global variables or
dot file. And I can use it like this without
having the need to use global variables
dot because it's a global variable right
now having URI. I want to convert it to a string.
So I use string interpolation because I need,
I've only added local host 3000 slash
not even slash just local host 3000.
We need to add rest of this, right? So let's just
copy this much and paste it over here. So we have
local, which is our IP address slash API
slash signup, which is our http.post request.
And you will see this error because it doesn't
accept the type string. It accepts the type.
So we need to convert the string Tori.
So to convert it, Tori, we can use URI
dot pass and then pass in this string. So your
I'm going to replace this. You arrive with this
and make you sure to add the slash
away because we have just used
local host or IP address 3000, not the rest of
the thing. Great. Now, after that, we need to
add a body. And if you go back to our JS file,
you can see in the body, we are passing in name,
email and password, because as I said, reg dot
body, and now it's getting clear right here.
We have the body tag and in body, we need
to add something. And now in the body,
we are adding this name, email, and
password, and we are accepting it using
rec. So we have request dot body and then we
can access all of these by object destructuring.
So now for the body, we can manually add using
this and just encoding this in adjacent format,
because we added a middleware. If
we just go to our index or GS five,
you can see we added a middleware of express
adjacent so that it only uses Jason. So whatever
string that we provide over a layer or map that
we provide, we need to convert it to Jason.
So we can use Jason in code for that, but we don't
need to do all of that because we've created a
user model for that sole purpose. So that there's
chances of less error of, you know, typing.
So we can just copy this user and use user dot
two Jason method that we have created just now.
And if we just go to the two Jason method, you
can see it uses Jason dot NCOR calls, the two
map function. And this is a two map function. And
it'll return this object. We are basically doing
what I told you earlier, but in a cleaner format,
so that there's less of errors, you know, and in
the user, I just realized in the user model, we
have not added email. So below name, I'll just add
final string email, and now you have to add it
everywhere. Now, again, a shortcut for this is
just to generate a constructor, then generate
adjacent serialization, and we are good to go.
It's as quick as it gets now, we need to
add an email property away. So let's add
email and we have the email from
our parameters named parameters.
Now we've posted this now, since we've
used express Jason aware in our service,
what we need to do to make some
changes is use head away. And now
this is going to be of the type string
or string. So let's add string or string
and then pass in the content type, which will
be content type as a header. And it's necessary
to add this just because of this express or Jason
life, but it also makes a life much, much easier,
right? So we have, if application slash Jason
char said equal to UTF eight, if you don't
understand this line, it's not a big deal. You
can just copy paste this every time we use that,
but we are going to use it every time when
we make some requests now to our own API.
And now let's just store this in a variable.
You can always use dot then or a cleaner way
of doing it is using a weight and store it in a
variable. Now, what is this? A variable response?
So let's have a response response equal to this.
And now it automatically adds a prefix of HTTP
because we are using a response from HTTP module.
And now, after getting this rest variable, you can
see, we can print it out. We have rest body to
access, whatever data is there inside of this.
Otherwise you can also access status code. The
ones that we mentioned, like having 200, 500,
400, all of that. And we are going to make use of
both of these very much in our application. So now
we need to do error handling. You can see where
we have added a TRICA blog, but that's not enough
because this is variable. We are sending some
stuff, right? If we just to go back on in the
odds or GS file, you can see we are sending the
data. So when it's 200, that means it's success.
But when it's 500, there is an error we need to
catch this error. Tri catch block is not going to
catch those errors, right? We are standing
that data. And whenever we get away your,
the response variable, it thinks
that yeah, it has center response.
There's no error for this. So it's not
going to get caught in the catch block.
And the same for this message that we
have, we need to catch this as well.
So now what we can do is constantly, we
are going to make use of this 400 and 500.
So what we can do is in constants, we can
create error handling, let's say error handling
dot file. So yeah, we are gonna
have an HTTP error handle function.
And then we are going to require HTTP response.
So we will have HTTP and let's import the HTTP
module. So let's go over here, have HTTP and pass
it to Ania. Then we can have HTTP dot response.
Then we will need a build context so
that we can display the snack bar.
And then we will need a avoid callback
function. Now this word callback is basically
function like this wide callback is basically a
short form for this. You can understand it that
way, and then we can have on success. So what
do we do when there's success? Right? Because
everything will differ for every
request. We are going to use this.
So every time we send a request, let's say we are
sending now for sign in. We are going to do for,
we are sending for signup. We are going to do
it for sign in as well. And we are going to use
it throughout our application whenever we send
responses or requests. So the success part is
going to differ continuously. So that's why we
are accepting that from the function as well.
All right, so now we will have switch. And in the
switch part, we will have response dot status code
based on status codes. We are judging if we
are having the error part or we are having
some warning or something like that. So first
case that we have is 200 when there's 200,
that means it's, it is success. So we are going to
run on success command. After that, we can break
After that we have 400 and then we can run the
shown bar. And now we need to create the show
snack bar utility function. So what is the show
snack bar going to do? So just show snack bar is
continuously going to display whatever images,
sorry, whatever text that we want. So you're in
the constant part. We are going to create that as
well. And here we are gonna have void show, snack
bar, build context, pass in the string of text
because every where the text is going to defer. So
that's what we have. And now we are in a scaffold
messenger context dot shown bar, just to avoid a
lot of boiler plate code writing, just to show
a snag bar, we are using this utility function,
and now we can return a text
which will display a text.
Now we can take the show, snack bar, display
it over here. And now pass in the text.
The text is going to be what, when there's
400, we want to display response dot body
at let's say message. Because if
we just go to the odd GS file,
you can see, we have the message property
away when we are giving a status of 400.
So yeah, we have it. And now you can see argument
type string. Can't be assigned to parameter type
end time. This is basically coming because this
is response body. And we need to decode this Jason
file that we have. So here we will just have Jason
decode pass this response body, and then we can
access the message property on it. Every time we
get response body, we need to decode this because
this is not a spring. This is Jason. I mean,
it is a string for us in dot and flatter, but
this is actually a Jason format. So we need to
decode this Jason so that we can use it later on.
And now we can again, break it. And finally,
we will have case 500 and it <affirmative>,
and it's going to be something similar to
the show snack bar. So we can just copy that
Paste it. And this here is going to be error, not
message. Then we are going to break it and then
pass in or default. So any of the status codes
doesn't match, what are we going to show? Well,
we are just going to show a snack bar where it's
going to show response, do body. So let's just
remove Jason dot decor so that it can entirely
show the Jason format only because it's very
rare when this will go any other way, because our
API is always giving these three status codes. Now
we can use this HTTP error handling everywhere.
It's very clean to do it this way, in my opinion.
So here we have H G DP error handle passing the
response. So the response is rest the context,
which is context, and now we need that
context. So let's require it at the top.
Great. Now, after having that, we need an
on success function. So whenever a function
is success, I mean, we get a 200 status code.
What do we need to show? Well, in our application,
you might have seen in the early starting one
minute video, uh, one minute part that we need
to basically show a snack bar. Whenever we have
a success saying that account has been created
and we need to log in with the same credentials.
So if we come back to our application, see
we have to enter name, email password. After
clicking on, sign up, we have to go to the sign
and route and then sign in with those validations
and then we'll get signed in. So here we just
need to display login with the same credentials.
And here again, we will show a snack bar in case
there's any error while sending a request.
So we have this error and now we can just
type in E dot two string, whatever we get away.
Great. So we, our signup user function created as
well. So we can just bind the signup user with our
UI. So we can go to the odd screen and your create
an instance of our function.
So we will have final,
sorry for our class, which will be so service.
And we'll call that service equal to service
And save it in the odd service variable. So we
can just copy it from the top and paste it away.
Now we can take this service,
create a function away called wide
signup user, then use or service dot signup user
pass in the build context. And there's no need of
using build context from your, because we are in
the state full visit. And then we have email. So
email is going to be email controller dot text,
and there's no need to trim this because later on
our Mongo class is trimming it, then we need to do
password. So we'll have password controller, text,
and then the name. So that
will be name controller, text,
and that's all that we need. It's not going to
return anything since it's voided. So we can
just take the signup user and bind it whenever
we click on the signup user button. So we are
Also here. We can see we are in a form
right now. We need to make some validations,
which we left earlier. Basically we are in this
custom button, we are in a form. Our parent is
a form and we have a key and every custom
text failure has a validator. If we go away
and we need to add this validator,
which we will add just right now.
So yeah, we just need to make this validations
happen. Actually let's create the validator
just now. So we have validator and in this
validator, let's validate first of all,
so, well, custom text feel is going to
have the same validations everywhere,
for example, where the value that we get, and
it's very similar to Mongo that reader. So we
have value. So here, the value can be nullable.
So first we wanna check if value is equal to Nu.
So if the value is equal to Nu or the
value is empty, so we will have value
is empty, then we need to return a text that says,
enter your, and what do we need to enter?
Well, enter your he text, right? Because we
are passing in email for the he text password
for the he text. So we just want to say,
enter your hint text. So we'll have enter your
email, enter your password, all of that. And
then we're to return now. So either return enter
your field or return because there are no errors.
So a validation is successful. That means we need
to return now. And now we are, we need to make
sure that every text field that we have in this
signup form gets validated. So we'll have F signup
form, key dot current state, and it's nullable. So
we can just have an exclamation mark dot validate.
So we want to validate it right now, software
validating. It'll give us a bullion value.
You can see so that we can put it an if
condition. So if validation goes, well,
it'll say true. So we can follow along with our
functions. That means our form has been validated.
Otherwise it'll throw us an error on the screen
itself. So yeah, we'll pass in, sign up user.
And which is this function that we just created
after saving this let's run our app. So we will
run without debugging. I've selected iPhone pro
simulator, and let's wait for our app to launch.
All right? So our app has launched and here we
can see we have that. And this is basically coming
because this is the demo app. So here we have that
and now let's pass in the name. So we will have
Ivan and not enter the email, just to
see if it's validating and pass in the
password as test one to three, click on signup.
You can see enter your email, which is a hand
text away knowledge pass in test 1, 2, 3, age,
email.com. Then click on signup account, created
log in with the same credential and to, and to
verify this, we can go to our MongoDB database
and here you can see test 1, 2, 3 gmail.com with
the password and the type as user, everything got
saved. And now just to verify, we are receiving
the right messages. Let me just remain, remove
this. We'll just pass and test one to
three.com. You can see user validation,
fill email, please enter a valid email address.
And that's exactly the message that we've given.
So that's pretty cool. Now let's now having that
in place and we've understood the sign apart.
Let's quickly do the same thing. Similar thing
for sign in now, what do we want to do when we
sign in? Right? So when we sign in, we have
these credentials past in. So now we click
on sign in. We want to make sure that we get
something known as JWT. So now let's close all
the saved files so that it looks cleaner
for us. Let's close the terminal as well,
and now go to our GS file so that we can
create a sign in route. So let's, uh, create
a sign in route and now let's do it as an
exercise. If you want, we can have exercise.
So basically what we need to do is create the
sign in route, but for that, you'll have to
open the documentation for Jason web token and
understand how it works. I'll just tell you the
basic working, basically this Jason web token
is going to make sure that we are who we say
we are. So while sending some data, which has to
be authenticated data. So for suppose, we need to
get the user data. Only authenticated users can
do that, but we need to make sure that we, the
user is who they say they are. So Jason web can,
is basically going to help us with that. They're
going to let us verify that the content that we
have have not been tampered with whatever data
that we are going to sign it with are not tampered
with, to know more about this. You can just Google
it online and make sure to download this Jason
web token package and implement it on your own.
It'll be a great, great task for you,
but in case you are not able to do it,
then don't worry. You can just follow along. Well,
it's going to be a post request just like this,
because it's going to sign up, sign in.
We'll have to use BCR JS again, because
the password that we have, for example, we have
the hash password, and then we need to find a user
with that same email. So we get the password.
But the password that we get will be a hashed
password because you're storing hashed
password. So we need to use B JS again,
to compare the password that we have in the
string format, because whatever the user enters
away is going to be plain, test 1, 2, 3, but
whatever the user has on the MongoDB database
is hashed. So we need to make sure that we can
use hashing and we can compare both of them.
So you can refer to the B of JS documentation
as well. But in case you're not able to do it,
we will do it together. Now, were you
able to do it? If not, let's do it along.
And if yes, then great job. We can just verify
if we are on the same page. So now we are going
to create a post. We are going to slash API slash
sign in. Then we can have asynchronous function.
We will get request and response. And we
have basically created our boiler plate.
And now we also need a TRICA block
because it's an asynchronous function.
And now in the
Catch block, we can just send stress status 500
Jason error E message. Yeah, we have it similar
to this line after that. Yeah, we are going to
get the email and password from reg dot body. So
we have email password equal to reg dot body. Now
we have a basic understanding of how this reg
dot body is going to work with our client side.
After that we are going to find the user, right?
Yeah. We will have to find the user because
we need, need to get the user data. So
first of all, we need to check if that
user even exists with that email. So we
will have constant user equal to innovate
user, which was our user model created using
mongoose. And as you saw in our file away,
we are find one option. We are going
to use the same thing again away.
So we will user dot find one. And
we are going to find by the email,
and then we can again, pass an email, but we
knew the shorthand syntax. We can just use this
after that. We can check if we get no user, I've
explained this to you as well. This is not like
dot. This is not a bullion value. This
consists of user data, but in case this
user data is null or undefined, then it'll give
us a true value. Otherwise it'll give us a fall
value. So if there's no user data, then we
need to return arrest that says with a 400,
obviously, because it's a bad request. So we
will have Jason saying that this is a message
and user with this email does not exist. Great.
After that, we have to get to the good stuff
after this, we have performed this validation.
That means the user has an email and this email
already exists. That means the user is signed up
after this. We need to make sure that the password
that the user has entered is matching or not. And
as I said, we're going to use B for that again,
because the password that we have
is test 1, 2, 3, but the one that
we are stored in the database is something
gibberish. So let's just type in gibberish.
So how can we compare both of them? Well, um, a
very simple thing to do is using BCR JS inbuilt
function called compare with this compare,
it will say synchronously compares the given
data against the given hash, exactly what
we want. So we have to pass in password,
which is a password from body. And then the second
argument should be the hash hashed password. And
the hashed password is going to be in the user
object, which is called user dot password.
And now this is going to be a promise. So we can
ADE this and store. It is in a variable call Isma,
which basically suggests because compar will
give us a bullion value. You can see where it's,
it is a bullion value, true or false value. So if
it is matching, then it'll give us true. Otherwise
it will give us false. So if is match, is there,
then we want to proceed forward. But in case,
if it's not there, so you love is match. And in
case you're wondering why I'm using like this,
putting a negation sign away and then
passing in the data. This is called
guard clauses. It helps in a writing better and
you know, a readable code instead of writing
nested AFLs. If conditions, we can just use
a negation and use guard clauses for that.
So you you're going to return a similar
message. So let's just copy this message
based in Ania. And you're going to send, send
a message with saying incorrect password.
Great. Now this is matching as well. So if it's
not matching, then we are saying it's an incorrect
password. And just one thing that I forgot to tell
you about this crypto js.com, the first approach
that you would've thought of is just converting
this password into hash, using this B JS dot hash,
and then comparing that hashed password along
with this pass, sorry, user password that we have
now, that way won't work because of this sold
feature that I told you, it adds a random string.
So no two passwords are exact same thing. It
is going to add a random salt, and that will
change the whole password. So two passwords,
which are same, are not going to have the
same hashed password. That's the thing to note.
So you are now we will have now JWT used. So let's
use the Jason web token. Let's install it first.
So let's take this, copy this, go to our terminal
in the terminal. We'll just exit our server for
now and install this. So we will have NPM I,
Jason, web token, click on enter after having that
installs, let's clear it and run our server again,
using NPM run dev, and let's use Jason web
token at the top. So we will have constant JWT,
which is it for short. So we can name
this anything as long as a required part
is using the correct name. So vLab Jason web
token. Now we can take this JWT. So vLab JWT,
and it provides us with a function called sign.
As you can see, it tells that it secretly signs
the given payload into adjacent web string
payload. So here, first of all, we need to
provide what we need this JWT to sign with. So
we need to pass in an ID and the ID ID is going
to be user dot underscore ID. And then we need
to sign, sign in with a key. Now this key will
be used to even verify our requests. So later on,
when we add middleware, which we are going to do,
basically for authorized personal only, we are
going to verify that using a secret or a private
key, you can see where, so we need to add that.
So we can name this password key. With this key,
we will be able to author verify that JWT is
correct or not. As I said, we are using J JWT
to make sure that the user are who they
say they are, and they're not hackers.
They will let us verify that the contents are
not tampered with. And this token will be used
everywhere in our application to send requests.
And we'll pass that in the header. You'll see
that later on, but I'm just giving you a spoiler
for what's going to come on later, then say, yeah,
we are going have token equal to JWT dot sign.
Now we will send this token. So we'll have
rest Jason, because with this, we need
to make sure that we store the data.
First of all, we are going to send this tokens. So
this token is going to recite in the app's memory.
So we need to make sure that we send it. And also
we need to send the user data because we want to
store that data in the user provider that we are
going to create when we go to the client side,
because when we click on the sign in, we are
going to return to the big homepage and we
want that user data to be accessed anywhere in our
application. That's why we are going to send both
now how to send both. Well, we can just pass in
token and then user, but now the problem comes in
token will be accessed using token and
then user, but we'll have to specify
one more property just to use that user.
So instead of doing that, we will have.dot,
which is object destructuring. And then
you can have user dot underscore dot
with this. Basically, if we have a user
property, let's say like this, let me
quickly add some comments. Say we have, let's say
name. So we have name as Revan, then the email as
something Ania, Gmail, dotcom, something like
this. So basically we are with using this,
these three dots, you might have seen it in
data as well, when do something for list. So
it'll give us specific property. So will this, we
have name separately, email separately like this.
And then we are also adding token away with
this. Basically when we send some data,
it'll just give us in a format like this,
Right? It will add token to this user part. And
now we've used user dot underscore doc, because
if user is locked to the terminal, you can
just try to log this in the terminal. A big
object will come out and that big object is of
no use to us. You can just try it if you want,
but that user object is of no use to us. So
we are using user dot underscore doc, which
gives us the correct information that we want
having that we can save this much. And let's try
to use this API sign and route in a thunder
client or the postman, whatever you're using. So
let's create a new request pass in this use post
and then pass ANP slash slash local host 3000.
As I said, you can use local host of Ania and
you have sign in. So let's just copy this body,
go to the body page, this body and remove
name because we don't need name anymore.
And then click on send. And here we have it. We
are logged in with a specific token that we have
received, which is pretty good. I, again, send in,
it's going to be the same token. You can see that
great. So we have this working now let's bind it
to our client side. So now let's just close the
terminal, close these files, and quickly go
to our service.dot file and create a similar
function for signin. So let's create this
and I'm not giving you this exercise because
this is going to be involving some
provider and stuff. So let's do it
side by side. So we have sign in user. Then
we need to get context, email, and password.
Then we need to remove this user
because we don't need that anymore.
We're not going to send some data. We are going
to, well, basically just use email and password.
Then instead of passing in the body as this,
what we need to do is use Jason, Incode pass
in a name and an email. You can use user model,
actually my bad. I didn't see that earlier,
but it's just two things. I don't find the need
to pass in it so we can have email password
as password. And yeah, good. Now we need to handle
the same error. So now everything here is going to
remain exactly the same, but we need to add some
changes in on success. If there is some error,
we want the same things to happen. And that's why
we created this HTTP error handling part. Right?
But now we need to do some stuff differently
in on success. So you, if we print our body,
let's just print it quickly. So we have
print res do body and connect to our,
the sign in user to our screen. So let's quickly
go to our odd screen and have avoid sign in
user, then create an empty
bracket and just use this
person. And then we'll
change this to sign in user,
remove the name part because we don't
need that anymore. And now similar to this
On tap, we are going to copy this on tap past it
it over a year. And now instead of passing and
sign up user, we have sign and user instead
of sign up form key vLab sign in form key.
And even here, if you've not noticed, we have
passed in the form as sign up form key. We need
to change that to sign in from key. Please do
that. Otherwise, you know, it's going to give us
an error. Great. So now we have binded this, let's
get our debug console and restart our application
And we are going to use test 1, 2, 3. So we have
test one, two, three.com and then pass in test 1,
2, 3, click on sign in user with the same email
already exists. And this error came in because,
well, if you go to our audit service, we have not
changed this, right? So let's quickly change that
and now let's try it. So we have sign in here.
You can see, we are getting our data token,
the ID, the email, the password.
That means everything is going good.
Now we just need to make sure again, let's go
to our art service and now in the own success,
first of all, we need to save this token to our
device so that we can process the state and our
application. Now, what is processing state? As you
can see, if we just sign in away, you'll see that
after we restart our application or after the
user quizzes, the application and starts again,
we'll again, come back to the screen. The reason
being in the main door dot file we've passed in
home as odd screen. It is not anything else. Now,
how will we do some conditional logic in case you
wanted your, uh, home screen? So what condition
will we put in now? The condition is basically
that we will use this token that will store
in our device memory using shared preferences,
a plugin, which we will get
to in just a minute. And then
we will get that data of the user and save
it to our database. Pretty simple. Right?
So now, first of all, we need to add two plugins,
which are shared preferences and user provider.
Again, just to mention shared preferences. We
will store token in our app memory and with
provider, we are going to store the user data
because when we log, you can see we get this data.
Now we just use this data to save it in our user
provider so that it can be accessed throughout our
application. And we have state manager and we
don't have to manually just pass in everywhere
through the construction, our user data. So now
let's quickly go to pop.dev. So we have pop.dev
using provider. You can see a wrapper around
inherited widget to make them easier to use
and more reusable. So let's quickly save
that, pass it in the dependency. Let's
stop a wrap execution as well. And also side by
side, let's have shared preferences done as well.
And in case, as I told before, if you want any
other state management, you can definitely use
that as long as you're comfortable to convert
them. So let's pause and share preferences,
And there's no manual installation required
for both of them. So we are good to go,
but in case you wanna see the usage and try
it on your own, I would highly recommend that,
do it on your own. And we're going
to use something from your only
basically to write the data to our app memory.
We can do final press first, get the instance,
then use this instance to set the value to our
memory. And that's all that we need to read
the data, which we will use later on while, you
know, persisting the state of our application.
We will read the data and we'll read it using
something like this. Again, get the instance.
And with this instance, we are going to read that
using getin here. We have certain it's pretty
simple, no need to worry about it. Great. Now all
of these things have happened. So here we can have
shared preferences, then we'll see it in
the variable press. And we are basically
just getting their instance. So
we have shared preferences dot
get instance. And since we are using Ave, we need
to use asynchronous. And now we need to basically
said the data now, what is our data? Well, this
is just token. So we have press dot set string.
And then what is the key that we are going
to store it with is going to be X Orth
Token. Now, if you want, you can store it in a
global variable because this exo token, we are
going to use whenever we start the application.
So we are going to make that functionality so
that we can process the state and to get the
string. We have to, again, pass in the key name,
where we are storing this data, which is exo
token, and now we need to pass in a value.
And the value is going to be pretty simple, this
token, right? So we can use response dot body,
but as we know it, we need to encode decode
that data. So we'll have Jason decode
and let's quickly have that.
So we have G Jason decoded pass response dot body,
and then use token on this, which is this. And
it'll save it in our shared preferences and we
can get access to them using this key. And if
you go away, you can see this is future as well.
So we can just await it. And there's no
need to use the bull value that it gives us
saying that, you know, this has been a success or
it has been a failure, no need to worry about it.
After that, we need to use provider and
for provider again, we have to create some
boiler plate code. So we can have
a new folder called providers,
which will first have a user provider or dot file.
So let's create user under
scope provider dot file.
And this user provider dot file will be called
user provider. Let's quickly create that. Then
we have to extend to change notify
because we already know that's how provider works.
I'm not diving deep into it. You can just check
out some tutorials on it. It's pretty simple. Now
we are going to create a private variable of user
where all of the values are going to be zero or
one. So let's have them creator. So we'll have IDs
T stringing name as Mt. Stringing email T
stringing password, AST string, password AST,
add AST type AST token, AST everything empty
After that, since it's a private variable,
where you going to create a GTA
for this. So we have user get user
And then return this private variable and
create a function so that we can update this
user. So we have set user and we have string
user, which we will get. And this is string
mainly because we are going to pass and response
dot body to it. And response dot body is a string.
And here we are going to set user, which is this
private variable equal to user dot from Jason,
which is another function in our user model,
which is this. Basically this is calling from map
and then decoding the data over there and
then passing it to from map. You got the idea
and then we'll pass in the source as
the string user, after saving that,
we just need to notify all the listeners
that our user value has been changed. Please
rebuild. Now we can go over here and have provider
dot of and pass in user provider context.
Then we'll set, listen to fault. Since we
are outside the build function, every
time we're outside, that build function,
we are going to set, listen to false. And
then we are going to call dot set, user,
passing the user, which will be response dot
body. And let's take this provider and put it
just below the share preferences. It's not
anything that would matter, but the thing is,
we are getting the instance. Then we are saving
that data, and then only we are setting that token
And then we just need to navigate to
another screen. So here we can have features
as the home screen and here let's
quickly create a screen. So let's
create a folder for that. We'll have screens
pass in the home screen and the widgets and all
of that will create later on. But for now
let's create basically a stateless widget
called home screen. Actually right now let's
create a state full widget right here itself.
So we have home screen passing the scaffold
and your, as the body are centered text,
which will tell us the token and the user ID E
so well, the actually let's print out the whole
Jason format or the whole user thing itself. So
here we can have final user equal to provider
dot of user provider contact context user, which
is the getter that we created. Now we can take
this user pass in the text, user.to string
so that it can be put in the text widget.
And now I think most probably it'll
just tell us instance of user model.
So what we can have is user two, Jason, that
should give us the right output. Whereas
user two string will just tell us that.
Yeah, it's an instance of the user model.
And that is like, yeah, we already know about it.
Yeah. We are going to use navigator.off
context and actually let's remove that.
So we have navigator dot push name and remove UN
until then we need to pass in the new route name.
So let's quickly give this route name and also
let's rename this. So we have home screen.dot,
and the out name going to be static, constant
string, route name equal to slash home.
And you have to register this route name in
our router dot file. So quickly copy this,
paste it down here. And we have home screen, do
route name and we have to return home screen.
Now we can go there, pass in the route name as
home screen, do route name. I'm not explaining
any of this code because you already return
it multiple times. And it would be a great
time waster just to write this again, game
right after having that, I think it should work.
So let's rerun our application and see
if it's working in the very first try.
All right. So our application has launched, so
let's quickly try to sign in. So we have test 1,
2, 3 other ag mail.com passwords
test 1, 2, 3, click on sign in,
And here we are getting an error. This
happens because you used a bill context
that does not include the provider. You added a
new provider in your main door file. And that's
mainly because in the main door file, we have
not registered our provider. So you're basically,
we need to wrap this my app widget with
a multiprovider widget so that we can
use provider anywhere in our application. And
then it accepts a child and then also a list
of providers because it's multi provider. And
then we need to pass and change notify provider
and then create, we are going to pass in
context and then pass in the user provider.
Also let's quickly get that.
Yep. Our error now should go away even the
warning away. So now quickly restart the app.
Now, if I click on sign in I'll pass and test
1, 2, 3, gmail.com pass in the password. Test 1,
2, 3, click on sign in here. You can
see, we are navigated to another page
and it's showing us ID name,
email, password, token, everything.
Now, for, as of now, there's no need to know, uh,
no way to know that a shared preferences data got
stored or not. But now the next step is going
to do exactly that. We need to get that string
in our main door dot file itself. In this
my app widget, we need to convert this to
a stateless widget state full widget, and
then get that data from shared preferences.
And then based on that, we can put a conditional
logic over here saying if you want to go to the
admin, uh, odd screen, screen, home screen,
whatever. So we are going to do exactly that.
So now let's quickly change this my app to a
stateful widget, because you're going to use
in it state aware, and now let's create an
instance of the class of final or service
or service equal to or service.
Now we can take this or service
and call function on it, which is getting the
user data now before getting the user data, let's
close all the other saved files and
save this one. So before getting all the
user data, let's think what we want
to do. So in our art service dot file,
we want to create a same request because we want
to get the user data to get the user data. We want
to get the user data from the API, right? I mean,
we have to ask, create our own API to get the data
now, before getting the data. We want
to get that token now to get the token,
we are going to use share preferences, get
string methods so that we can get the X
or token that we've already stored. Now that exo
token can be Nu as well because we logged in.
But before logging in and starting
our application, we are going to,
again, run the, get user data function. Now
when that get user data function is run.
There's a possibility that token will be null
because for, for example, when the user signs,
uh, uses the application for the very first time,
and we call the get user data function, because no
matter what we are running this instate function,
right? So whenever we run that in state function,
it is going to get that user
data. And in that user data,
we are using shared preferences dot get string.
Now that string that we save in, for example,
year, we saved in exo token. But if we are using
it for the very first time, that exo token is Nu.
So you want to check if that token is null,
then we want to show that odd screen itself.
Otherwise we want to check if that token is
valid or not, because that token can be altered,
right? It's in the app memory, it can be altered
by hackers or even person who knows about the
phones very well. So you want to check
if that token is valid or not using JWT.
And if that token is valid, then we want to get
the user data. So there's a lot of validations.
So let's create this, let's use this function
just to create another function, to check
or to get user data. So let's
name that only get user data
pass in the bill context, remove required
argument, and also let's require remove
require because there's only one parameter to pass
in. What's the use of the named parameters. Cool,
aware before doing any of this,
let's comment it out for now.
And also let's remove the print statement from
your because print is not good in production code.
Also remove print from your, and let's
avoid the HTTP error handling for now.
So your, we want to, first of all, get shared
preferences. So we have shared preferences
equal to avoid shared preferences dot get
instance. After we get that, we will get
some token. So let's call the string token, which
can be Nu you can see aware because that's what
preferences give to us. So you have preferences
dot, get string yet string. And then we want to
pass in the key that where we have stored. So
it'll be X or token if there is no token, it'll
return Nu if there is token, it'll give us some
data. Now we want to check if that token is Nu.
So if that token is Nu you're going to press
dot set string and passing the key as X
or token and the value as an Mt. String. So
with this, we are basically telling that yeah,
user has used the application for the very
first time, and now it is an Mt. String. Not Nu
after that, we want to check if the token is valid
for or not. So for that, we are going to create an
API. So let's go to our odds file. And we are
going to create this in odd GS, because well,
it is related to authentication task only. Let's
copy this and I would recommend you to not copy
again and again, and type it so that you get used
to that. Centage right. I'm already used to it.
So I'm just copying it again and again. So now the
TRICA block is going to stay the same. We have it
after that, we want nothing from reg dot body
and token will be passed through a header,
not through body. So we have
slash token is valid as the name.
And then we want to remove all the
things that we have aware. So here,
what do you wanna check? First of all, get the
token. So we have token equal to request header,
Pass an X or token.
Then we check if there is no token that is passed
or the token is Nu, then we want to return Jason
and you'll see something great away.
We'll just return false, no object,
nothing with this. It'll just say there's no
token because our post is token is valid or not.
We just want an answer and true our
false. So we are passing in falls away.
Then we want to use JWT dot verify. If the
token is there, then we want to verify that
token. That's exactly what this function is for.
Right? So here we want to pass in the token,
which you ever received from the header. And
then you can see the secret or the public key,
which we signed it with. You can see this is the
secret or the public key. So we can just use that
after that we will check if it is verified or not.
So your, we can store it in a variable. So we have
constant verified or is verified. You can, uh,
take the variable names on your own. So if it is
not verified, then again, we have to return
dress dot Jason as false. Correct. Now, if
the user token is verified, then we want to check
if the user is available or not, because I mean,
the token can be valid. But what if that token
is just a random token that turns out to be
correct? So we want to check if that user also
exists or not. So we wanna check constant user
equal to innovate user dot find, and we always use
find one tele, there are many more options. You
can just see it in auto search. Find, find one,
find by ID, find by ID and delete and all of those
functions. But we are going to use find by ID
because we don't want to delete anything, right?
We just want to get that data now to find by ID.
We are not getting ID from request or body, and we
are getting ID because we have signed that with
the user. So after using verify, we are getting
access to that ID property that we are stored
in it. You can see JWT, it signs with that ID.
So now we are getting that verified object.
And on that object, we are using.id property.
Now, if that user doesn't exist again,
we are going to return race, Jason falls.
And finally, if all of these conditions pass
in, then we are going to pass in rest. Jason.
True, great. So this is our function for token is
valid and we've created an API now. So here we are
going to have a wait HTTP post again, then we need
to pass in the URL. So that will be dot pass, pass
in the URL, which will be dollar sign then slash
token is valid or not. And we're not testing this
API in thunder client, mainly because we will have
to get this token and pass through the header.
Instead, let's do it right here itself. If there's
any error, we are going to see that error only,
but in case you want to do it, there's absolutely
no problem with that. You should definitely do it.
So with this, we are going to get the token
rest. So if we put both as rest response,
it will be very confusing. So let's
name it specifically. And now,
as we told, we have to pass in on header. So
we have head earth and headers will consist of
String, comma string.
And as I told before, multiple times, we, whenever
we use pass header, we have to pass this content
type, make sure to do that because we are using
express or Jason. And now along with that,
we will pass an X or token. This is the name we're
going to give as well as the name of the shared
preferences. Key, both are the same thing. And
then we need to pass in the token that we got AR
and now we have already checked if token is
Nu. So we can just pass in that the token
is not Nu. Now we are going to get that
response. So now we will have our response
and then we will just use response
dot body. So we have token response
body. This is the actual response. So we have
Jason decode passing the token response dot body
so that we can use some objects on this
response, right? So you, this response
is going to provide us with true of false,
because that's what we have supplied away. True,
false, false, false like this. So we are
checking if response is equal to true,
Then we want to do a wait and get the user data.
So yeah, we need to create a API to get the user
data, to get the user data. Let's create another
API called get user data. So here, what we are
going to do is router dot get pass slash, then
we'll pass in oath. And this is the middleware
that we now need to create. This middleware
will keep, make sure that you are authorized.
That means you only have the capability to
access this route if you are signed in. So
now let's create this middleware. So you, you have
server and we are going to call this middlewares
And your first middleware is going to be S
something similar to this. We, we will have
another middleware called admin because
we want the similar thing to happen with
admin also, right? Admin protected routes
should be there. And similar to that,
we have oath protected route. So here
we are going to get JWT equal to require
Jason web token. Basically we will pass in the
token and we need to verify that token just like
we did before. So yeah, we are going to create
a function. This is not going to be a route.
So you'll have asynchronous request re
next, and next is similar to, you know,
continue on with the next route because we are
going to pass it in as a ware. When we reach,
when we use next, I'll explain it to you. Then
we have a try and catch block. So we have try
catch pass in the error and then pass in re status
500 Jason pass in the error as error message.
Then use this tri block to have constant token
equal to request dot header. Because every time
now, onwards, whenever we use authentication,
basically to fetch products, to, you know, save
it in card, we are going to use this middleware.
So we are gonna pass it in as a header, which is
the best thing to do. So we have Xu token,
and then we are checking. If there's no token,
then we want to return some data.
So we have return rest status
4 0 1. And this is 4 0 1 because this stands for
unauthorized. So if you go to the website again,
you can see we have 4, 0 1 unauthorized. Although
the HTTP standard specifies una authorized
semantically, this response means unauthenticated.
And now we will pass in adjacent saying
that the message is no author token
access denied. That means that the user
has not passed only token what to do now,
and now we will have verified. So let's
go to our author JS and copy this,
paste it over here. And we will verify this token.
We are getting from your pass in the password key,
and then we want to return rest dot status photo.
Oh one again, because it's not on because it is
not authorized. And then person Jason,
which will be message as token verification
failed authorization denied. Great. Now, after
this, what do we need to do? This is gonna be a
very important step. So make, keep, make sure
to keep a note of this. So here we will have
request dot user. Now we are adding a new object
to this request, which is user, and we are saving
something to it, which is equal to verified.id.
Now, every time we can't pass in the body,
every time we can't pass in the body, the user's
ID, right? So now what are we doing is adding this
middleware so that here we can perform all
the validations, if it's valid or not. And
if it is valid, then we are storing user ID in
request dot user. So whenever we created create
some authenticated route like this one, where we
add the middleware, as we can use rec dot user,
like we are direct dot header. Now, if
I add author, I can add rec dot user,
and that will fetch the user's ID to me. Great.
Now we can have rec dot token equal to token,
and in the same fashion, we can access the token
as well, because these are the two things that
are given away. And we need to use that later
on, somewhere in our application, after that
we can call this next callback function.
This next, if you don't specify will not
go to the next API route. For example,
now here we have request response,
and this is where to be asynchronous, obviously.
So here, basically, if you don't call next,
it'll make sure that yeah, it authenticated
this, but it won't run this callback function
next basically means that it can call the next
callback function. So let me quickly add that and
thus, we can follow along so we can just
check constant user equal to innovate
user dot, find by ID. And now the ID we know is
rec dot user. If you don't trust me well enough,
you can just print this out and see to print.
You can always use console.blog. After that, we
are just going to send this lab.dot user doco doc.
As I mentioned before we UI, we are using doco doc
and then pass in the token, which will be request
dot token. Now we should be able to get the user
data so we can go to the odd service and get
the user data. So here we can have eight HTTP
dot get pass in the URL, which will be dot par.
And the is simply dollar, sorry, like this dollar
and pass in with a slash don't forget this slash
because URI is nothing with the slash. We've
already talked about it pretty much every time
and also pass in the parent thesis. After that,
we will save this in response. So we
will call this response HTTP response.
Actually let's call this user response. HTTP
response is pretty lame. And then obviously we are
using get, but we also need to pass in headers and
headers is going to be something similar to this.
So we can just copy this and pass it in over here
and token, this exclamation mark is not needed
because here we have already told that token
can never be Nu that's. Our smart flatter is.
So now we can take this user provider. So we have
variable user provider equal to provider dot of
user provider person in the context set, listen to
falls, and then say, user provider set user. Now,
instead of doing that, you could have obviously
used user provider set user. It doesn't matter.
Pretty sure I did this because it gave me some
errors back then, but it won't give anything
to you. Then we can just pass and user rest dot
body to set the user appropriately. And that's
all that we need. So let's remove this error
handling part. Let's restart our application.
And actually this is not working because we
need to get the, we have to bind this to our
UI. So we'll have to run all service dot, get
user data cost in the context. And after having
that get user data done in the home part, what
we can have is provider dot of user provider
Context, and let's have that. So
we'll have context.user.token.is
not empty. So if the token is not empty,
that means that we have saved some token.
And that means we can go to the bottom bar so we
can have constant home screen. And if the token
is empty, that means we can go to the odd screen
saving this much. We can restart our application.
So app has lowered up, but there's one
problem where you can see in our server,
we are getting this error or router dot get, and O
is not defined. So basically in our a yes, we need
to go wire and use O but we can't use O because
we need to export it. So we can module dot exports
equal to this. A, now we can use this a
by importing it so quickly, import it and
save this much. So wrap started.
So let's restart our application
and now we are on the home screen directly.
And again, if I restart the application,
let's go to our diva console.
UNC. If I restart the application,
we are still on this page. That means a state
persistence has also worked. Now we can start
working on better things. So now we let's
create this bottom navigation bar so that we can
navigate better. We navigate between the homepage,
the product page, or, you know, the profile page
account page, and then finally the card page.
Great. No, now let's just create a bottom bar
so that we can navigate. So you're in the
widgets. I'm going to create bottom bar
and you're not creating any specific
feature for it because it's a bottom
bar and it'll be used everywhere.
Basically in that application.
After that, we're going to create it as
a stateful widget and call it bottom bar.
Now this will have a route name because we
are going to navigate to this bottom bar
whenever we are on the hot, hot screen, and then
we need to navigate. So this is the bottom bar
that we're going to use. And then we are going
to call it a route name and set it equal to let's
say, actual home, because earlier it wasn't home.
And this is going to be actual home. After that,
we can come away and return a scaffold, which will
have a body, which we will figure out later on
because this body is going to be based on what
bottom bar item we are on. And now let's create
the bottom navigation bar. So let's remove the
body so that we can focus on the UI part. Now,
so here we are bottom navigation bar. Then
we are gonna pass in the current index.
And the current index is going to be end page
equal to zero. This will keep track of the
current index and we will change this value.
Whenever we want to change the current index,
then we need to pass and selected item color.
So whenever an item is clicked on what should
it for should its color be. So we are in to pass
in selected navbar color, which is present in our
global variables file and whatever we copied
earlier, then we need unselected item color,
and that will be global variables dot unselected.
Navbar. After that, we are going to have a
background color, which will be global variables
dot background color, and then an I can size,
which will be 28. All of this is tried and tested,
you know? So in case you're wondering how I got
those values. I just put up some random
values and got that I can size after that.
We are gonna have a bottom navigation bar item and
person an I can as a container, not an I can just,
but a container because we want a, we want
a green line to appear at the top, right?
That's why a container. Then we will pass in
a width and we will create width at the top.
So that in case we want change it any time
we can just change it to wire because bottom
navigation bar or the containers, width
is going to stay the same for every, every
bottom navigation bar item. So I'm going to
pass in double bottom navigation bar width.
So let's say bottom bar width and set it equal
to 42. Let's grab this and paste it over here.
Then we are going to have decoration so
that we can add that decoration, right?
So we are going to have a border and border will
be from the top. So yeah, border top border side,
And we'll pass in the color and this color is
going to depend on the page we are on, right? So
if this is the zero element, so if we are on the
zero element, that means this is a selected item.
So if this is a selected item, we want to show the
green or the teal color on the top. So what I'm
going to check if it's pay, if page is equal to
zero, then global variables selected navbar color.
Otherwise we can just have the background color so
that it mixes in. So we have global variables dot
background color. After that let's specify some
width. Otherwise it'll be too small. So let's do
it at the top again, because this as well is going
to be used in every bottom navigation bar item.
So we'll call this, let's say bottom bar
border with, and we'll set it to five.
Then let's take it from here, pass it over here
and save this much. And then the container is
going to have a child obviously so that
we can pass in the I icon. So it'll be
just an I icon of home. So we have I icons dot
home underscore outlined. Now, copy this much
and paste it again. But before pasting
it, actually we need to add label.
It's actually a required field. So if you
don't pass it in, it'll give you an error.
So make sure to add it. So we have to pass in over
here as well label, which will be an empty spring,
and we need one more navigation bar item. So
let's put in a third one and quickly let's
change their value. So we are in the third one.
We have third one. We look after in a while, but
the second one will have person outlined outlined.
Then if page is equal to one, then we want this
and this looks great. Now about the third one,
it's going to be the card one, right? So this
is for the card. This is for the account or
profile, and this is going to be the homepage.
So let's save this much and see what
we're getting. We're not seeing anything
mainly because we have not used bottom bar
anywhere. So let's go to the main door dot file
and pass in bottom bar instead of the
home screen and make sure to use that
home screen.dot let's remove that unused
import, save this much again, go to the
auto service dot file so that whenever
we are navigating to the next screen.
So yeah, we have it. Yeah. We are going to pass
in bottom bar route name and it's not registered,
so we need to register it. But before that, I
think, yeah, this looks great. So now let's go
to our router file and register the bottom bar.
So your, we will piece this much, have bottom bar,
route name and pass the bottom bar.
Okay. Now let's try to restart our
application and see what you're getting here.
You can see we're getting an error and this error
is because we have probably missed label putting
labels somewhere. That's what I was telling you.
And that's probably in the last one. So let's
add it away, saving this much. Let's restart our
application and you can see this is showing up.
And there's one takeaway that's because we have
not changed this. So let's change this for two
and here we have it. Sweet. So now we need to work
on the cart feature. Now cart icon is going to be
a bit different from other one, because
we are going to use a package for this.
And the package we are going to use is badge
so that we can add the number on the top. So
if we have a cart here, we can add a number of how
many items have already been added. So for that,
we are going to use this package.
Let's copy this badges. And it's a
pretty simple usage. Just add this to
your pop spec and we can use that. So
I'm just going to use dot, add dependency,
pass in badges and stop our app execution.
After this pub get is run. I think I can restart
our application and then write the code for it.
So you're run without debugging. And now
in the child, let's wrap this. I icon with
a widget known as badge, which
will be from the badges package.
And now the elevation is going to be set to
zero because we don't any other, you know,
uh, popping out thing. We just want it to stay
along with the, I can, then we are going to have
badge content and this content is going to depend
on the card. But when we add card, we look into it
for now. We will just have a text, a constant
text, actually, which will just say a number
which will be two for some reason. And then we
will have badge color, which will be colors white.
Then we have a child and that's all that we
need. So let's save this much restart and see
what we're getting. You can see two showing up.
Also let's change this to shopping cart outline
Great. Now, here we have, it looks great. Now
the next thing is, whenever we click on any of
the icons, we want this thing to navigate
away and the correct content to show up.
So you, we are, we are, we have to add a packet or
we have to add a property for that, which will
be on tap. So whenever any item is tapped,
what do we need to do? Well, we can create a
function right at the top called update page.
We will get a page and then we are going to
set the state. And the global variable page
will be equal to the page from the parameter.
Pretty simple. Now we can take this update page
pass into over and looks it. Now, whenever
I click away, you can see this is shifting
great. Now the next thing is to correct
to correctly, show the information. So
here we are going to basically have a list
of widget of pages, which will be equal to
multiple widgets that we are going to create
for now. We are gonna have a constant centered
child text saying what this page
is for. Now. We have account page,
But above that, we are going to have our
homepage and we have already created homepage.
So no need to pass in, you know, the
centered text, but for card screen and for
account screen, we are going to have this so we
can pass in account. Let's say card page also
great. Now let's take this pages in the
body. We are going to pass in this pages
because it's a list and we are going access.
And the body is going to be the widget at the
particular index, which we are continuously
changing, which is this page over here.
Now save this much. And here you can
see, we are getting the home screen,
your, the account page, and finally the card page.
Now let's design the account page. First of all,
then we can design the home screen. So now let's
quickly close all of these save files and you,
we are going to create a new feature. Let's close
the home and odd screen, and you create a new
feature called account. This account is again
going to ask screens and widgets. We'll create
services later on when we need it, but for now
we need screens and widgets. So your first thing
we're going have is an account screen.dot file.
Let's import material dot. Let's create a state
full widget. Actually let's try a stateless
here. Then we'll call it account screen. We
are going to return a scaffold and the app bar is
going to be preferred size because here we have,
this is the app bar that we need to create. So
now we are going to use preferred size for that,
and then passing the preferred size that we want.
So we want a size that will be from the height 50.
After that, we need to have a child which
will be an app bar, and we need to pass in
a flexible space. The reason for flexible space
is that we need to have a linear gradient away,
but app bar doesn't have a property to add a
linear gradient. So we need to use flexible
space using which we can specify a widget, which
will have a linear gradient, and that would create
that design. So let's quickly look at it. So
we have box decoration, passing the gradient as
global variables.app bar gradient. Great. So now
let's take this account screen, go to the bottom
bar dot file and replace this center text with the
actual account screen that we have just creator.
So now let's look at it. We
need to restart it probably.
So here we have the app bar showing
up. Now let's design this app bar.
So in the title, we are going to have a row
because we need two things away, right? This
is the Amazon logo, the bell I and the SOI. So
this is going to be considered as one, and this
is going to be considered as another element.
So first of all, let's have a container which
will have an alignment of alignment or top left.
Then we need to have a child and the child is
going to be the Amazon logo. Now to get the logo,
what you can do is go to the assets folder
on my, get a repository, go to images
and download all of them because you're going to
need all of them. I already have them installed.
I'll put it in. So what I'm going to do is in
the root of the folder, we are going to create
an assets folder. Let's rename this. I don't think
I can type it properly, but yeah, we have assets.
And then we are going to pass in an images folder
and then copy this images, folders, content away
after you've installed, you can just take them
and paste it over here. Yeah, we have it. Now we
need to go to the prospect, do file and add that
assets. So we have assets slash images and we are
not going to manually specify all the images.
So put, uh, slash away here so that it can
take in all, everything that is provided over
in this folder. After that we can close it,
restart our application and pass it in. So here
we are going to have image dot asset pass in
assets slash images slash Amazon N PNG. That's the
name of a file. And here we are getting an error,
mainly because we have not passed in children
for the row. So we are going to pass in children.
And then in the container, we are going to pass
in the children. We are gonna pass this container.
Now, after that, we are going to have a width
of one 20 height of 45. And the color is going
to be colors, not black because by default, it'll
take it as a white color after saving this much.
I think our app fail. That's why
we have our own table to see it.
Now let's restart the app and see what you're
getting. All right. So our app has loaded up.
Let me close the file. Full file manager. And you,
we have it Amazon end showing up. Sweet. So now
we need to create another container, which will
have a rope, because as I said, these are two,
the two elements are together. So first of
all, let's give some PAing. So we have constant
insert dot only from the left. We are gonna
have 15 from the right. We are gonna have 15.
Great. Now we are gonna have a child
which will be a row. And in that row,
we're going have children, which will all be
constant because it is just Ikes that we're
going to display, uh, bell Ike and search
Ike. So yeah, we are going pass in padding,
pass in the padding as sets
dot only from the right side
15. And then we want a child of Ike and the
ICAN will be Ikes dot notification outline.
And let's save this much. You can see, we
are getting this I icon great. Now we can
copy this. I can and paste it 10
again. So we have Ikes dot search
After saving this much. You can see this
showing up again. Now all of them are
together. So basically what we've done is this is
one element. This is another element. Now we have
put them both of them in a row. So now to make
them go apart, what we can do is in the parent
row, the first, most row we can pass in a property
of space evenly. So here, what we can do is go
at the top and have main access alignment
as main access, alignment.space, evenly,
and actually not space evenly, but space between,
and here you can see it's showing up. Great.
Now we have the app. Now the next thing is to
work on this part, which is saying the hello
plus the name of the user. So for that, we are
going to, first of all, minimize this app bar.
Then we are going to pass in a body because
this is a scaffold and the body will consist
of a column, which will be a column of constant
widgets, because everything that you're going
to pass in your is going to be in the widgets
folder so that it doesn't get crowded away.
And there's no unnecessary rebuilds
as well. So here we're going to have
underscore app bar under got that. This is the
name of a file. I couldn't think of anything else.
So you are importing material, data,
creating a stateless widget, calling it below
app bar, and then returning a container which
will have a decoration of constant box decoration.
So we're gonna have a gradient which will
be global variables dot a bar gradient.
After that, we are going have a padding of
constant insert dot only from the left. We
are going to have 10 from the right. We are going
to have 10. And from bottom, we are going have 10
and let's just name it properly. So we have child
passing the row and we have a row mainly because,
well, it's hello, admin. Now we are going to have
a rich text. And rich text is mainly because,
so that we can have two, you know, text in
one line, you could use a role for that. But
I think that rich text is also a great option
for that. So yeah, we are gonna have a text span
where we are going to have a text saying, hello,
and we are going to leave a space where, so
that, you know, there's a space where like this.
So yeah, we are gonna have
a style of constant textile
Passing the phone size as 22
and color as colors, draw black.
After this much, I think we can have children.
And this children is again gonna consist of
all the text spans so we can just copy
this text van, please it away. And we
need to pass in the user's name and we have
access to user's name using a provider.
So why not user? So we have final user
equal to provider dot of user provider
context user. Now take this user pass
in over here. So we have user.name
And yep. We have it. So let's pass in a parent
thesis that we've missed and pass in the below
app bar over here. Let's see how it's looking
here. You can see hello, Revan showing up. So now,
if there is something like this, just to resolve
this error, what we can do is go to the app bar,
pass it, pass in a row over here. So we have
wrap it with a row and let's save this much
and you can see it extends further three.
Otherwise you could have just used container
and given in the Medoc query dot context dot size
dot width. And that should have worked as well.
After that. The next thing we want to wear is
these buttons. So let's pass in a size box of
height 10 and we've passed in cons convey. So
there's no need of passing in cons again and
again. So yeah, there is some spacing as well. Now
we want to create this layout. So first of all,
let's create a widget known as top
Buttons.dot
Let's, import material dot. And then we want a
state full widget and we are gonna call it top
buttons. And then we are gonna return a column
because you can see they're all in a column. And
in that column, we are going to have row two row
just to demonstrate it to you. We have a column,
this is a column. And in that column we have
a row. And then again, we have another row
pretty simple. So let's quickly create that.
So we have return a column and children,
so let's pass it a row which will be children
and will consist of these buttons. Now you can
see these buttons are being excessively used in
this place. So we can create a separate widget
for that, which will be reusable. So we have
account button do file let's import material dot,
call it a stateless widget, and then call
it account button. And then over your,
we are going to return a container with margin
of constant engine sets dot only left 10
symmetric, sorry. And from horizontal, we're going
to have 10. That, that means from the left hand,
from the right, we are gonna have 10 and we have
height 40. Then decoration will be box decoration
Where the border is border dot. All
color will be color stored white,
and there is no width at all. That means there
is no border at all. Let's go where you can see
Now we need the border radius. So we have
border radius of border radius dot circular
50. Now, in case you're wondering that we can
see some border away, but away we are setting
the border with a zero. You'll realize later
on when we use, uh, the button, because the
button we're going to use is outlined button
so that it can give us a nice clean outline.
We are just setting the border radius
away. And if we set the border radius,
there is going to be an automatic border applied,
which we are removing aware. And then we want a
color of colors dot white. After that we are gonna
have a child which will be an outlined button.
So the child aware is going to be a text
and the text will be whatever we get from
the constructor. So let's have final string
text and require this from the constructor.
Then pass it in over a, your then the style is
going to be a constant textile where the color
is going to be colors.black and font. Weight
is going to be font, weight dot normal.
Now this is an outline button.
So we need an on tap also.
So whenever we click on that, what should happen?
So we want that from the structor as well.
Let's call this on press.
So let's create it from the construction
as well. So we have final void call back on
Tap, required it from the constructor. So we
have on tap and here are in the on press person,
the on tab. Great. Now let's use this account
button and see how we need to style this account
button moving forward. So the very first button
that we have is your orders. So yeah, your orders.
And when we click on it, nothing is going to
happen. As of now, also we need to pass in top
buttons away just to see any input or output.
Sorry, here we see it. Your orders looks great.
Now let's add a bit of, you know, curve to it.
So in the account button, we are going to have a
style which will be elevated button, not style
from so it'll capture elevated button style.
And the primary color that it's going to
have is colors.black, 12 dot with opacity
0.03. This is just a tested value.
But in case you don't add opacity,
it'll look very good, very bad. And
this is this color that we can see.
And we add a border radius,
obviously. So let's copy this line,
paste it over here. And before
that, we need to specify the shape
in which we can specify the border radius.
So we have rounded, rectangular border,
and there we can specify the border radius. So we
have border radius. <inaudible> over here, suite.
Now, V this looks great. Now let's just increase
it size. So to increase it size, what we can do is
wrap this container with an expanded widget so
that it can take all the available space. You can
see it takes everything. Now, if we add another
account button, it'll diminish its size. So we can
have another button that says, let's see what we
have tell seller. So we can pass in turn seller.
You can see they all, they both taken the maximum
space. They can get after creating this row,
we need to create another row for logout and your
wishlist. So we can just, you know, copy this row,
paste it down your, and before pasting it, we
need to paste it out. So we have constant sized
box of height. Then now we have
log out. So we will pass in,
log out, and then we need to pass
in a text. That will be your wish
list. Sweet. So yeah, we have, it looks awesome.
Now, one thing that I noticed in this app bar,
the below app bar part, we are not bolded this,
so what we need to do is go to the below app bar
dot file and your in the user.name, we have all
this and extra thing that we need font way bold.
And if we save this much, it becomes too
bolded. We don't want that. So let's pass
in w 600. All right, this looks great. So after
restarting this and creating these buttons,
the next thing we need is, again, a sized box
after which we can have the list of orders.
So what I'm going to do is space it out even
more. You can see there's a lot more space
there. And now we are going to create a new widget
called orders. So that will be orders dot, dot.
Yeah, we are gonna import material. Let's quickly
import that. Then we need to create a stateful
visit because we are going to Fe the orders that
the user has made. And we are going create an
API for that for, so we know that in future,
it's going be a stateful visit so we can just
create it right now. So now we have column, and
then in the column, we need to return children.
Now, the very first child that it's going to
have is going to be well, this part, which is
this part, which is a column, and then we need
a list view builder so that we can build all
of these products. So these are the two things
that we need. So let's quickly work on them.
So we have row passing the children. And
the very first child is a container saying,
actually we need some padding. So we have
constant sets dot only from the left.
We need a padding of 15. Then we need a child
which will be of the constant text saying your
orders. Then we need a style of textile
and the textile will be font size as 18
Color as colors black. And I don't think we need
to mention that. So here we have the color and
we'll pass in colors black. And I don't think
we need that. So let's just remove that and see
if we need that or not later on. So we'll pass
in the font, wave, wait as font, weight dot w
600. And with this much, let's take the orders and
put it in the account screen. So we have orders
go to this and you can see your orders showing
up suite. Now we need, let's put trailing coms.
Now we need to pass in another container. So let's
copy this container, paste it again. And we have
C all. And one other thing is that we don't
need it from the left anymore. We need it from
the right, because it's a, it's in the top,
right? So yeah, we're going to have a color
and the color is going to be global variables
dot let's import it. So we have global variables
dot selected navbar color. Let's remove this
constant from your, and yeah, let's go VRC.
Let's put this as a small, and
now let's space between these two
row elements. So we have main access alignment
as main access, alignment, or space between
your, we can see it looks great. After
that, we need a list view builder to
display our a product. So let's create a
common display products or order, sorry.
So here we are gonna have a fixed size of
container. And it's very important to mention this
height. If you don't mention this height, it's
going to give you a render box flow error. You can
pass in, you know, expanded widget, but it'll take
in all available space and it won't look good.
Also, we need to create this outside of the
row. So let's copy this, paste it outside the
row in the column or trailing commas. So
you, you can see they're all in line now.
So now very first thing is padding. So
we have constant agent sets dot only
from the left. We have 10 from the top,
we have 20 and from the right zero,
because it's going to be very scrollable. After
that, we have a child with list view builder.
And for now we are going to pass in constant index
And create it like this.
And yeah, we are going to return under return
the product that we're going to create. But
before doing that, but earlier we need to pass
in an item count, which will be three, let's say,
and year to return, or to view something just for
design. We have to create a manual list. So, you
know, just a temporary list that we are creating.
So here, what we can have is list, which will
be called list. Let's say it's which temporary,
so we can name it, anything. So
here, what we need to pass in is,
well, first of all, the image, so we have image
and the image is going to be anything that you can
find out what I'm going to pass in as the image is
from unsplash.com. So you can just go over there
and search one thing. So I'm just going to
take this copy image address based it in over
after that, we are going to have the products,
actually, that's all that we need. So
let's remove it for our, for our application
for now. You know, we are just going to have
images because here, if you see, we are
just display the images of the product.
So let's copy this paste, it paste it, paste
it. Let's say four times, we can take this list,
Pass it in a way. So we have list dotting,
and then we are going to return a product
now to return a product. What we are going to
return is a widget. So let's create a single
product.do. And this is going to be a very,
very useful widget. It's going to be reusable
everywhere in our application. So we're going
have import material dot a stateless widget,
and it's going to be called single product.
This will be used even in the admin side,
even in, you know, everything basically. So we
have to pass in a padding, which will be cons
edge, insert dot symmetric, and
from horizontal direction five,
then we need a child as a decorated box
so that we can just create, you know,
A decoration. We don't need a container
for that. So we can just pass in decoration
as box decoration. So we can
have border as border dot,
all pass in the color as colors.black
valves and width as 1.5. If you come back,
if you come back away, you can see that the
border over here is like this. So we need
colors.black dwells and colors. Black dwell is
going be a very useful color for us because it's
going to add act as a separator everywhere. Now,
after that, we are going to have a border radius,
which will be border radius dot circular five,
and then the color will be colors dot white.
Then we need a child which will be a
container. And then the width will be 180.
Padding will be constant sets dot all 10. You can
see there's, PAing everywhere over here so that
it looks neater and cleaner. And then the child is
going to be an image.network. And then we need to
pass in the image. Now we'll get the image from
the constructor. So we have final string image.
Now we can click on this. Well,
I can generate a construction,
Then pass in the image over here.
And the fit is going to be box fit,
Dot height, fit height. So it'll fit according
to the maximum height that the image can take.
It doesn't care about rest of the things
then we can have with as 180 passed in,
it are taken the same with
as the entire container.
Now we can go there and return a single product.
Now it requires an image. The image will be list
at index and that's all right, because it is a
list of string. If you go back there, you can see
it's a list of string. That's all that we need to
do later on. Then when we create our own API and,
you know, create some stuff, then you will realize
how different this will get. So here we have it,
your orders. So now, instead of having this as
a vertical thing, what we can have is scroll
direction as access dot horizontal. Because right
now you can see it's vertical. That's why rest of
the things are not even visible because it's
vertical. So, and the height is one 70. Now,
if we save this much, you can see it is visible
to us now. And it looks pretty good. So our
design for this screen is also completed.
Now, the next thing we want to want to work on
is the homepage UI. So let's create that quickly.
So now let's close the terminal and all the saved
files. Now, what do we need to do? Well, close
this account page. Let's go to the home screen,
do dot again and create a widgets folder now
because we wanna create widgets. And it's
that UI that we're creating. Now, let's quickly
look what we want. This is the thing that we are
going to create. So first of all, we need an app
bar. So let's quickly create that, right? So now
in the scaffold, we are going to have an app bar
again, the preferred size. So what I'm going to do
is go into the accounts screen now to the account
screen, not account button, sorry. We are gonna go
in the account screen, copy this app bar widget.
And then again, close this much, come over and
put in the app bar. Now, obviously we need
to make some changes over, but before that
let's import app bar Gradon. Now the
title is going to completely defer.
We can see in the title, we have this a bar
and the mic Ike. So now what I want to do is
instead of returning this container, what I'm
going to do is wrap it with an expanded widget
and remove this alignment. We don't need
that instead. We will give it a height of 42,
then a margin. That's why we are using a
container. Otherwise we would've used a sized box.
And then we have only from the left, we
wanna give 15, you can see in the picture,
let me quickly go there. There's some
margin aware. That's what we are doing
after that in the child, we want to wrap
it with a widget that is called material.
We don't have any image over. So you gonna have
a material. And this materials purpose is just to
give some elevation and some water radius. So we
have water radius dot circulars is circular seven.
We could have wrapped with container and give
it it, given it a border radius over. But since
we want some elevations, because you can see
this pops out and thus the elevation is going
to be one. And then we want a child because
we are going to have a text form field past.
Now we could have used the custom text field,
but you can see that the design defers. So we are
gonna create the text form field manually away.
Then we need a decoration. The decoration will be
input decoration. Then the prefix icon is going to
be an inkwell widget because when we click on it,
you know, it gives us kind of a splash effect.
That's why, so we're gonna have an on tap property
past over a year. Then we need a child
which will be a constant padding.
Then the padding is going to be and sets
dot only. And from the left, we want six
let's quickly go there. So we have a left task
six and then the child away is going to be an,
I can saying I cans dot search. The color will
be colors.black, and the size is going to be 23.
Great. Now let's go there. You can see
our funny text form field showing up,
but there's more of an error because we
have this container. So let's remove that.
And here we have it. Now let's design
this to look something like this. So
the very first thing that we do is in the
text form fields input, decoration itself
over here, I guess. So we have filled past in
as true. The fill color is colors dot white.
The content padding is cons agency's dot only. And
from the top, we want 10. After that, we are going
to have a border and the border is going to be
constant outline input border. And then we want
to give this again, a border radius of circular
seven. So let's just copy this, paste it in away.
And actually I made a mistake. We want to pass
in border radius dot all, and then the radius
dot circular seven. Now we can remove this much.
Then we need border side as border side dot none.
Let's see this much. Then we need an enabled
border. So let's pass in an enabled border
and this will be similar to this border.
So I will just, you know, copy all of this
and pass it. Actually, we need to copy this,
pass it in. And the border radius is going to be
border side of color, colors.black
38. And the width is going to be one.
Now, since this is constant, it is giving us an
error. So let's remove this pass in the constant
array and passing in colors, draw black 38
And passing in constant again because we made
an error. Cool. So if you come aware, this looks
something like this. If you click on this, you can
see there's some effect due to which it becomes
flat. Otherwise it's elevated. Let's restart this.
You can see again, there's some border, but if
you click on this, it comes back to normal. That's
exactly what we want. Now. Finally, we want to
pass in a hint text. So let's pass in the hint
and we need to pass it in the input decoration.
And here we are going to pass in search Amazon
dot end, save this much. Now this doesn't matching
with this. So we need to pass in the textile. So
we have hint style pass in the constant textile.
And then the font weight is font, weight dot w 500
pass in the font size as 17. And that's
all that we need. So let's save this much.
Yeah, we have it. When we
look at it, it looks great.
Now we just need a mic icon. So we can quickly
create that since we are in a row. So what we
can do is over here, have a container saying color
as colors dot transparent, then we need a high 42
then margin of constant sets, dot inserts dot
symmetric in the horizontal direction we need 10
And the child is going to have a mic, right?
So we have constant ICAN as I icons dot mic
color as colors.black, and
the size is going to be 25.
If we go back away. Now this is matching
with this. Let's restart the application.
You can see it is matching, but still it's not
clearly matching. And the reason is because
you can see there is some spacing over which
your, sorry, there's some spacing over here,
but there's no spacing over here. That means our
a bar size is a small bit smaller. So we can just
change this to 60. Now, this looks super good. I
am pretty satisfied with it. So now we can work on
this address box part. So now what are we going to
do? Well, first of all, just minimize the sad bar.
It takes in a lot of space and in the body, we are
going to have a column which will have children.
And then the first child that we have is an
address box. So let's create that address box
in a separate widget. So we have import
material dot, a stateless widget of address
Box. So yeah, we are going to have a container of
height 40 then decoration. And this is not going
to have the same linear gradient as this. You
can see it away. We have this linear gradient,
but this linear gradient differs from this. So
we're going to manually create it. So we have
constant box decoration and the gradient is linear
gradient pass in the colors. So the colors are
colored or from AGB, which stand for alpha
red, green, blue. And then we can pass in 2 55,
1 4 to 2, 2, 6, and 2, 2, 1. Then we can copy
this past it away. And your a is again 2 55, but
R is 1 62. This is 2 26. So let's change
it to 2 36. And this will be 2 33.
Let's take this address box,
paste it in over a year and
save it. Let's put some trailing comma so that we
can format the document. You can see it's giving
us a color similar to this pretty cool
<affirmative>.
Now we need some stops. So we have stops as
0.5 to 1.0. Yep. Again, looks pretty cool.
And after that, obviously we need a draw so
that we can include this icon, then this text.
And then again, the second, so let's go
there, have a child as raw. Then the children
also, you, we are going have a padding of constant
sets dot only from the left. We are have 10.
So the row is going to be a constant. I
icon as Ikes dot location underscore on
underscore outline. Then we have a high size
of 20, and also let's put a comma way here.
Let's put some comma so that we can form
other document. And here you can see,
we have the I icon showing up with some
pattern. Now we need to create a text. Now
the problem with this text is, first of all, it
can overflow. You can see whenever it overflows,
meaning the address is too long because usually
the address is going to be too long. So,
so in that case, what we are doing is making
sure there's dot and that is done using a
property known as text overflow dot SIS, but
we also need to make sure that we get as much
space as we require for this. So we'll have to
wrap it with a expanded widget and then only
we can use SIS so that it gives us this dot
format. So let's do it. So we have expanded,
The child will be padding and the padding will
be constant edge, insert dot only from left five.
Then the child will be a text and we
are not in the children again of the
row. So let's go over there, pass in the
trailing com. And here we have the text.
Now the text is going to be well delivery to the
name of the user, uh, hyphen, then the address of
the user. So let's quickly write it. So we have
delivery to, and we use string interpolation,
user.name, and let's use user's name.
So we have final user equal to provider
Dot of user provider, context dot user. This is
nothing new. That's why I'm going quickly aware.
Then we can pass in the, uh, dash and then we can
pass in user address. And users wrote address can
never be Nu because we are passing it as an empty
string. And even if it is Nu, at some point,
we have some, uh, work done so that it always
shows us an empty string. So here, if you go,
you can see there's nothing showing up and you
won't be able to see the magic of this expanded
widget and then the texture overflow. But you, you
need to trust me on this. When we just pass in the
address, you will be able to see. So now constant
textile will be font, weight, font, weight dot w
500 pass in the overflow. And overflow is
text overflow. SIS SIS stands for those dots.
Fade star is when you know, the
starts, the text just fades away,
but we want SIS because that's a
better user experience. In my opinion,
after this expander wet, finally, you
will see this dropdown icon so we can
create that. So we have constant padding
and the padding is going to beset dot only
from the left. We have five from the top. We
have two, let's see this much. And in the child,
we have ICAN as I icons dot arrow drop
down outlined, then the size will be 18
and yep, we have it. You can see it's looking
pretty cool. Now, since this is expanded, you
can see the I icon is mentioned earlier when the
address comes in, this will look less awful. And
the way the address is going to work is we are not
going to ask for the, ask the user for any address
in the starting itself. What we are going
to do is whenever the user clicks on this
ad to card goes to the order page. And then
for the first time, when he enters their,
uh, you know, the address we are
going to save it in our database.
And then we are going to keep track of that
address always. That's how it's going to work.
So now having the address box in
place, let's create this category list.
So let's close this and here we are gonna have
a constant sized box. Let's create that quickly
of height 10, then let's remove
this. So I do command first stop. And
what I'm going to do is, so now let's just remove
this constant from your, pass it in the column
and yeah, we have it. Cool. Let's also remove
this user because we don't need the provider.
So of course we'll have to remove all of this
stuff again. Sweet. So now the next thing is
the categories thing. So what I'm going to have
is pretty simple. Again, we are going to create
top underscore categories, your dot file, import
material dot, create a stateful widget for them.
Let's create a stateless widget for now. So we
have top categories and we are going to have a
container of height 60. Then the color is going
to be colors dot white. Obviously you can see
the color is white. And even if we don't mention,
it's not a deal, so let's try to not include it.
And the child is going to be a ListView
builder because we have five things away.
So let's build it out using ListView builder. So
we have list review builder. Then we have, uh,
context and then index pass.
Then we have an item count,
And now we need the items for this, the items
for this, we have already installed the images.
So we have the appliances books. These are all
category images. So we are going to use them,
but just to initialize them in a list so that, you
know, it stays good enough, very editable. So we
are going to add them in the global variables.
So if you want to get access to them, you can
just go to this repository and copy all of these
things and put it in the global variables class.
So here we can go there. So here I am in the
global variables class, I can just pace them
over here. You can see now, save it, go by
your, and access them using global variables
dot carousal images, length, and it's not carousal
images, sorry, it's category images link. Then we
can get access to return a column because well,
it is going to be column, right? You can see where
a column of this image and this mobile text.
So we are gonna have children as the container
and the padding going to be constant sets only
from actually let's do symmetry. So we have
horizontal as 10.
Then we have child, and then we are going to use
clip RX for this so that it appears as, you know,
a circular thing, or you can use, uh, circle
avatar widget for this. So I'm going use clip R
And then we will specify the border radius,
which will be border radius dot, circular 50.
Then the child is going to be of mage dot asset,
and it'll be global variables dot category images
at index at image. So if you just go in
the global variables class, you can see
it is a list of map of string com mastering.
So here we have title, then mobile's image as
this image. So we are accessing suppose the
zero element, then their image property.
That's exactly what we're doing over here.
And since this can be nullable, we can put
an exclamation mark. Now we need to specify
their height. So it can be
first of all, box fit dot cover.
Then we can pass in the height as 40 the width as
40. And that's all. So let's save this much and
see what we are getting. We're not seeing anything
mainly because we are not used top categories.
So let's go our pass in the top categor,
we are passing the top categories,
and now we are able to see this. Now you can
see, this is pretty funny. We just need to
use them horizontally. So what we can do is
scroll direction as access dot horizontal.
Now it looks great. Also let's give some padding
to each and everyone. So let's give up a specific
extent to which an item can be there. So
what I'm going to do is pass an item extend,
and you're passing 75. Every item is going to have
a width or the extent as 75 just looks neat. Also,
let's remove this container to say size box.
Now, after this container, we need a text that
will say the category that we are having. So you
are, it's going to be something similar to this,
paste it in wire, and it'll be title.
If you go to the global variables, you
can see this is called title. That's why
now we have style as constant textile, and we
need to diminish the font size, which will be
12 because it's lower than the usual. And then we
can have a font, weight of font, weight dot w 400.
Again, save this and you can see
this is coming out. Pretty cool.
That way, exactly the way we want it to come out.
Looks great. Now the next thing is this carousal
image. And now if you haven't noticed it already,
this is carousal. So meaning if we swipe on
it, it'll show us other images. So for that,
we are going to use a plugin called carousal
image. So here we have carousal slide already. So
this is a plugin that we're going to use. So
let's install it. I'm going to use dependency
and stop a app execution and close the top
categories because we are done over even
the global variables file. We don't need to add
anything else. And now you create a new widget for
carousal or carousal image do that.
So yeah, we are gonna import material do, uh,
let's import it, material dot, then call
it a stateless widget, call it carousal
image, return, carousal slider. This is what
comes from the package. Carousel slider dot
let's also get our app running after we've
specified the items parameter and the options
parameter. What is this option going to be
carousal options. So let's quickly add them.
And now we can get our app running. In the
meantime. Now we can focus on how it's going to
look like. Well, first of all, the items is going
to return a list of widgets. You can see that
now art items are going to be in a separate list
that we have in global variables. We have already
added that. So if you go to the global variables,
you can see, we have carousal images over.
We're going to use each one of them. So what we
need to do is map over every image in the list,
and then we need to return an image based on that
URL. So what I'm going to do is global variables
dot carousal images dot map. We will get I,
so we have I, and then obviously we need to
convert it back to a list. So earlier what we
need to return with IE is a builder widget.
Then it'll accept a builder parameter. And
in that builder parameter it'll return to us
build a context. So here we are
going to return image.network,
passing the image.network, which is I
E when we map away, we get that URL.
And then we are using fit as box fit
dot cover, and the height as 200. Cool.
This looks good enough. Now we need to pass in the
carousal options. But before that, let's see how
it's looking. So here we can again, have a size
box of height 10, and then finally we will have
carousal image save this much.
And here we have it. At least it's now a working
carousal, but now we need to make sure it takes in
all the available width so that what
we can do is go to the carousal image
In the carousal options, we will pass in view,
port fraction as one, and the height as 200,
you can see it is failure, a specific height,
so that all images have the particular height
in case you want to change it. The height
does not differ and does not look ugly.
So here now this looks like a proper
carousal, and it's pretty neat. Finally,
we need the deal of the day and this
deal of the day is going to work
on the rating system. So after we integrate the
rating system in our application, we'll be able to
show the proper deal of the day product. But for
now, we are going to keep it as a static image
and a static text. So what I'm going to do
is in the widgets have deal of the day, do
we are going to import material dot,
create a stateful widget. As I said,
we are going to create an API for this. So we
have deal of the day. Then we are going to have
to return a column and it'll be wrapped by a
gesture detector. Because when we click on this,
we need to get to the new page to
display the details of the product.
But now we are going to have children, the
container, which just says that, yeah, this
is the deal of the day. You can see that and it's
in the top left. So we are going to have alignment
as alignment.top left padding as constant insert
dot only from the left 10 from the top 15,
after that, a child with constant
text saying deal of the day.
And then we need a style of textile
with font size 20, say this this much,
we are not seeing anything because we have not
bound this to, uh, UI. So let's quickly do that.
So just after this, we can have not a constant
because you already have a list of constraint.
So here we just need to type and deal
of day. And now we can see deal of the
day correctly showing up pretty neat. Now
we finally need to show an image.network,
which will for now just show a static image.
So again, we can go to unsplash.com and get
a new image. So I'm just going to copy this
image address and paste it in over here.
Now we need to specify
certain height. You can see,
but before that, we can go to the
home screen and write this column
with a widget known as single child scroll view.
So that in case there's any render flow error,
you can know it's scrollable. Always. You
can see that now in the deal of the day,
we need to specify certain height. So the first
of all, we are gonna have a height of 2 35,
And then we need to make sure that the fit is
box fit, dot fit, height. This looks great. So
in this particular height, it's going to fit
now for now, it's looking very bad, but when
we add our own products, it's going to look neat
because it's going to be, uh, PNG format image,
And it'll contain the entire products height.
We don't want them to go according to their
width. We don't want them to take the entire
width. All we want to show is the correct
height of the product and the
correctness that it shows.
So after that, we finally need to add all of this
price and name of the product, all of that stuff.
So yeah, what we can do is have a container with
padding of constant sets dot only from left 15,
from top five from right 40. And this will be
the product name. That's exactly what we want.
So you're in the child. We are going to have
text as the product name for now. We can give
a star name. So let's say everyone is on sale.
So we can have max lines as two and text overflow.
So let's have overflow as text overflow dot Ellis,
again, the dot format that I've already told to
you. And for now, let's just give it a constant
text because later on, it's always going to
change. So we'll have to remove this constant
and let's see how it's looking. It's not looking
great. So yeah, what we can do is make some
corrections, have a padding, uh, sorry, just have
an alignment past in which will be alignment.top
left here. We have it. Now looks good. As the name
gets bigger, you'll understand why we are using
such a small form size, but
before that we needed to create
product, right? I mean the price of the product.
So now let's just add that. So we have container
Pass in the padding. So let's copy this padding,
paste it in away. And it'll be only from the left
15 pass in the alignment as alignment.top left.
And then we need to pass in the child as a text,
which will be slash dollar because we want to
display dollar, right? I mean it's nine $99.
So you want to display dollar. And if you use
dollar, it'll consider it as string interpolation.
So we have to PA pass in back slash dollar, and
then we have dollar as the price. But for now
we are not depending on the price from the
API. So we can just pass in hundred like this,
and also pass in constant aware. Now, if we see
aware, this looks good, but it's very small. So we
can just increase its font size. So we have style
as a constant textile and pass in font size as 18.
Let's remove this one now and there we go. Dollar
a hundred looks good. And final thing that you'll
not be able to notice as of now is we want
to display a list view builder below this
so that we can show other images of the same
product. So to do that, we are going to go below,
add a row of images. So let's quickly add
that. And it'll be main access alignment as
main access alignment.space between then
the children will be the product images.
So for now we can just create image.network
pass in the images. So let's quickly grab some
of the images from Europe and let's paste
it more times, let's say four times more.
And then we want each of them to have a fixed
width, height and all of that. So let's pass it
in. So we'll have fit as box fit, dot fit width.
So it, so here it's going to fit according to
their width so that, you know,
it stays in a proper constraint
and the width can be hundred and the height can be
hundred as well. So that we create a box, right? I
mean a square. That would be good. Now, if we save
this much, you can see we got a render flow error,
and that is expected because we need to wrap
this row with again, a single child scroll view
with the help of the single child scroll view,
we'll be able to pass and scroll direction, which
will be access dot horizontal. Now we save this
much. You can see it's scroll label and it looks
good enough. And finally, below this, we just need
to tell that, yeah, let's see all the deals of the
day. So we have container with padding as constant
edge and edge dot only. And from the left 15
from the top 15 from the bottom 15, and in
case you don't want to write all of them 15,
what you could have done is pass in symmetric away
and then vertical as sorry, Ania vertical as 15,
because top and bottom is 15. And then you could
have removed this left to say, copy with left
15. This is also great. And the earlier one is
also great. Both of them look great. <laugh>
So we have alignment.top left, and
then the child will be text saying, see
all deals. Now we just need to pass
in the style, which will be a textile.
Now the color for this is
going to be colors, dots,
and the shade will be 800. All
of this is tried and tested.
If you want, you can just use different shades and
see which one you like. I'm preferring this one.
So now if we scroll here, we have see all the
deals and it looks magnificent. That's the way I
want it. So our home screen UI is also completed
and it looks exactly the way it, we, it to look
now in case you're wondering why deal of the day
looks shabby, not like this. When we add great
images, you'll understand why it looks great
enough on this. Now, the next thing we want to
work on is the admin screen, so that we can add
products and use real products so that whenever
we click on this mobiles, we can see the proper
categories. When we click on this essential,
we can click on, uh, proper categories. We're not
going to design card because we design card only
when we are able to add them to our card for now,
we just need to be able to add products. And for
that, we are going to go to the admin side inside.
And for that, we'll always have to do some
conditional rendering logic. So you are again
in the main door dot file. We'll have to check
where if the token is not empty, then we
need to check. If the user's type is not,
Is a user. If it's user, then we want to
show that otherwise the admin screen. So
let's quickly do that logic and then
work on the adding products feature.
So it's pretty easy for us. Well, we can just
copy this past it away and have user dot type.
And now we wanna check if it is equal to user,
right? So if that type is now equal to user,
then we want to show the bottom bar, otherwise
the admin screen. So for admin screen,
let's create a new feature. Let's close
all of them and now create admin feature.
This will have screens. And now the screen over
here is going to be admin underscore, screen.dot.
Here we are gonna import the material dot,
create a stateless or state full widget.
And this admin screen is going to work in the
same way as a bottom bar, because it is going
to consist of bottom bar, displaying several
things like this. Here we have the home button,
the analytics button, and the orders button is
gonna be pretty similar to the bottom bar. So
after having that, let's turn it this into a
scaffold and let's keep it this way for now.
Then we can go to the main door dot file and you
put a call in and then pass the Ironman screen.
Sweet. So now if I restart the application,
I should see a blank screen and we are not
seeing the blank screen mainly because we
have not changed the type of in the MongoDB.
So let's click on this edit icon using
which you can edit your type of the user
or any other field. And then we are going to
change this to admin and then click on update.
After doing that, we can just click on restart
and here we have it, a blank screen. Now in case
this is, uh, irritating you, the debug banner.
What you can do is go, we are in the main
dot main dot file. And here we can have B box
show, check mode, banner, and set it to false.
And now this is gone. Great. So now we can close
rest of the files and go to the admin screen
here. The very first thing is, again, the app
bar that you want create, you can see this part
idea and to create this kind of a bar. We can
just copy it from somewhere. So we can just go
to the account screen, copy this, a bar that we
are minimized. Let's quickly copy all of this.
And again, minimize this go in the admin screen,
pass in the app bar, this app bar click on save.
Obviously we need to import global variables.
And then again, click on save. You can see Amazon
dot, showing up. Now we need to remove this
bell and this kind of icon. So
let's remove this whole container
and pass in constant text admin
with a textile, which will be
basically that. Yeah, we want to bold this
out. So we have font, weight, font, weight.
If you go, you can see, as I told previously,
this is all the white color. I just wanted to
demonstrate this to you. So now we can change the
color and set it to colors, draw black. And yeah,
this looks great. Just similar to this. Now, what
we need to do is create the bottom navigation bar.
And again, it's gonna be pretty similar.
So let's copy the contents from a bottom
bar dot file here and just going to select well,
everything. So let's select everything and paste
it in the admin screen. So bottom I'll minimize
the app bar and here have the bottom nav bar
here. We have it. Now we need to create these
variables so we can create them or actually copy
them from your itself. Yeah, we have everything.
So now we can just paste it. Now we need to create
some different pages or widgets because we want
to render different pages. So your I'm we just
going to copy the center widget until we make
those widgets. So we are going have analytics
page, and this is going to be the post page. We
are going to create post page just right now,
but for some time, let's just keep it so
that we don't have to deal with some errors.
And now we don't want badge in our application.
So we are going to remove this bottom nav bar item
and copy this bottom nav bar item, paste
it down here, and this is going to be
the orders. And we are going to check if
this is two. So if this is two, we want this,
we've done this logic. We've covered this logic.
So we need two to worry, and this will be all
inbox outline here. We will have analytics
underscore outline because this is analytics
and this is posts. So we will have
home underscore outlined only here. We can see
the correct symbol showing up and it's okay.
Now let's create a post page. So we will
have in the screens itself, we will create
posts, underscore screened, or that
other thing that you could have done
is made a views folder and created views in that.
But I'm not doing that after that,
it's going to be a stateful widget because
in just a while, after creating the UI,
we are going to create the products and display
them. We are going to create APIs for them
that side. So now we have scaffold
your, we are going to return a body
and the body for now can be a
centered child text saying products,
and we can put cons for them. But instead
of doing that, we are just going to pass
in cons for center, because now we are
going to have a floating action button.
This floating action button
you can see is over here.
So this floating action button is going to help
us go to a new page where we can add products.
And instead of post screen, they should,
they should be product screen. I'm not sure
why I named it that way, but now let it be. So
here, I'm gonna have a floating action button
with child as a constant I icon of I icons.ad, and
then on press is going to be a function like this.
And then I'll just save this much
and you can't see anything because I'm
not bound this post screen to the pages
widget that we list of widgets that we have.
And now we can pass in cons to a yeah. Cool.
Now we can go away, restart our application.
There's absolutely no need, but yeah, we have it
floating action button. Now we want this floating
action button to appear in the center. So what we
can do is floating action button location as
floating action button, location.center float,
and yep. It appears in the center.
Great. Also, another thing that we want
to add is a tool tip. Some people won't understand
what this is. So if the long tab they want to see
what is happening. So tool tip will help us with
exactly that. And we can say, add a product. And
now if I long click on this, you can see, add a
product shows up. Great. Now let let's create,
add post screen or add product screen right
now. So let's name it. Add product screen.dot.
We will import material dot, create a stateful
widget and call it, add product screen. You
already know why this is a stateful widget,
because you're gonna create APIs. And along
with that, we are going to have text form
filled because we are going to create a form.
So here we have the UI of this. So now
again, we will return a scaffold layer with
a body and an app bar. So for app bar, we can copy
what was there in the Ironman screen. So let's
quickly copy all of that and paste it away.
Now we just need to import global variables
and save this much and let's navigate to
the ad product screen to navigate. Uh,
of course we need to create a named route so
we can static constant string, route name,
equal to slash ad product. Now let's
register this so we can go to router.dot,
create this and pass in, add
product, screen dot route name,
and even your ad product screen.
All right now in the post screen,
whenever we click on this, but we want to navigate
so we can create a function over here called
why navigate to our product. Pretty simple,
just not mixing our UI with our logic.
So just creating it at top. Even if you
create it inside of this anonymous function,
it won't matter. But I just like to do
it this way. Then we will have navigator
push name and pass in the route. Name,
route name is add product, screen
dot route name, take this navigate to add product,
pass it in the on press and save this much,
restart our application. And if you click away,
we go on the next screen. Now in the next screen,
we don't want this. Instead. We just want a simple
title. So now let's close all the other file
and work on this. So via in the title, we are
going to replace this entire row with just
a constant text widget saying, this is ad product.
We need to style this
with a textile, which has color of black. Now,
if you go, you can see it's pretty similar to
that. Now the next thing we need to work on
is this container. Now this container looks
very different from what we have
created so far and this, because,
and it is simply because this is bordered and all
of that stuff. So for that, we are going to use
a plugin known as dotted border. So this is the
package that we're going to use. Let's copy this,
add it to the dot. Using do dependency. Let's
top our app execution. All right, now we can
run the app again, run our debugging. And in
the meantime, what we can do is first of all,
minimize this app bar and now in
the body, we will have dotted water.
But before that, as you can analyze, we have this
image and then we have this product form fields.
So for that, obviously we are going to create
a form. And there's a possibility that this
might overflow because every screen is going
to be different, but our sizes are fixed.
So what we can do is wrap this with a single child
scroll view. So here I'm gonna have single child
scroll view pass in the, the child and the
child is going to be a form whose key we are
going to create in a while, but we will have
a child. And the child is going to be a column
whose children and the very first children, child
is going to be a dotted border. Now we have that.
So let's create dotted border and it's going to
have a child which will be simply a container.
So in this container, we will have, first of
all, some properties defined. So width will be
as much space as it gets radius. Sorry, high eight
will be one 50 decoration will be box recreation
with border radius as border radius dot,
circular 10. So that, you know, we get some
border radius. It's exactly what we are
seeing. Then we have a child aware which
will be a column, and this column will specify
what contents are inside of this, the folder
folder thing, and select product
images. So what we can have is children,
and it'll be constant. I
can, I icons dot folder open
with a size of 40.
After that, we are going to, again, leave
some space. So we have size rebox as hide 15,
and then a text,
which will be not constant because you're going
to use a shade color. Because if you see a wire,
this is not even gray, not even black. This is
somewhat of a shade of a gray. So we are going to
use that. So it'll not be a constant anymore. So
we have select product images pass in the style,
which will be textile with a font size of
15 and color of colors dot gray shade, 400.
You can see this is not a cost anymore. So if I
save this much and go on this screen, you can see,
uh, dotted water is operating well, but we need to
leave some space from your, and from your, but if
you analyze the screenshot that we have with us,
you can see there's some spacing left from your,
and there's some left from your as well.
And even from the other side. So my point is,
if there is spacing left from all the sides,
what we can do is wrap the column only with
a padding widget makes sense. And then we
will specify that we wanted symmetric and in the
horizontal direction we wanted, let's say 10. Now
we have that spacing done. Now in the column,
we will leave constant size blocks, height 20.
Now we have that left as well, but
still it's not logging, uh, really cool,
like this one. And that's because we need to
specify some properties to make it look good.
So yeah, we're gonna have some properties in the
dotted border, like border type as border type.
If you pass in circle, it'll create something like
a circle, but we want like a, so yeah, we have it.
Then we need to specify the radius, which will be
constant radius dot circular 10. Now you can see
the curves are appearing pretty well after that.
We need a dash pattern and it accepts double,
which will be 10 comma four, and obviously
put in a cons because it's a list of Inger.
Now, these dashes appear very well after that.
We will have stroke cap as stroke cap round.
You can see it's appearing pretty neat. Now, after
that, we just need to push this in the center. So
that should be fairly easy with the column using
main access alignment as main access alignment
center and boom. Yeah, we have, it looks
insane. Now we just need a couple of text
fields and this text field we can reuse because
our custom text field is also the same look.
So let's quickly copy it down. So let's create
first a lot of spacing. So we will have a height
of 30 because you can see in the start, there's
a lot of space. Then the space decreases.
Now we will pass in custom text field, pass
in the controller and hand text. So now
we will pass in and create
a couple of controllers.
So we will have final text editing
controller as the product name controller,
which will be equal to text editing controller.
And let's remove this and pass in text editing
controller. After that, we can copy it four more
times so that we have a description controller
and then we can have price controller
and then quantity controller.
And I think that much is enough for the text
editing controller. So obviously we need to create
a dispose for them. So let's dispose them before
we forget, let's take this product name controller
call dispose on them then a couple of more times,
so we can pass in this, the price controller. And
finally the quantity controller. Now we can
go down, pass in the very first controller,
which will be product name controller, and then
pass in the hand text, which is product name,
make sure to add not a very descriptive he text
because our validation is based on this. He text,
you can see enter your product name
or whatever letter you want. See now,
after that, we want a constant size box again, and
now this will be smaller. So we will pass in 10.
Now we can just copy this
format, paste it in again,
and this will be well description controller.
And now we will just say description,
save this much. And yeah, we have it. Now the
problem with description controller or the
description form is that this is bigger because
description can be bigger. So for description,
what we need to do is make sure that the max
number of lines that a text field can add
is bigger. So what we can do is go to this custom
text field and now add another input of final end
max lines and require this dot max lines. Now,
the problem is that if we require it everywhere,
you can see there are errors in our ad
product screen, and even in odd screen,
because we are using custom text field everywhere.
Now, suppose we have a very big tech, uh,
code base now. And if we want to make this change,
it'll ask us to, uh, put in max lines everywhere.
And we are already happy with what we had earlier.
So how do we fix this? Well, we can just remove
this required and set it to the default value of
one because everywhere the max number of lines
was one because by default, max number of line is
one. Now in case the user enters the max lines,
it'll set to the value, the user enters from
other class. Otherwise it'll take in the value
of one. So now I can take this max lines and pass
in max lines from the construc area. Now your IPA
max lines again, and pass seven now. Yeah, we
have it. You can see description is now longer.
Now similar to the product name. We are gonna
have several more fields. So let's quickly
add them. I think two more is enough. We need
price and quantity. So let's quickly put them in
and same for quantity. So we have
quantity and person, quantity controller.
Now we have everything. Now, the last thing
we want is a dropdown menu. So whenever we
click on this dropdown menu, we want a list
of categories that are available for us.
So now let's create them. So we will have sized
box, which will take in all the available space,
because if we don't specify this, it'll only
take in the amount of which it requires to put
in this text mobiles or whatever. So it'll be only
this much small just me, just let me demonstrate
it to you. So it'll be only this much long. We
don't want that. We want uniformity. So we will
just pass in this big. So here we are gonna have
a child of dropdown button, which had provided by
flatter. Now we will have value and the value
will be the items that we create at the top,
which will be the list of the product items.
So here we can create list of string
called product categories and
then pass in mobiles essentials,
then appliances, books, and fashion, make
sure to use whatever, uh, make sure to
properly name them according to our global
variable. So if we go over there, you can see
mobiles essentials, appliances, books,
fashion, make sure to have all of these
categories. And these are very essential for
our app because based on this, we are going to
store the product categories whenever we store
the products and this will play a huge role. So
make sure to not make any typo. So now we can go
down and I value, first of all, is going to be
the category. So let's create a global
variable called string category and
set it to a default value called mobiles.
Because here you can see in our app,
we have already put a default value of mobile. So
whenever the user clicks on the screen, the first
category or the default category is mobiles.
So now we can take this category as a value.
Then we need an ICAN. So the ICAN is going
to be a constant I icon of Ikes dot dropdown,
actually Ikes dot keyboard, arrow down.
And then we need to pass in the items,
the list of items that we want in our app.
So now that items, if you hover over, this
is a list of dropdown menu item object.
So what we need to do is what we have done earlier
with the carousal. We need to map through the
product items that we have. So product categories,
dot map, then we have string of items that we get,
and then we want to return this drop
down menu. So we will have return
drop down menu item. And now if you are very
confused with the error that are coming in,
what you need to do is change it to dot two
list. The error goes away. And now in the child,
we are going to have text or
saying the item that we have
right now because we loop through it, right?
So product categories is a list. We map through
them, we got a single item, and now we are
displaying that item for the Semino. And now
we also want to put in a value. So whenever this
has changed, you can see there's an non-change
property that we need to add. So whenever we
click on this, we need the value to be assigned,
right? So what is that value going to
be? Well, it's just going to be item.
And that's why I said that this is going
to carry the product categories list that
we created. Their names is going to carry
a lot of value. And finally, after this,
we need an unchanged property so we can create
unchanged and we will have spring of new value
and then just set state to change category
equal to the new value that we received.
And we are pretty sure that it's never going to be
Nu because every value, every time we click on a
trip, do down menu item, it's going to return some
value and that's it. So yeah, we have the mobiles.
If you click on this, you can see list of options
that it gives us. And if I click on essentials,
now it's essentials and that's because of the
on change property. We rebuilt the whole screen.
Cool. And finally, after the size box, we will
need another size box so that we can create a
button. So a button is going to be pretty simple,
a custom button. Now the text is going to be sell
and the on tap is going to be the sell product
that we need to create right now. So yeah,
we have it. The UI is now created. Now the next
step is to create the API, to sell a product.
Let's create that, but actually before creating
our own API, what we need to do is be able to
click on a, on this and be able to select an image
for exactly that we are going to the.dot file.
And here we are going to create a utility function
called pick images. This will help us pick images
simple. And now I've named it pick images because
we are allowing a product to have multiple images.
So it'll be a list of file and
it'll be images which will be empty.
Then we will have a try and a catch block.
And here we are not going to display a short snag
bar. Instead we are just going to print it out
because there are very less conditions in which
we are going to get any error. And whenever we
get this error, it's mainly because the user does
not select any images. And that's not a correct
way to show the snack bar because if the user
doesn't show images, we don't need the snack bar
and also remove the dot HTML import and instead
do.io because dot HTML only works on web
suite. So now in the tri block, we need to select
the image for, to select the image. We need to
install a plugin file picker, or you can even
install image picker as long as you know how to
use them. There's not much difference in both of
them while picking an image or selecting an image.
So let's add that dot add dependency, put in file
picker, and I'll save this file for now. Stop a
app execution and see if there's any installation
required. So here in the installation and set
apart, we can see, we need to do something for
Android, IRS, web, desktop, or anything. So here
you can see Android all said, you should be ready
to go as long as you can see runtime permissions.
So, yep. It's all good for us after that in
the iOS, it ask us to, well, use all of this in
case of the file type that we are using. So we are
using file type image. So let's find one for that.
And here we have it. Whenever we use file type
dot image or file type.video, we need to add
the following key. So let's click on this, copy
it, go to our info dot P list file and add it.
Make sure that your info P list
file is in the iOS, not Macs
pasted down your, and then you need to
explain why our app uses the photo library.
Well, we want images, right? So we can
just write. We want image for product
and you need to definitely write something that
is very more formal. But I think for me, since
I'm not uploading to play store or app store,
that's fine. So now I can rerun my application.
And while that is happening and actually, while
the app is launching, now we can in the tri block,
add a wait file, picker dot platform dot
pick files. And now we need to pick files.
Well, first of all, mention the type which will
be file type dot images. So that it'll only show
us the images of the type file type, sorry of,
uh, files of the type images, sorry, after that,
we need to make sure that we allow multiple
images to be selected. And yeah, we have it
also just remove the extra sor put
a semicolon after having that let's
toward them in a variable called files, and
this will be of the type file picker result.
You can see that we have file picker result. Now
with this file picker result, first, we need to
check if files is not equal to Nu, we saw that
it can be Nu and we know you need to check that
files.files.is not empty. So the files list that
it gives us is not empty. So if this is the case,
that means file is not Nu and files is not
empty. Meaning the files, which is the variable
dot files, which is a property, which file picker
result gives us is not empty. So if it's not
empty, then we need to go to and do four. And I
equal to zero. We basically need to map over all
the files way up. So you can have files dot files.
I is less than files.files.link I plus plus,
And then add all of the files that file picker
has to our images. Two are images list. So have
images.ad path and file, which will take in a
path which will be files dot files at I dot path.
And here you can see the argument type string
can be assigned to the parameter type string.
So we can just put an exclamation mark away.
And finally, we will return this images list.
And then finally, we can give your, you know,
a future list of images or the file as a return
type. Great. It's always good to have the return
type of error because later on when we use this
pick images, we won't know what the return type
is and it'll be dynamic dynamic. Isn't a very
good thing in the R product screen, we can
create a function called void select images,
and this will be asynchronous again, here we
will just say, result is equal to of eight
pick images and we need to import it from
the utility file. Then we need to set state
Of images, which is not created. Yes. So we
will create list of file, call images and set
it to an MD list. We will also input this
file and then we will have images equal to
result. Now we can take the select images
and wrap this around this dotted bottle.
So we will wrap it with a gesture detector
and on tap, whenever we click on this, we want
pick images to run. So yeah, we have
it and actually not pick images,
sorry. We want to run select images,
which is a function that we created away.
Pick images is a function in the utility file.
Sweet. So now let's restart our application,
click on this floating action button, click
on select product images, and here I'm able
to select the images and I can select multiple
images. If I click on add, I don't see any error.
That means it has been successful. And images now
has this. So let's try to display those images on
the screen for that. We are obviously going to
use carousal slider again. So for that, we can
just copy it from our carousal image dot file. We
could use this function in case we were receiving
items from the constructor, but you're
not doing that because we've created
that in a separate feature. Now I'm not
saying we are not going to U reuse some
features widgets, but in this case, let's not
do it in case we want the products to show up
differently where it's great to have a
different, you know, widget shown away.
So here I can check if images, the
global variable that we created is
not empty. So if it's not empty, then we
need to obviously show the carousal slider,
otherwise a gesture detector.
So we can paste it import the carousal slider,
not carousal options. It'll only import this,
but we want carousal slider as well as carousal
options. Then we can remove this carousal slider,
save it and see what the is. Let's remove this.
Yep. Looks right. And also remove this global
variables dot carousel images. And instead
add images dot map this. After that, we DEC
receive a, a file over and now the file is not
going to be image.network. It is going to be image
dot file, which is another widget so that we can
display a file. And if you save this, you can see
the images are showing up just with the hot reload
and everything shows up cleaner. And later now,
finally, we can go to the API request where we can
create our API. So now let's close all the same
files. And in the admin, we are going to create,
um, another folder called services.
And here we are going to have admin services five.
And here we are just going to create a class
called admin services inside of which we are
going to have several folders. And the very first
function that we're going to have is sell product.
Now this is going to require a lot of things.
So let's give it a named cons named parameter.
So we will have build context, obviously, just
to display the errors. Then we will have a name
which is the product name. Then we will require
the description, which is a product description.
Again. Then we have a price and this will
be in double because the user can enter
digits or decimal points. Then we can have
quantity, which will be double as well. I mean,
you can have interior as well. It won't be a
problem, but I'm just gonna go ahead with double.
Then we are gonna have category.
And then finally a list of file. Let's copy this.
And this will be called images. Now I'll import
this from do IO and here, this is going to be
asynchronous and put a tri block, obviously
aware. We are going to show a snack bar,
so you will have E two string. And now
the very first thing that we need to do
is upload the images to the database.
Now we could have done that in the
server side, but doing it in the server
side is less easier as compared to doing it
in the client side, using a plugin, which is
provided to us, first of all, where are we going
to store these images? Now we can't store these
images in Mongo database. You can store them,
but I think it's very difficult to store them.
And I would not recommend doing that because
we have only 512 MB of storage given by Mongo
DB, because we are using their shared cluster.
So instead, what I would recommend you to use
is Cloudinary. This is the website for cloud
d.com and this is their client sided usage. So we
can use cloud instead of sending HTTP requests to
this cloud, uh, storage. What we can do is use
cloud public, which as it tells here, allows
us to upload media files directly to cloud without
exposing our API key or secret key, which is huge.
So now let's quickly log in and you would've to
sign up in case you're coming for the first time.
Actually I'll also sign up. So you
need to enter your name. I'll enter R
then I'll enter my email after
entering the password and the email,
you don't have to enter company
site name, then you, you need to
enter a product. So we can just write
program media for image and radio API,
click on robot and click on create account.
All right. So after confirming the email,
your become welcome to cloud, what's
your main role. I'm just going to say,
developer, click on continue. Then we need
to build a new website. We can click on done
and here we have it. Now let's first of all,
delete all the samples. We don't need them. Let's
click on refresh. We have all of these samples
still there let's quickly delete all of them.
And then here in the settings, we need to get two
things. First of all. So actually let me tell you
why we need them. So here we can just take this
cloud in the Republic, add it to our dependency.
Let's stop our app execution. And now let's
create an instance of the Cloudinary. So
let's run our app also. So here we have final
Cloudinary equal to cloud public, and let's
initialize that where in the constructor, it
asks for a cloud name and the upload preset.
So for cloud name, what we
can do is go to the dashboard
and here you can see, this is the cloud name. We
can copy this, paste it here. And then it asks for
upload preset. As we saw, we don't need API key
or API secret key anymore. So we can just click on
settings and get our upload preset. So to get the
upload preset, yeah, we need to click on upload,
go down, enable unsigned, uploading, delete
this signed uploading. And then this is
our upload preset. So we can copy this
upload preset, go to our dashboard again,
and your pass in the upload preset as well.
Now, make sure to not use whatever I'm using
and create your own account because I'm going
to be deleting everything after this tutorial.
Great. So now we have a file list of
files and it is called images. So now
I'll create list of string called image
URLs. And what we are going to do is
essentially map through all of these images
and send it to this Cloudinary storage.
So we will have four N I equal to zero.
I is less than images.link I plus, plus
then we will have of eight cloud dot
upload file. And you can also refer to
their documentation here, which clearly states
how to go ahead. Your it is written. So we need
to upload file. And as we saw, we Cloudinary
filed or from file is what we need to pass in.
So we will have Cloudinary file, not from file.
It gives various options like from bys, from,
from URL, from future, by by data. But we will use
from file because we have a file and then we will
have images at I, and this is a file. We'll
use that files path and store it over there.
Now we will just use cloud in a response to store
it in a response variable. After that, we can just
use images, image, urls.ad, which is this list of
string and add the response dot secret URL that
it gives us so secure URL. So this is the download
URL that we get from file base or the upload URL,
whatever you want to call it. Now we have
access to this so we can send this to our API,
but before doing any of that let's. So now before
moving ahead, there's one thing that I would like
to tell and one change that I would like to make.
That's simply we store all of the files away, but
you can see if we store it it'll store in our,
in our media file library and it'll store it
here continuously. I mean, there has to be some
management in our uploading as well, right?
Let's make a folder for this. It won't create
a folder by default. It'll just store images
like itself. So here we can pass in the folder.
So every product that we have will have its own
folder inside of which we will have several
images. So here we can pass in the folder as a
name of the product and save this much. Now we can
go ahead. We are not able to test it yet because
we don't have all of this stuff. So now let's
create a product and finally upload it to our
MongoDB as well. Now we will be
uploading only URLs to our MongoDB.
So now, first of all, we have to create a
product model. So let's quickly create that
product.dot. So it'll be pretty simple class
product, whatever we have accepted from the
structor, that's all we need. So we will call
it final string name, final string description,
finals, double quantity, final list of string
of images, and make sure to not use file away.
We are storing all the download URLs
away. Then we have final string category,
final double price, and year we will also have
string, which can be nullable called ID a string,
which can be nullable called user ID. All
of this. We are not storing right now while
sending data to our server, but we will
store when we get data from our server.
And we will also have rating, which we will create
later on after we add the rating functionality
and make sure to add the final keyword for both
of them as well. Now we can create a constructor
then Jason serialization, and like earlier, we
made changes for the ID in the, from map function.
We can pass in map, underscore ID aware. You can
see in our user dot file as well. We have passed
in map underscore ID aware and similar to that,
we have map underscore ID in the product as well,
because you're not passing in the ID. Mongo or
Mongo database is going to create it for us.
Having that in place, let's
create a product model over you.
So we will call this product and now
we need to pass in the name. We have it
description. We have it quantity. We have it
images. We need to pass in the image, match,
URLs, category, price, and all of
that is done. There's no need to
enter rest of the things that it has, for
example, ID and user ID, because they're
after that, we just need to post that. But
before doing that, we need to create that
API. So what we can do is go to a server and
here in the routes, we are going to create
admin JS route. This will contain all the admin
dot JS functions. So obviously import express.
Then we need to create an admin
route, which will be equal to
admin route, uh, which will be equal
to express router as a function.
And then we need to create a post function so
that we can add a product. Now, before starting
with this, there's an exercise I would like you
to do well. It's just creating an admin ware.
Like we have this Orthodox GS middleware. We need
to create something like an admin middleware. What
different will be admin middleware. It's basically
you are. The only difference that we need to make
is get, we have the ID. We need to get the user
by their ID and check if the type is admin or
not. That's the only thing similar to the oath
Middleware. So try it on your own. If you can
do it, then let me know in the comment section,
otherwise we'll do it together. Were you
able to do it? If not, let's do it. If yes,
let's verify your work. So you're in the
middleware. We are going to create admin
JS. Then we are going to require JWT. So we
will have Jason web token. Then we will create a
function called admin, which will be asynchronous
and we'll give request response. And next we will
already understood what all of them are. We need
a try-catch block. And instead of writing all of
that, let's take in the inspiration from oath.
You should write it on your own, but since I'm
already familiar with how to go about it,
and I've written it multiple times before,
before even creating this tutorial.
So I'm just going to copy paste it.
So over here, after if it's not verified and we
are setting user to verify.id and all of that
here, we can get the user by their
ID. So we will have constant user
equal to of it. User dot find by ID. We
will pass in the verified.id also get user.
So we need to require user. So we will have
constant user, which will be equal to require dot
slash models slash user.
Great. Now we have that user.
We also have awaited it and we can use our
weight because it's an asynchronous function.
So here we can check if user type we already
have that. So if we go to our Mongo database,
you can see if users type is admin. So
here we are just checking if it is user
or the user type is seller, then we need to
return a status saying 4 0 1. This is unauthorized
saying with the message. You are not an
admin and admin. And if it is an admin,
well obviously request user request
token. And yeah, we have it. Great.
So now we can create the post route. So
obviously let's add a comment of adding product.
So we will have a post route which will be called
slash admin. Now we have already used API, but it
is for a common user for admin. We're going to use
slash admin slash ad product. And in case you want
to extend this app further after this tutorial
and you don't, you want even those sellers
to be a normal user. What you can add here is
oth instead of creating an admin metalware,
but we are allowing only admin to use that.
So obviously import admin, which will be
Slash middleware slash admin. Now we've passed
or admin as a middleware, and you can add as
many middlewares as you want. You want 2, 3,
4, you can add them. So obviously we'll have
asynchronous request response. Then
we have a try and a catch block
where we are basically going to return res dot
status of 500. You should be familiar with this
by now. We are just making use of this again and
again. So it should be a good practice for you.
And here we have to get some things from
request your body. Obviously we already know
how the format of this is. So now we can
have name, description, images, quantity,
price, and category. Now, just to remind you
these names over your should be matching to a
product dot file. When we convert it to map,
you can see all of these should be
matching to what we pass in in the routes.
Great. So now let's create a product model.
So now we have to create a product model here
as well. So we have product JS and similar to
user model. We're going to have all of that.
So let's paste it down here, call it product
schema. And now we will just have this much
before we forget. Let's create a
model for this, which will be product.
And it'll equal to Mongo dot model pass in the
model name, which will be product. And this
will be the product schema and obviously exported,
which will be equal to product. Now, before
forgetting all of this, let's do it right here
itself. Now let's define schema. So first of all,
we need a name which will be of the type string
required set to true and trim should also be true.
Then we need a description which will
be of the type string required. Again,
set to true and trim. Again, set to
true. After that, we let's add images.
This will be an a, so now, till now we have
not stored any, a anywhere in our application,
right? So to store an a, what you can do is
obviously create like this type of string
type of a sorry like this. But instead of
doing that, we are using something fancy,
aware. We are using list. And this
images list is going to consist of
Properties, which will be type string and
or will always be required. So it'll be
set to true. So you are, we are creating an
area of images which have these properties
after that, we need a quantity, which will be
obviously a number you can't pass an <inaudible>
or anything like that. You need to pass in a type
number or otherwise you can just pass an N 32
a or end something like that. Then this is
also set to true. Then we need a price which
will be of the type number again, and will be
required. Let's rename this to number again,
after having quantity and price, we need
category the user ID. We are still left with
that. So obviously type string required. True.
This is a category which is mobiles or whatever.
Then finally, we will have the user ID, which
will store the ID of the user who sold this.
Now I don't think it is needed. So let's remove
this. What my idea initially was that we would
create user ID, which would store the idea of the
admin who sold this. But now, as I'm thinking,
I think we will have only one admin in
this application, which will be ourselves.
So there's no need of storing user ID. So
we can, again, go to a product.dot file,
remove the user ID, remove this user ID again,
this and this, and we are good to go. So again, we
can go to the products and finally, we are going
to have something known as ratings, but we will
reach there later on. Now we have all of this.
So let's create a product model which will be
let product equal to product. We have imported
that and it'll be a new product, obviously.
And then we need to pass in, in the object,
the properties that we need. So obviously name,
we know the shorthand now, description,
images, quantity, price, category,
user ID is not there anymore. So I think all
that is there is this. If you go by, you can see
name is needed, description, images, quantity,
price, category, all of that we have passed in.
Now we need to save it to our database. So we
will do product is equal to elevate product. Lord
save. What we are doing here is basically using,
let, let, will make us change the variable name
later on or variable value later on. If we use
constant, we know that from flatter as well,
if anything is constant, it can't change
later on, but with let it allows us to change.
And here we are basically creating a
new product and assigning it to product.
Then we are saving that product, which is a model
and it gives us a function. Do we are saving that
to Mongo database and whatever Mongo database
returns to us, which is, uh, a product within
underscore ID and underscore underscore
version that we are saving in product so
that we can return product to our client site. So
now we could test this API using thunder client,
but instead of doing that, what I'm going to do
is directly go to the Ironman services dot file,
and you're directly create a post request to check
in our application itself. So I'm going to import
HTTP as HTTP. Then we will have http.post. We have
to pass in the URL, which will be dot pass URL,
which will be dollar from our global variables
slash admin slash add product pass in headers.
So we have to pass that outside this. So
we will pass in the headers because this
will be only by authenticated or authorized
users, because this has a functionality of
Art middleware. So obviously we need to pass
in the headers. So let's copy the headers from
one of the files. So we have art service and
let's find the headers. Yeah, this header,
let's go here, pass in this header. And
finally we need to pass in X or token,
which will be from the user provider. So
let's create the user provider at the top.
It's not an asynchronous function, so we can
create this other top, calling it provider.off
user provider context, listen, set to false.
And that's it. Now we can take this user provider
and use user provider dot user
dot token, which can never be Nu.
And finally, don't forget to pass in your body
because headers are different. We are PA we
are authorizing ourselves using this header, but
with body, we are sending the data that we need.
So if you go to admins, you can see authorization
is done using admin middleware, which looks at the
request dot header. But here we are looking at
request dot body. Those are two separate things.
So now we need to pass in body,
which will be product, got two Jason.
After that, we need to do error handling,
which will be HTTP error handling,
and we need to pass in response. So
let's to this in the response call
response as equal to innovate HTTP response GTP
post. Now we can pass this response. And in on
success, we can display a shown bar saying product
added successfully and then navigator dot pop,
so that we go back to the main screen.
So if I restart my application now and
before doing anything else, let's bind the sell
product to our posts, actually our products free.
So now we will create an instance of the
class. So we will have final admin services is
Equal to admin services. Now take this
admin services, call void, sell product.
Now obviously we need to
validate a form. And for that,
we are going to create a global key for that.
So we will have, let's say final underscore add
product form key equal to global key of form
state, and use that, that add product form key
in our form. So let's go down to our form
and here use the key, add product form key.
Now we will be able to use the validate function
so that every field in this screen gets validated.
We have already looked at it in our file.
If you forgot about it, it's a good way to
remember about it. So now it'll give us a bullion
value to validate. And if the form is correct,
all the fields are being passed in. Then
we can say admin services dot, sell product
pass in the name, which will be well
product name. So let's quickly type in
product name, controller dot text.
Then we will pass in description, which will
be description. Controller dot text price
will be price controller dot text quantity.
And actually this requires a double value.
So what we can do is double dot pass. And since
this is a string, we can use double dot par.
So passing this. So we have this done.
Now we can copy this page straight
over here and do the same for quantity
controller. And here we have it sweet.
Now, before even validating the
form. One thing to note your
is that if we validate the
form, it'll not think about this
image that is there. So here, we also need to make
sure that the VI images that we have is not empty.
So we need to make sure, and actually instead of
a, or we need to do. And so we need this form to
be true. That means all the controllers that
are there should be fair. And the images list
that we have should not be empty after doing
this much and using the cell product down
in the on tap, we can pass to it, the
cell product and restart our application.
Now let's see how it works around. I'll select
some products. Let's say I select a few iPhones.
You can see I'm able to select
them. I'll call them iPhone 13, pro
one twenty eight GB. I'll give some description.
Let's say great iPhone for great people.
I don't know, man. I, no, man, this much. So
then in the description we can say, good phone
must buy totally worth it. And yeah, now
we can pass in the price thousand dollars
quantity we have is 20 and it's in mobile
section. So now we can click on cell.
Nothing is happening and you can see, we got
an error, cannot post slash admin. Now, anyway,
when, whenever we get this error, it, we should
be sure that the URL is correct. So we have
that. <inaudible> other thing that we should
note is that this admin router should not,
should be connected to our index
GS file so quickly export it
And then use it in the index GS file using app dot
use admin router. And here we need to save this
and we are still getting an error. The reason
for that is if we go to our admin router and
in the admin, we have not exported this. So let's
quickly export this. So we have moduled or exports
equal to admin. I usually forget that. Now, if you
go where connection has been successful. So now
let's restart our application and all
the data has now gone. So I'll quickly
fill in and then see you. So I filled in
all the details. Now I can click on sell
And you can see product added successfully. Now
there are no errors of even in the DB console,
there are no errors. So now, if I just refresh
my database to see a new collection, which is
products, we are the user's collection,
which consisted of all the user data
here. We have the products collection,
which consists of all the products,
and this is our very first product. It consists
of images and you can see our secure URL.
If I just click on edit to grab one
of them and paste it in the browser,
you can see via Ania. Also, just to show you
the folder management. If I click on refresh,
you can see iPhone 13 pro one 20 at
GB. Both of them are the same folders,
but this consists of all the URLs.
And this came in two times because
There was some error in our script, but still
it's fine. This won't happen and repeat again.
But yeah, we have it, our four files showing up.
So now our data is getting stored. The next step
is to display them over on this screen. It should
be very, very easy for us to do it. All right?
So now what I want to do is close the terminal,
close all the safe files so that it looks a bit
cleaner and a lot less messy. And now in the admin
services file, I'm going to go down and create a
new function to get all the products now, to get
all the products let's, first of all, create our
own API to create our own API. Obviously let's
go to the admin JS file. And this is your fourth
exercise to get all your products by all. I
mean, literally every product that is mentioned,
I want, we want that so that we can display it
on this screen because yeah, the admin, right.
And the API name that we want is slash
admin slash get products pretty simple.
So please try it on your own
and then we can do it together.
Were you able to do it? If not, we can do it
together, otherwise follow along. No problem.
So your admin router dot jet should have slash
admin slash get products and make sure to get,
make it as a get request, because this will
not be a post request. All we are doing over
here is just fetching the products. We don't
need any input from the client side, right.
We just go on the screen. We see the products, no
input is given. So yeah, that's it. Now we need an
admin middleware because only admin should be able
to access it and then obviously request response
and yeah, that's it now
where we have our TRICA block
and then we should have race, rest
status, 500 Jason. And the Jason that
we will pass in is the product, sorry,
the error saying E dot message. And in the
tri block, what are we going to have? Well,
we are going to get the products and
it's fairly simple await product dot
find. And then we don't pass in any criteria of
what we need to find using find, as we've seen
before, it'll get, give us a list of documents, of
whatever ID that we pass in. For example, if you
want to pass in, if you want to get a particular
ID, then what will we do pass in ID over here
and pass in the user's ID like this suppose this
is the user's ID. If you want the, uh, let's say
Product description. So with their description,
if their description is again, Ania, then we can
get their description using that. And it'll
fetch us all the products in an I, which are
with this Ania, but here we are not specifying
only what property we need to find by. That means
it'll get all the products that we need. And then
simply we just need to return that to the client.
So we'll address George Jason products, and
that is our get products route. Pretty simple,
just a bit of logic was required in that. And
obviously we are going to fetch all the products
and what we are going to do over here is
quite different from what we did earlier on
here, we are going to return list of products
by converting them. For example, we send the
Jason product survey, right? We are sending the
products data back to the client side. Here we,
in our client side, we have access to the
product model with that product model.
We are also able to convert any Jason format
that gives us into a product model. So you
to use it in a app, you're going to return future
list of product because you're going to get list
of product in adjacent format. And this is
obviously going to be asynchronous and thus,
we will also need a try and a catch block.
And then we are just going to return a shown
bar with a context and the string
that says E two string. Obviously
we need to pass and build context over so
that we can appropriately show snack bars.
Then we need a user provider because we know
we need to get the token of the user. So we
have final user provider equal to provider dot
of user provider context dot. Yeah, that's it.
Then we can create a list of product as well,
outside the tri block. So we have list of product
called product list, which will be empty.
Now this product list will get some data
as soon as we convert the Jason
to a product model. So for that,
we need to send a get request. So we will have
HTTP get pass the URL, which will Beri dot par
dollar slash admin slash get products, a lot of
boiler plate code again and again, you're writing
so that you're familiar with what you're writing
and you know, it becomes a practice to write this
way. After that all we need is headers because
authentication is still needed. We don't need
to add any body, but authentication
is still needed. So obviously we can
copy these two headers, paste it in over here
and save this in a variable. So we will have
Response response equal to this. And then we
are going to handle this error. So we'll pass
in response. And then on success, what we need to
do is convert this Jason format that it gives us
the response dot body, whatever Jason
format it gives us. We need to convert
that to a product model. Now, as you can
see, we are going to get list of products
in Jason format over here. Also, we are
finding products and it'll be list of products.
So what we need to do is run a four loop so that
we can get each and every product that we have. So
we will have four. I equal to zero. I is smaller
than Jason decode response dot body. If we just
do response.body.link, it'll give us like 100
characters or so, because the response dot body
is a string and we're getting that strings link.
But in, if we do Jason decode, it'll convert it
into a list format that we want and grab
its link. Then we will just do I, plus plus
then we will just do product list.ad, which is
this. And we need to add product over here. So,
well, first of all, what we need
to do is product dot from Jason
and enter the product. Now, what is the
product going to be response dot body,
whatever it sends us at a particular index,
which is this four loops index that we have.
But you can see from Jason excepts, a string.
If we use Jason decode, it doesn't give us
a string. So what we need to do is rather
this Jason, from Jason, with Jason in code,
and in that we'll have Jason decode so that we can
pass in response dot body at particular index. I
let me format this so that I can explain it to you
again. If it's not clear, basically what we are
doing is we are having product list, which is a
list of products and empty for now. We are adding
them. Then we are using product from Jason, which
we got from Jason serialization. When we created a
product model, then we are converting it. Let's
say we are converting it over here. We have
response to our body. We are converting that into
a map or a format using which we are able to get
the products, Jason, a particular products, Jason,
at that particular index, since we are looping it.
And then we are encoding that because from Jason
accepts a strength source, we can't just pass in
Jason decode, right? So if I just try to do this,
it's not great because it'll give us an object.
So now it's not giving any error because Jason
decode is other type dynamic. But when we run it,
it'll give us a runtime error because from Jason
will accept a string. Jason decode will not give
us string. Finally, we will use Jason in Cordova
so that we can use a string and it converts
adjacent to a string. And then we are converting
it into a model and adding it to a product list.
Great. This was a bit of twist and trick, but
that's cool for us. We can solve that after
that. We just need to return that product list and
cool. We are done. Now. We just need the switch,
all products to run whenever we start the screen.
So now we need to go to the post screen. And if
you want rename it to product screen
and call the init state function.
And then here we are going to call fetch or
products. And we can't turn that function
of admin services. This function over a
year in the innate state because innate
state cannot be turned asynchronous. If I do
it over year, it'll not give us any error,
but in the runtime, it'll give us error because
in state can't be asynchronous. So to avoid that,
you can either do it and change dependencies.
Otherwise you can just create a separate function,
fetch all products, which can be asynchronous
later on, and obviously create an instance
of admin services over year in case you're
wondering why I do it globally every time.
That's simply because if we have more
admin services feature that we want to use,
we don't have to use admin services
dot, fetch, all products or anything.
In that case, we can just use Ironman
services instance and get all products.
And we've passed in the context and you can
see it has a return type of list of products.
So let's await it. And also to display it,
we will need a list of products to show up.
So what we can do is create list, list of product,
which can be nullable called products. And this
is nullable and not empty because here we need
to show a loading bar. As long as we don't Fe
the products, which can take some time, right? We
are sending, we are getting data from the server.
So as long as the data is being fetched,
we want to show a loading indicator.
Now, whenever we fetch all the products,
you might see a bit of delay now
to put that loading indicator, we are going to
check if it wasn't an empty list, if it was an
empty list, I suppose we are going to check.
If products.is empty, then we are going to
show a loader, otherwise this, but the thing is
initially even if fetch all products doesn't have
any product. For example, before we have added any
product that you, the element is using the app for
the very first time, and there are no products at
all, even then the products list will be empty.
So that will cause our app to continuously show
a loading indicator, but that's not the case. We
have already fetched it. That's why we are using
Nu type layer so that we can check if products
is equal to Nu, that means that the data has not
been fetched. And if it's empty, that means that
the data has been fetched because list of product
is always going to return product list. Uh,
if it's empty, then it's not going to add and
return and empty list. At least now let's create
a constant aware called actually a widget
aware called loader.dot. And we can import
material dot for that, create a state list. Widget
called this dateless widget, call this loader.
And basically we just need to return a centered
child showing a circular progress indicator.
Obviously mark this as constant, nothing
else is needed. You can specify the color
of this and all of that in loader. But in our
case, we've already said in the main door dot
the theme of our application, and that's exactly
what we want to show. So we have the loader
Pass cons and actually remove this colon sweet.
Now, still it won't show us anything. And that's
mainly because, well, we need to run set state so
that it fetches all the products, which can take
some time. So after the widget has been rebuilt
completely, you know, it'll show us the loader and
then it'll set state that yeah, the loading part
has been completed. Now let's get our terminal and
restart our application just to see if there's any
error. And now you can see loader is continuously
displaying. The reason for that is pretty simple.
You can see the error showing here as well.
Your in provider, we have not set listen to
faults, even if, even since we are outside
of this post screen, you know, build context
function. So now let's restart our application
and we are still seeing this loading indicator.
The problem again is that we are fetching all
the products, but we are not saved it in the
products variable. So let's quickly save it
and restart the application
Here. You can see, we are seeing this
again. We can restart the application,
we get it very quickly, but for a very small
time, you could have seen the loading indicators
showing up. Now let's display this products on
the screen for that. It's pretty simple. We have
the body here. We just need to replace the body
with whatever we want to show. So first of all,
we just need to show a grid view builder. So here
we have the design of our application. This is
how we want to make it. Well, you can see this is
the design and this design might seem very similar
to the single products that we had created. If you
remember, we had created single product.dot widget
product widget. We are going to reuse this widget
over year, even though it's in another feature,
it's pretty good. We are just going to reuse
that feature everywhere now. So first of all,
we need a grid delegate. So the grid delegate
is going to be constantly a grid delegate
with fixed cross access count. Mainly how many
products do you want to show on this? Uh, in a
row side thing in horizontal direction, how
many products do you want to show? Well,
I just want to show two.
And then the item builder,
which will give us context and index and we go
into return something. So now in the item builder,
we are going to get first of all, the product
data. So let's save it in product data, variable,
product data, equal to products
Which can never be null index. And we are saying,
and we are assuring that this can never be null
because we are already checking your, if the
product is null, we are going to show the loader
and it'll keep showing the loader as long as it's
not. So here we can be sure that the product
is not Nu. Then we need to return a column.
We are not returning just a product, single
product, because it's just displaying to us.
The list of the products is right. I mean, sorry,
the image of the product here. We also need to
display the text and the delete I icon. So
for that, we are going to return a column
With children and the first child is going to
be of the size box. We are going to give it a
specific height of one 40 saying this is a child,
which is the single product. Now single product
will receive a type of image. So let's pass in
the image, which will be product data dot images.
At zero. You can see that images can be a list
of string, but we only want to access the very
first element on that because we can't display a
carousal image on that. You know, it, it is going
to look very viewed. And now finally we want a row
so that we can display the text and the delete.
So let's quickly create a row with some children
and obviously main access alignment as main
access, alignment.space evenly. Then the children
is going to have an expanded child of text saying
product data.name. Overflow is going to be text
overflow dot SIS. We have already looked at
this logic, so I'm not explaining it again and
again. And then max line is two. If you want,
you insert it to 3, 4, 5, whatever, but let's keep
it two so that it looks good enough. After that
We need an I can button so that we can create a
delete option. We're not going to create a delete
option right now, but we will look at it later on.
So we have I cans dot delete underscore outline,
and also put a cons where yeah,
cool. Now we are getting this error
and that error is coming mainly because
we have not specified the item count in
our grid view builder. So the item count is
products.link, and also make sure to pass, not
then click on restart. And here we have
it. We are able to display the products.
Now let's add another product. So we
will have a bottle so that, you know,
we just have some other category. So let's
say stainless steel, less steel bottle.
This is good. Non rusty bottle price will be,
let's say $30. And the quantity will be 200 and we
are going to mark it as essentials, then click on
sell. And the product has been added successfully.
If you're not able to see it, don't worry. If you
come back, ER, you can see stainless tail bottle
just need to refresher. Great. All right, now
let's just work on the delete product as well.
Since we are, ER, I know I said that we will touch
that later, but now let's just get done with it.
I'll close the loader file and in the admin
or yes, let's make this as an exercise for you
Create a route using which we will be able to
delete the product. I'm not giving you any clues
for this. Try to use the functions, which we
haven't touched before actually, but you have
told to you about it. So try it on your own and
let me know in the comments, if you could do it,
were you able to do it? If not, don't worry
about it. We'll create the API together
so that we are using admin router dot
get slash admin slash delete product.
Obviously we are going to do admin, call
this as an asynchronous call back function
and have this. Now, obviously this is not
going to be get, this is going to be post
because we need to send in a body of the idea
of the post that we want to delete or the index.
So here we are obviously going to have tri cash
blocks. So I'll just copy it from here. I'm tired
of writing it again and again, and now in the
restaurant status, we have T message. But a year
what we are going to do is first of all, grab the
ID from request dot body. Then we want to find the
product and delete it. So for that, I've already
mentioned about it. We will use product dot,
find by ID and delete. This is the function
that is given. So we'll find by ID the product
and then delete that product pretty simple.
So we'll just pass in ID and then we will do
product is equal to automate product save so
that we save the updated list in our database.
And then rest Jason send in the product that was
deleted. Now there's no need for this, but just to
send a status code of 200, you're doing this.
Now we can come to the admin services
class and in year we will create a
function called void delete product
and like other functions we
are going to have required
build context, then product that we want
to delete and then, uh, void callback
of on success. Now earlier we saw
that whenever we created a product,
let me just type it out. Then I can explain. So
earlier we saw that whenever we created a product
or fetched all the products and then maybe
added a product you saw that we had to
refresh the screen. That means go over here.
And again, come back to see that new element
now to resolve this. What we can do is except from
the parameter on success argument. When we do this
in the, on success, what we will do is in the
post screen, whenever we call this method, we will
take the products and remove that product
that we just deleted in the database as well.
So on the client side, also, we are
deleting what the user sees and even on the
server side, so on success with the will help us
with that because we are not giving the, because
if we don't take it from the, uh, parameter, what
will happen is we won't be able to call set state
let's suppose we pass in the product list, which
is this product. We pass it away and then delete
the product. But to display it on the screen,
again, we need to call set state. We can't call
it an admin services. It's not a stateful widget.
So for that purpose, we are having on success,
passed in through the parameter. Now rest of the
things are going to stay pretty similar. So what
I can do is copy this, go down again and paste it
away up. Now obviously we'll make some changes.
Now we don't need to create product and cloud
all of that stuff. So let's remove all of that.
Obviously we need to put in asynchronous and
synchronous and in the headers, we want to pass
that, but product, we don't want to send in the
product. We just want to send in the ID of the
product. We can pass in the product to Jason, but
instead of sending that whole, what we can do is
just pass in ID. So that will be ID and then pass
in product.id. And obviously Jason encode this
and there we have it ID send, and we obviously
have the headers done. Make sure to add that
then in the error handling on success part, we'll
just pass in the on success, call back function.
Cool. Now we can take this delete product and
use it in our function. So here we can create
wide delete product. And let me just type it
again. And it'll take in product argument,
because even here we don't know which product has
to be deleted. Only when we click on that button,
we will get to know which product has to be
deleted and obviously the index so that we can
delete it from the client side as well. So now
we can use admin services dot delete product.
Now context is there. Product is
passed in now in the own success.
What do we need to do? I would highly recommend
you to try it on your own and think about it.
Well, it's pretty simple, right? We just take the
products and then remove at that particular index
that we get it. So in the grade view builder,
we have access to the index. So with that index,
we will remove that particular product simple. And
now we need to reflect the changes on the screen.
So we need the build function to rebuild
again. So we can call search state easy. Our
work is done only if it success, it will remove
otherwise it won't remove it. Now we can go down
and your call, delete product pass
in the product, which will be product
Data. And the index is obviously there
because the index is the same name.
Now we can save this much. And whenever we click
on suppose let's say iPhone 13 pro you can see,
we are getting an error over here. And we got that
error because if we go back to the admin services,
we again forgot to change our URL. So let's copy
the URL from your, and paste it over here. Pretty
stupid mistakes. You're we keep making, but
that's fine. Now, if we click on iPhone pro 13,
no document found for query this object ID.
So that error came in, mainly because if we
come back away, we have product is equal to avoid
product.save. And we don't need that. Whenever we
do product dot find by ID and delete, this will
make sure that the product is deleted and the
product is saved as well. So now we just need to
do this and then we can send adjacent of product.
I change all of this just to debug what is going
wrong, but now we know the error. We just need
to do product fine by ID and delete and then send
the product. Now, if I try it again and click on
delete, you can see we're not getting any error
anywhere. And now if I restart the application,
The product is deleted. Now, even if we go to
the MongoDB database and go to the products,
You can see query results are zero. Now
let's add, uh, some products so that we can
see them on the main screen when
we to the user side of the things.
So after this, obviously we are going to move to
the Mo user side. We are not going to work in the
admin anymore because there are no features to add
in admin, as long as we don't allow the user to
send the products to anyone. Right? So now I'll
add some products like two or three, and then
see you when I change it to the user side of the
app. All right. So I've added to products there,
but I'm still on the admin screen just to
notify you that whenever we add a product,
you could see that it wasn't real time. Now having
the knowledge, how to make it look real time, you
can do this for the ad product as well, so that,
you know, it looks a good experience for the user
or, and also now we can go to the users.
I wanted to demonstrate how I'm shifting to
the user part. If you've not already noticed
here, I'm just changing the type two user
and I'm clicking on update and
then restarting the application.
Your we have it. Now, what we need to work on is
whenever I click on one of the categories, I want
to get shifted to another screen and display the
category, display the products of that category.
So for that, we are, again, coming to the home
feature, let's minimize all the, the folders
and in the home screen, we are going to pass in
another screen called category deals screen. Do,
do you obviously will import the material
dot, call it as a stateful widget because
you need to get the products. And now we
are going to create a category deal screen.
Now over here, we're going to do things a bit
differently. First of all, we are going to have
a scaffold and that's going to be normal. And
then we need an app bar that is also going to be
normal. So we can go to the admin screen, get the
admin screens app bar. So let's quickly copy that
and paste it in the app bar space, then click on
import library and in the title instead of a row,
we want to display a text that just says
that this is this category. And we are
going to get category from the constructor
so we can write final string category,
and this will be required. This dot category.
And we are receiving from the constructor so
that whenever we click on one of these screens,
we get the suppose we click on essential. So
we get the essential string and based on that,
we can fetch products away. So here, I'm just
going to write text as widget dot category,
and then the style will be obviously the black
color. So let's quickly add that style. So we have
style constant textile of color, colors.black.
Great. So now over here, after this preferred
size widget, we need to add a body and here the
body should be a column showing a list of widgets.
So the very first thing that we need is seeing
that, that the children are container of
padding. And then we need to add that pairing.
So we have sets symmetric from the horizontal
direction we have, let's say 15, and
from the vertical direction, we have 10
after that, we have to align
them. So we have alignment.top
left, and then we need to have a child saying the
text and there, this text will basically tell,
keep shopping for and the category of
that. So we have keep shopping for dollar
widget category. And I use braces
for that, because if there is
like a dot and full stop, and it's not a single
word, then we need to use brace for that.
Then obviously we need to style this
so that we can increase the font size.
The color will be black, so we don't need to
worry about that. So we have font size as 20,
and now just to view it, what we are going to
do is whenever we click on any of these buttons,
so let's go to the top categories and here, if any
of the button is clicked. So here it is. First of
all, we have to wrap this video gesture detector.
So wrap it with a widget call, gesture detector,
and then the on tap is going to be what we tell it
to be. So it'll be void navigate to category page,
and this will just receive the category that we
clicked on because you can't get access to it in
the separate function that is created, right? And
now we will just say, navigator dot, push named.
And I just realized we didn't
create a route for that. So
we need to go in the category, deal screen
and call this static string static, constant
string route name, which will be equal to slash
category deals. Then we can take this route name
and go to the router.dot,
obviously past it over year.
And this will be called category deals, screen,
route name, return, the category deal screen.
And this is not and year we need to pass
in. So here we need to pass in an argument
that is the category. So let's quickly add that
now, how do we get access to the category that
the user passes in? Well, it's very simple. We
just say that category equal to settings and
it'll be route settings because our parameter type
is your route settings and this route settings dot
arguments. And now if we save this, you can
see that the type of category is an object.
We don't want that. We want it to be
a string. So we can say as string,
because we know always the user will always
enter a string. Now we can take this category,
pass it in. And it's not a constant
value. So we can just remove that.
Cool. Now we also need a build context to where,
since this is a stateless widget and yeah,
the build context, and then finally the route
name we want to transfer it to. So it'll be
category deals, screen, or route name. And
finally the argument that we want to pass in
which can be done using this arguments argument,
and then pass in the category as the argument.
Now we can take this navigate to category page
and pass it in like this, and what do we need to
pass in? Well, first of all, context, and then
the category to get the category, we can just
pass in global variables.
So let's get access to them
dot category images, add that index
where we click and it's tighten
pretty straightforward. And here you can
see the argument type string can be assigned
to the parameter type end. So the error is
because we have passed in carousal images,
aware it is category images. And now finally year
we can put an exclamation mark because it can be
now, let's see if we click on any of this,
keep shopping for essentials. It shows up,
keep shopping for appliances. It shows up.
Now the next step is to get the details,
which we were working on aware.
So now after this container,
we need to have another container
which will be of the height one 70 and
let's make it a sized box. So we'll have a sized
box of height, one 70, since you only need to
specify the height, no other property has to be
changed and the child will be a grid view builder.
And just to tell you why we are using grid
view builder, again, it's mainly because
builder lift view builder grid view builder is
always used when we don't know the item count.
So I mean, we know the item count, but it's going
to be dynamic. It's going to keep changing. So
will is good in that because it'll only build on
demand, right? So you're, we are going to have
constant liver grid delicate with fixed cross
access count. And the cross access count is one
child aspect ratio is one point so and main
access pacing is 10. Great. Now we can have
item builder as context index and return
something. Now, as of now, item builder is
not going to return anything because we don't have
access to any of the products. So what we can do
is return a text saying hello, and we will specify
item count so that it doesn't give us error.
Like let's say 10. And obviously we'll specify
other properties like scroll direction,
which will be access dot horizontal. Then we need
some padding. So we will have padding as constant
inserts dot only. And from the left 15. So after
saving this much, we can see hello, hello. Hello
keeps showing up because we've passed in the item,
count as 10. And if we keep scrolling, we can see
all of them showing up side by side. Sweet. So
now let's create an API so that we can get all
the data of a certain category so that we
can keep displaying them. So you're in the
home you're going to create service is, and you
are, we are going to have home services dot file.
You, we are going to create home services,
create a function for that. But before that
let's quickly rename it. And then we are going
to return a future of lift of products because
essentially they're going to be products.
And we have, we have seen this pattern
already, right? So it's not a big deal. So
we just need to do fetch category products,
get the build context. So we have build context
then, uh, category of which we want to get
products. So we have required string category.
Now we can create this function and obviously we
need a need to write a lot of boiler plate code
again. So what I'm going do is go to the admin
services and copy all of this code that we have
in the fetch all products part, because we
need to fetch category products. And it's
going to be a very similar thing to that. So
obviously let's import all of the stuff again,
import HTTP as HTTP dot. Yeah, we have it now
obviously make this function asynchronous.
You should be familiar with
the patent till now, and then
import global variables, import HTTP,
error handling, and import dot convert.
And finally, the utility files show
that so that we can show the snag bar.
Great. Yeah, everything. Now let's
make some changes that we wanna make.
Well, first of all, this line is correct. This
line is correct. We need all of these. This is
for token. This is just for returning the product
list. Then your, we need to create our request.
So I can go to the product JS file and here
we don't have it. So let's quickly go down
and in the routes, we will create product JS.
And this will basically Fe us all the
products of a certain category. So obviously
again, we have to write a lot of boiler plate
code. So what I'm going to do is go to the admin
router, copy this line, paste it away, your then
copy this line, paste it away. Your, and then we
are going to create a get request so we can take
this and paste it in between. Now let's change
all of these places. So I'm going to press option
on macwas so that I can grab all of these three
things and change it side by side. So we have
product router and you have, so now we have
to pass in slash API. Now this is not, uh,
admin route. This is everyone can access a
route. So now, and finally we need products.
Now, obviously we need a middleware of odd.
So let's import that. So we have constant or equal
to require slash, and this not this, because this
is a route. So we do dot slash middleware slash
suite. So now we, first of all, I want to
look, I want you to look at this API route
that we are creating. This is a get request. We
are not doing a post request anymore because we
don't want to post any data to our server. We just
want to retrieve that data. But along with that,
we need to give a certain kind of, you know,
body to it. How do we give that body? Well,
it's not a post request. So obviously we won't
be able to give any body in the get request.
So now in the URL itself, we are going to give
the body. So how are we going to do that? Well,
the Ania URL that we have here is API slash
products, but now it'll become, and we want the,
uh, from the client side to enter something
like category is equal to, let's say essentials.
This is the URL that the client side will have to
enter so that it can get products off a certain
category. You can see that. So with exclamation
mark, we are putting a full stop or to our
path, which is the main part, which is also the
URL scheme of our product router. And then after
that, we have the name of our property, which
will give us the value of these essentials.
Another thing is, if the client side gives us
this URL, how are we going to access this value
essentials value now to access that we are going
to use this request object. Again, we use this
for request dot body. We are going to use this
for getting this essentials category as well.
So to do that, what we are going to
use request dot query dot category.
So basically request dot query
will get us anything with an,
with an, with a question mark before it.
So suppose you have another URL that is API
slash team question mark. So suppose you have
another URL, which is slash API slash let's say
Amazon. And we put in a question mark, which will
be theme equal to doc. That means if we want the
Amazon client, if Amazon client side to
be of the team, doc, then we can do this.
So now to access this dark value, what we can
do is request dot query with this, we get access
to this dark variable or the dark
parameter, whatever you wanna call it,
we get access to that. In case you want
to have something like API slash products
slash sorry, products category is equal to
essentials. If you want this kind of URL scheme,
then you'll have to use request dot pers
dot category. You can see that with this,
we get access to this essentials value, but if
we use request query, it'll get us this value.
When we use question mark, I hope that was clear.
Now we can just remove all of these comments and
get the particular API product. So what we can do
is obviously console dot log it so that I can show
it to you. So we have request dot query. We are
going to call it category and see if there's much,
obviously get the product from the models.dot
file. And what do we need to find? Well,
a category based on request query category, pretty
simple. And then we just need to return that
to the user. As simple as it gets. Now, we can
take this slash API slash products, go to this.
And instead of this URL, we want to pass in slash
API slash products. And now we need to pass in the
category, which will be category equal to,
and then we need to pass in the category,
which we have access to through the
parameters. So we have category.
Yeah, we have it. Now we need to do error
handling again. And we will get a product list
because we are using find over
here in the product route.
So it'll catch us a lot of categories so we can
just use for loop and all of this explanation and
logic. I've done it already. And then finally,
we just need to return this product list.
Now we can take this home services,
go to our category deals and get
all of the products that we need.
So what we can do is in that state,
and we are going to call
this fetch category products.
We're going to use this fetch category products,
call this asynchronous, and this will be
list of product. This is pretty similar to what
we've already done. So I could have given this
as an exercise. Now I think about it, but
that's fine. If you had paused the video
and done it by yourself, that's a very
good initiative by yourself. Try to do
it more often throughout this video, because now
everything is going to probably be similar except
the search functionality and all of that part.
I think it's pretty similar. So now let's quickly
build the app. We have home service,
home service equal to home services,
and then we can take this home
services and call home services
dot fetch category products
pass in the required category.
So the category is widget dot category because
you're getting it through the construction and
then we need to call straight so that the entire
widget rebels or the build functional, sorry.
Now we have access to this fetch category product
and the product list. So you're obviously first
check in the body that if product list is equal to
another, then we need to return a constant loader.
Otherwise we need to return a column. Now we can
come down and scroll your, so we need to return
a column which will have certain
children with a size box of height, one
30, then a child of decorated box.
And the decorated box will have
decoration of box decoration.
So now we need a border which will be border dot
all and passing the color as colors.black 12,
which will be 0.5. I'm not explaining this code
away because we have already written so much of
UI code that now it should be very familiar what
all these properties mean and what will come out
the screen. We will see that later on. So now
we need to pass in a child in the decorated box,
which will be a padding of padding cons, edge,
inserts dot all, and pass in a value of 10.
Then we need to pass in a child again, which
will be image.network. And now we need to get
this image network. Now, what is this image
network? Well, first of all, let's get clear
with the product aware. So product will be
product list that we just created at the top.
And that particular index that we get aware
as we saw builder will return to as an index.
So at that particular index, we
are going to have this product.
Now we have access to that product. So now
we will have image.network as product images
at zero, because images is our list. So we
need to get the very first thing after saving
this much. Let's see what we get outputted on
the screen. So let's restart our application.
And if I click on essentials, yep. Nothing shows
up. And that's probably because in our item, count
your, I passed in a static value of 10. I
have to chain that to product list link,
and obviously put an exclamation
mark before this product list.
Now, if I restart the application and close all
of these error messages, go to, let's say mobiles,
we cannot get slash API slash products. So that
reason is mainly because you have not connected
this product, product router to our index Rogers
file. So let's quickly connect it. We've forgotten
it multiple times. So it's a good reminder for
you to not forget and not make mistakes like me.
Now, if I click on restart, can restart and go to
mobiles. Again. There's nothing over here to see
appliances. We have the little MacBook
showing up. That's great. Now let's
return something else below the size box.
So now the very first thing we need to return
is again, a container which will be over here
in the alignment. So we have alignment.top left,
then a padding, which will be cons
sets only. And we need to do left zero,
top five, write 15. So let's quickly
write that. Then we need a child which
will just say the product name. So we have text as
product.name and then max line is going to be one.
And if it exceeds that, then we can just
start an overflow saying, text overflow
dot SIS, having this much done. Let's see what we
are getting. And I'm pretty satisfied with this.
Now, if I go to, let's say fashion, there's
nothing to see appliances yard, MacBook
essentials. We should see a bottle and we see
that great. It works exactly as we want it.
So now the next thing we need to work
on is after fetching these categories,
we need to work on this search part.
So whenever we search for something,
it should show up. For example, if I type S
then it should show me stainless steel products
on another screen. So let's create the UI and
API for that. So here we are in the home screen
and here, what we need to do is click on the
search bar and whenever the user hits on enter,
then we will get some value and then we need to
navigate to the search screen. So, first of all,
let's close and minimize all the features folder
except the home part. And in the features,
we will create new feature called search.
And this search will have, will obviously
a screens folder. And in that folder, we
are going to create search screen, do dot.
Then we are going to import the material dot,
create a state full widget called search screen
and call this a constant. And now we will need
route name for this. So we will create constant
static string, route name equal to slash search
screen. Let's say after that, we can take this
route name and register it in the router. So
let's go quickly over there and register it.
So this will be called search screen
dot route name. We have imported that
and we will get search query that we need to
pass in. So again, we need to pass that to the
construction because every time we are on the
home screen, we enter some value. Then we will
transmit that value to other screen. So you are
along with that, we will need final strings search
query, which will be equal to well, not equal to,
we have to generate a constructive based on that.
So we have required this dot search query. Also
change this to a scaffold so that we don't see
a container after that. We can just take in the
search query and pass it at the search query.
Now you can see the name parameter category is
required. So let's see why we need that. And
that's because we haven't changed the search
screen away. So let's change it quickly.
And you, we have it. We have registered the
route. Now, whenever the user clicks, we
need to navigate to other screens. So here we are
gonna create a function called navigate to search
screen. We will get a query. So we'll have
string query and use navigator use navigator
dot, push named and pass in the context. And the
route name will be search screen or trout name.
Cool. Now let's take this navigate to search
screen and find the text form field where we
will pass in as the on field submitted this
navigate to search screen. So whenever this
field is submitted, we will get certain value that
we will output it on the screen. So just to test,
if it's working till now, what I'm going to
do is pass in the body, a centered widget,
which will be the widget search query. So if I
type hello over here and then click on enter,
and we are getting this error because here we
haven't passed in the argument. So the argument
that we need to pass in is the query. Don't forget
to do that. Make sure to add this. Now, if we,
again, type in hello and click on enter, you can
see hello showing up. If I type something else,
let's say, great click on enter.
We see great sweet.
So now let's work on the search services instead
of designing it first, we are going to work on
the services part so that we can create our own
API first fit those products and then display
it on the screen. That would be real farm.
So yeah, I'm going to create search services
file. And obviously let's remove the capitalized
S create a class called search services,
and now we need to finish the search product.
So what we can do is go to the home services
and copy the same thing that we've done
earlier. So let's quickly copy all of this
because we are going to fetch certain things and
it's again, going to be a get request. So yeah,
we have that. So let's import all of these stuff
that is needed quickly. So we have provider
user provider, we have imported, we need
provider, let's import HTTP with name spaces.
Then we need the global variable. Then we need
the error handling. Then we need Jason encode and
decode and the shown bar utility. Great. Now we
have that. We have copied the same function again,
because we are going to fetch the same product.
So we are fetch the product. So we are going to
have HTTP get request. We just need to change the
URL and we need to return the product list again,
because we need to display them on the
screen, right? That's right. And now,
instead of category here, we need the search
query. That's the change we need to make. And
you name it as fetch searched product, your
change, the API. So our API is going to be
API slash products slash search,
and then dollar search query. Now,
if you don't understand this API, that's fine.
Now we are going to go there and create it out.
But basically what we are doing is slash API
so that everyone is accessing slash products
so that, you know, that's a convention of our
URL. Then we need to search. And then we are
passing in the search query. Since this is a get
request. If I just show it to you via get request,
doesn't allow us to add any body element.
That's why we need to pass it in the
URL itself. Now, how do we get access to this
extra search query that we are passing in? We
have already talked about it when we were creating
in the, uh, an API in the products dot GSFI.
So when we created slash API slash products,
you saw, we use rec query category because we
are using question mark you. But when I, I told
you that whenever we use something like this
suppose search, then we are going to use requests,
category, or requests, whatever is the name,
or just request paras.
You get the idea. So that's what
we are going to use. Let me remove this console
log it's not needed. And also this URL. It was
just to demonstrate it to you. And now I would've
given to you given this to you as an exercise,
or you can actually do it as an exercise to
create an API, create a get request to search
products and get them
well pretty state forward. But this is going to
be a bit different. If you want to try it out,
Google it out and use it and find the correct
solution. You're free to do it. But if you want,
we can go along. This is a bit different from what
we've done in the past. So obviously we are going
to copy all of this and call this slash API slash
products. But after that, we want slash search.
If we go to the search services, you can see we
have slash search and then the search query. Now
we want to get access to the search query. So what
we will do is slash search and the name with this,
we can get access to the name. So just putting a
colon over here, we get access to it. Now, if we
pass something over and suppose we get a request
to the URL that we have already passed in the
client side. So we have slash API slash products
slash search slash let's say, I wanna find
an iPhone. So I pass an I. So we want to get the
access to this. I to get access to this, I, now I
can simply use request paras.name because you've
named it as name. Now, if I type in over, let's
say hello now to access this part, we can ask dot
hello. If I have another per, after this, let's
say, great. I can access this great using request.
You can see, this is how easy it is, even if it's
all hello. And it gives us the autocorrect option.
That means we are doing it everything correctly.
So now having that idea, what we are going to do
as to remove this and make it an readable format.
And now what are we to find? Well, obviously this
part is going to change. We are going to save it
in products and we are going to innovate, use
product dot fine, but the condition is going to
be bit different. Remember when we use rejection,
our application, we are going to use rejects. Now
earlier we used reject so that we could validate
our email. And we found out that REDX is used to,
is used in search patterns. So exactly
what we want to wear. We need to
use search patterns so that we can get that.
Now mongoose and MongoDB have built in support
for that. So what we can do is pass in the name
because you want to provide products by their name
and then pass in the rejects. So we have dollar
rejects and then pass in request.paras.name,
<affirmative> name, and then options.
I, with this, we are able to find the
products based on their name, even if the name
is iPhone and we find out and we type in, I,
it will features this product, which is pretty
cool. And then we just send in this product,
nothing else after creating this API, which was
very simple. And actually, before going there,
an alternate of approach you could have taken is
finding the product based on this name itself.
So we just pass in name as request dot
paras name. Now this would've worked. If
you passed an iPhone, if your product
name was iPhone and you passed an iPhone,
then only the product would show up, but
it wouldn't be a search pattern to get
search patterns and some products with similar
names. We have to use the part of RegX part.
Great. Now we can go to the search services,
pass in the URL that we have correctly.
We need all of this. Again, I've
explained it to you earlier.
You must type it out so that you get a hang
of it. And if you have a better approach, make
sure to cry that approach first and then use it in
your application. If you find that as a bit of a,
and then you're going to return the product
list. Now let's go to the search screen,
use the init state function, and we've done that
loads of time. So we are going to do it again.
So we have list of product called products. Now
we can take this product and set it equal to,
well, first of all, we need to get, create a new
function. So we have fetch searched to product.
Then we need the switch search product function
created. And now we will have products equal to
and well, final search services, search services,
equal to search services. We can take this,
pass it in and fit the search product pass
in the context and the search query widget,
which is widget dot search query because we
are receiving it through the construction
and ADE. This now, obviously we need to set state
because we changed the value of products. And now
here we can check. If products is equal, equal
to Nu, then we need to return a constant loader.
You might be familiar with this pattern already by
now. It's just a practice of writing it again and
again. So you're used to it and you get confident
to build any other application that you want.
So now if we restart it, let's see what we
get. You are basically let's type in high.
So yeah, let's type in high and
you can see high is showing up,
but we are not printed any products and it's
not giving us any error again, your as well,
that means it is a success. So now let's build
the UI of this app. So here we have the UI of
the app that we need to create. Well, first
of all, is the same app bar. So let's quickly
create this app bar at the top right now. So we
can go to the home screen, copy this app bar,
paste it in the search screen. After that import
everything, we need to create this function,
but we can import this and now go to the home
screen again, just to import that function,
not import actually create that function. And now
past it over here there, we have it. Great. Now,
if you come aware, looks right now, the next
thing we need to work on is first minimize
this so that it looks less gigantic.
And in the body we are gonna have
column and in the children, we are going
to display, first of all, the address box.
So we have already created a widget for that,
which is called address box. Let's have that
Great. Also remove the loader from here and paste
it in the body, put a space AOR. Yep. Otherwise,
you know, the scaffold won't be there and it would
be an ugly bar that is showing up continuously,
which is not what we want after that. We
need a sized box. So we have constant sized
box of high 10. Then we need an expanded widget so
that it can take whatever spaces available because
the rest of the space is all for our search
products. And we need to display a list view
builder so that unless view builder will give
us an error. If we don't specify some height and
what height do we want? Well, all the available
height for us. So we can quickly wrap it with an
expander widget. After that list, view builder,
we'll get a context and an index, and then
we need to return a product or a widget that we
will call search products and create it manually.
But we also need to specify item count for
that. And our item count is products link
here. We earned to return the search
product. So let's create a widget for that.
In the widget, we will have searched
Product dot.
We will import material dot, create a
stateless widget, call it searched product.
Then we will receive the product from
the parameter so that we can display
their details successfully in the product.
After that, we are going to return a column
because if you see, let's break it down.
So if I break it down really quick for you,
we have a column widget inside of which we have
A row. And in that row, first of all, we have
this image. And after that, we have, again,
a column with that column. We have a text that
is showing this a rating widget for which we
are going to use a package, then a text again,
just to show the price and then eligible for
free shipping and in stock that is there. So now
we are going to return a column, the children,
and the first child is going to be a container
with some margin, because you can see there's some
margin from the top, from the left and the right
side for the top. We use size box, but we need it
from the left and the right side. So we are gonna
have a container so that we can pass in certain
margin. Then we need constant edge inserts, dots,
symmetric. And in the horizontal direction, we
need 10 because they're both left. And right, if
you're wondering why I'm always using horizontal,
if you click over here and come away, you can see
horizon horizontal is for the value of left and
right, both vertical is for top and bottom instead
of specifying dot only and write 10 left 10,
what you can do as horizontal 10, after that, we
need a child and the child is going to be wrote as
I talk, we need an image and the description of
the product later on. So we have image.network.
And you're the first image that we're going
to show is product dot images at zero.
If you want, you can create a carousal, but it
would be really laggy and wouldn't make app look,
feel really good. You know, so here
we will, app fit as box fit, dot,
hide, fit height, and let's see
why we're getting this error.
And that's mainly because here we pass in the
children for the row. So let's pass it in,
take this image.network, past it in. And well,
the height should be 1 35, which should be 1 35.
Now let's go over here just to return the search
product and see what result we are getting
till now, and then pass in the product
for us. The product is going to be product
products at index, and there we have
it because this is a list and we're
accessing a particular product using
their index. Now we save this much
and restart the app, open up the DVA console
and the, and let me just to remember the
products that we are. So we have stainless
steel product. So I'm going to type in big S
because it's in small S so I'll just type in this
and you can see stainless steel pops up amazing.
Now, after that, we need to display the products
of the, uh, sorry, the description of this.
So we will have, again, a column with children.
And the very first thing we're going to have is
a container of with 2 35, then padding
of constant agent sets dot symmetric in
the horizontal direction, 10, then a child just
displaying the products name. So we have product
name, passing the style as
constant textile of phone size 16.
And now if it see the stainless steel pops up,
it'll go up as, and when we get new products,
but also let's add max lines as two
after which it'll just cut it down so
that it doesn't exceed. You can see that,
then we need another container. So let's copy
this, paste it down. We need a container of it,
2 35, but the padding year will change.
The padding will become from the left.
We are going to have 10, sorry, left
then. And from the top, we are going to have five
and changes to only. Then the child is going to be
The stars because you are the next stars for
stars. You're going to create a separate reusable
widget over your, in common. So we have stars
dot dart. Let's import the material dart create
a stateless widget for stars and your, we
are going to make use of an external package.
So the package we'll be using is this fluter
rating bar. We can copy that, paste it down your,
and you can see it supports on all the
platforms. So as soon as Google pay apple pay,
start supporting Android iOS. It does support
that, but Linux macro, web, and windows,
we can start deploying it everywhere because
none of the other packages need any other thing.
So obviously we are going to
get the rating from you. And
for now, we are, as long as you're not
working on the rating section, we're going to
tell that the rating is going to be a static value
just after we create the rating. We are going to
change those ratings. So you're in the terminal.
We are going to pass in rating bar indicator, and
we are using rating bar indicator because
it is only a view, view, only visit.
And you want the direction
to be access horizontal.
After that, the item count is going to be five
and the rating is going to be the rating that we
get from the construction item, count specifies.
How many stars do we wanna see? And rating will
tell us how many stars should be filled. Then
we specify a fixed item size, which will be 15,
then an item builder, which will give us
context. And other thing that we know don't need,
and we will just have to display an
I icon. What is I icon that we want
to display? Well, I icons.star and
the color should be global variables
Dot secondary color, because that's
the golden color that we need.
Now we can take the stars, paste it in instead of
the product's name and pass in the rating for now,
it's gonna be a static value. So just to see if
it's working or not, we are going to have four
and mark this as constant, save it here. We have
it. Four stars are filled and it looks great.
Next thing again is going to be a container.
So let's quickly copy this, paste it down.
And what do we need to show? Well, the price.
So let's quickly have a width of 2 35 again,
but the, we, again, we are going to have the same
pattern as the rating. One, we can copy that and
paste it away, and the text is going differ. So
yeah, we are going to use string interpolation
because we want to use a dollar sign. And as we
saw for dollar sign, we're going to have dollar
dollar product price. Max line is set to two
and phone size should be 20. If we save this
dollar 10 shows up, let's just bold it.
So we have font, weight, font, weight,
And now it's bolded looks sick. After that,
we can just copy this container just to write
free shipping and in stock. So we can have two
of the same thing. And we want your only left
as 10. And we'll just say a text with nothing
as a styling and say, eligible for free
shipping. And we can have a constant after
that we will have in stock. So we will have
in stock. Max lines will be two, and the
color is going to be colors dot peel. Let's
quickly write that out and remove the constant
from everywhere. Press on command, full stop,
and add a constant modifier. Instead of passing
it over here, we need to pass it over here.
Great. Now we can see it's looking
similar to this and it looks great
exactly the way we want it to look.
So now, just to check if it's working or not, I'll
write Mac and click on enter. You can see MacBook
air M one showing up. And if this photo looks
ugly to you, what you can do is change it. So
in image.network, we will have fit with. And if we
save this much, this whole picture comes in. Now,
the next thing we need to work on is whenever
we click on any of the products, we want to see
their details all. So your is a design of the
product detail screen that we need to create.
So what we need to do is minimize, let's say
some of the folders and in the features folder
create a new folder called product details,
and then click on the again, folder sign so
that we can create screens folder and then
create the product details, screen.dot file.
So here we are going to import material dot,
create a state, fold widget, and call this product
details. Screen, obviously add a cons
to conveyor, and now we want return
A scaffold with an app bar, right? If you come
back to the way you can see, this is a bar that
we need to create. So to create that app bar,
we will go to the home screen, copy this method,
paste it over here, then import search screen.
After that, we can again, go to this home screen.
So we just need to copy this app bar, copy
this and paste it in the product detail screen.
So let's come over here and paste it down there.
After that, we will need global variables import,
and we have already passed in the function
aware great. Now to test this application,
uh, test the screen till now we can have
a static, constant string route name,
which will be slash product detail screen. So we
can just name it like this. And obviously we need
a product so that we can display its details,
and we will require this to the construction.
So let's click on generate
construction and here we have it.
Now let's register this in the
router.dot file. So copy this,
paste it down here. We will have product detail,
screen, route name, then call this product
detail screen pass in the product. And the product
will be saved from the argument so that you are it
as product. And we will treat this as a product
and now just pass in product away. And our router
is set as well. Now we can close all the safe
files, go to the product detail screen, because
that's what we need to style. And in your, after
this app bar, we need to work on the body section.
So let's see what we need. Well, first of all,
we need the ratings part and the idea of the
product. So let's quickly create that. So you
will have a single child scroll view because
you can see different screen sizes. And as
I mentioned before, different screen sizes
will lead this to scroll. And if there's too
much of description, if added for any product,
we want it to be scrollable. So after having that,
we can create a child which will be a column.
And then in the more column we need children and
the first child we are going to have your, is this
row. So let's create this row. It's children will
be text saying the product's ID. So we will have
widget product ID so we can see that it can
be Nu. So yeah, we have it. ID can never be Nu
after that, we can have star widget, which will be
reused and the rating will be well for now static.
So we can just pass in forward. After
we calculate and add the rating part,
we can change this to something real. After that,
we need to add the main access alignment, uh, main
access alignment space between and save this much
also to see whatever result we need. We can just
use broader product detail, screen dot route name.
So where do we want it? Exactly? Well, whenever we
click on this category and click on this product,
so we need to go to the category deal screen. And
whenever we return a certain product here, we need
to wrap it with a widget call, gesture detector,
and we'll pass in the on tap,
which will be just navigator
dot push name. And then we need to pass in
the route name, which will be product details,
screen, route name, and then finally not to forget
arguments, which will be the product after that.
Let's save this much and here we come. So if you
click away here we are. We're seeing the correct
things. Now we want a little bit of padding from
the side. So what we can do is go to the products
layer and in the row, we are going to add a
padding. So wrap to the padding of <inaudible> dot
all eight. Now this looks better after this. The
next thing is the title. So let's have a padding
widget again, so that we can leave space from the
side and the top. So we will have padding constant
edge insert dot from the vertical side, we want
20. And from the horizontal side, we need 10.
After end, after that, we need a
child in it, and the child is going to
show the widgets product name. So you'll
have widget product name and let's
configure the size for it. So it will be
constant. Textile font size will be, let's say 15.
After saving this much, you can see stainless
steel. What is showing now in case you wanted to
start from here? What we can do is in the column,
pass in cross access alignment as cross access,
alignment dot start. Now we can come aware
and you can see it's showing up pretty cool.
After that, we need the image and this image is
not just one image. It's going to be a carousal of
images. So what we can do is after this padding,
again, create a carousal slider. And for that,
we have already created a widget. So let's
just copy this, paste it away. Is it aware
and import carousal, slider aware the item is
widget dot product dot images that we need to map
through. And every image will give us I, and all
of that is fine. Now let's remove this current
thesis and port comma and your VRIT looks great,
just that the image size isn't matching. So we can
change this height to 300, not this height, let's
say the height away. We can change it to 300. And
yeah, this looks bigger and cleaner. After that,
you can see, we need a bit of divider or spacing
for that. We are going use something cool. We are
just going to use a container, but in that we are
gonna pass in the color property of colors.black
twelves with that, we get this kind of layout, but
you can't see it. So let's increase its height.
So that will be five. And after doing that much,
you can see this great divider exactly like Amazon
showing up after that, we need to show this price.
So after the container, this is a deal price. Now
observe the differences in the text here. You
will see that the deal price is a small text,
and this is a bigger text in different
color. And as you've already seen, we can use
raw widget for it. Otherwise we can use rich
text and text span. That's exactly what we are
going to do. So obviously have a padding
so that it doesn't mix up all. And you'll
have insert dot all eight after which we will
have a child of text span, rich text, sorry,
that will take in a text. And the text is
going to be a text span. And in that text
span, we're going to enter the
deal price. So we'll have deal
price. And also it is a name document.
So we need to pass in text via,
also put a trail income. After that, we need
to specify some style, which will be constant
textile. And the font size will be 16. Color
will be colors.black. Even if you don't mention
it will be black, but since we are having a
difference of colors in the next text span,
let's mention it. And then finally we have
font weight, which will be font, weight.
Let's put some comas and also put,
uh, spacing over so that in the next
children child that we have, there will be
a letter of space. Great. Now it looks good.
Now we just need, uh, price. So for
price, we can pass in, in the rich text,
in the text span, sorry, children. And
the first child is gonna be a text span.
So let's just copy this text span, paste it in
over a year and we need another parent thesis.
And here we need to display the price.
So obviously we are going to have dollar
which will be back slash dollar and
then dollar widget product price.
Now all of our warnings faded away because
this child, one of the children has a text,
which is dependent on a state variable. So to
say, since you're, depending on the structor,
it can be a constant value because it, it
can change time. It will not be constant.
Now, if you come aware, we
can see no difference in the
text, font size or anything. So let's make
it 22 and change this to colors, rot red.
Now, if we save this much, this still looks, you
know, this flashes in the eyes, the red color. So
we can change this to font, weight w 500 after
that, this looks great. Now the next thing is
leaving some space. We want the description. So
let's copy this much. After the rich text, we are
again going have PAing, but we will add that later
on. So we have widget product dot description,
and also let's put it after the PAing widget
and then see this stainless steel. Great.
Now we will just wrap it with a pairing visit
because we want all cons agencies dot all eight
after saving this much, you can see this looks
neat, but when we have a bigger description,
this all will make sense.
After that,
after that, you will see that we need a kind of,
again, this container, so we can just copy it,
paste it down here, and then we need the
buttons. So we need a buy now button and
add to card button. So obviously we are
gonna have custom button text will be by now
And on tap will be empty function
or an anonymous function for now,
after that, we can just see what we are getting
this isn't looking really good. So what we can add
is a padding widget again, and in that pattern,
which we are going to have constant edge and
search dots symmetric from the vertical direction,
10 and from the horizontal direction also 10.
So what we can have is 10 overall, instead of
vertical 10 horizontal 10. I didn't realize
that while writing the code myself, but now we
have it. Great. Now we can just copy this again
and paste it down after a sized box of 10
so that it, they both don't stick together.
And now this will change to add to card.
Now, if you come back,
you can see the color change, oh, sorry.
The product two buttons showing up,
but now we need to change the color for
that. We can go to the custom button
and here, here, we will accept a few
arguments. So we'll have final color
color, and this is only needed for product. It
is page. So we can have this draw color with not
required and no default value. This is not needed
because here we are going to pass in the style,
the primary color, which can be Nu you can hover
over this and see, this can be Nu. So this can
also be null. And if we don't specify anything,
primary color will be null and will default to
the main theme of our application, which is this
orange color. Now, if you go to this, add to card
and pass in the color, and the color is going
to be constant color from RGBO 2 54, 2 1 6 19
and one. And if we save this much, you can see the
difference, but now we need to change this color
as well. So now to change the custom buttons color
inside of the text, what we can have is a style
And the style will be a textile where the, where
the color will be a conditional operator. So we
will check here. If color is null, that means that
the user does not enter anything. Then we want it
to be white because here we never mentioned
anything, right? That's why the color was
white aware, but in case we mention
it, we want it to be colors.black,
simple enough. And now we get the black
color. Great. After this padding widget,
we can have a size box again of the high 10, and
after that a container. So let's quickly copy that
and save this much. Yeah, we have
it now. Final thing, if we see
the rate product, so the rate, the product is
going be fairly simple. We're going to have a
pattern of text. So let's quickly just copy one
of the text. Let's copy this one, paste it down.
Your, so the engine sets will be symmetric.
And from the horizontal direction we need 10.
Then in the child, the text is
going to be read the product.
Then we can have some styles passed in. So
we'll have style constant textile, and let's
remove constant from everywhere and put it in the
paring widget because we know everything is static
over. So the textile is gonna be font size 22,
and font weight will be font, weight dot bold.
After saving this much, we
operate the product scene.
Now, finally, we want the rating bar that we have
created at the top as well. But now we can't use
the same widget because as I said, it was view
only. Now we want to make changes. Whenever we
tap on it, we want to rate the product. So
for that purpose, we are going to create
rating bar dot builder, which is another widget
provided by the same package, aim package, flatter
rating bar. So if we come back over
here, you will see in the item builder,
we get context and an index, but we don't need
the index for now. And we just need to return
a constant I icon of ikes.star with are with color
as global variable, secondary color, after saving
this much, we need on rating updates. So whenever
the rating updates, what do we need to do?
Well, it has returned to us some rating that
the user clicked and on, then what do we need
to do? So we will configure this in just
a while after creating this UI, and then
let's see what we get. Yeah, we have it.
So if we save this much, you can see,
we can rate it anywhere, but there's still a
bit of, you know, configurations I want to do.
So, first of all, I want to add an initial
rating. An initial rating will be dependent
on the average ratings that we've received so far.
So in case 10 users have passed the value for the
rating. And then each one has passed in suppose 5,
4, 3, 4, 3, something like that. We need to take
average of them and show it as an initial
rating so that the user can rate that much
as a rating. Then the minimum rating
that the user can give is one.
We don't want the user to get zero. Then
the direction will be direction, access dot
horizontal, and we will allow half a day.
So after that, the user will be able to give
half values as well. So if I click
away, you can see half values given.
Great, so that the double value that we've
stored in our Mongos comes into use. And finally,
we know item count, which is fives and item pad,
so that this doesn't look so much congested. So
we will have constant engine search symmetric
from the horizontal direction, passing four
and great. We have a rating that created now,
this looks great. All right. So now having that,
that you, I created let's bind it to the
search product as well. So if we search suppose
MacBook and click on enter, and if you click
over, we should be able to go there. This is
fairly straightforward. What we can
do is go to the searched product,
sorry, searched screen. And whenever we return
the search product, we want to wrap it with a
widget call as gesture detector. And again, on,
on tap, we want to navigate. So we have navigator
dot push name, pass in the route name,
which will be product detail, screen
Dot route name, and then pass in the
arguments, which will be a product.
Now the product is the product list that we have,
where you can see that and that particular index.
So we can just copy this and pass it as the
argument. And it won't give us any errors.
Now, if I click on this, you can see we are seeing
the product, but still the image looks very bad.
So what we can do is go to the product detail
screen and in your, in the image.network part,
we can have fit dot contain. And now we
have, it looks great, exactly what we want.
So now let's work on the rate product
functionality. All right, so now let's
create a new folder in product details called
services, and this will be called product details,
services.dot file. And this will
obviously we have product details
services. So the very first function that we're
going to have is the rate product function. So
let's create that quickly for your rate product.
This will be taking in a build context actually,
instead of writing all of that again and again,
I would recommend you to do that, but I'm just
tired of writing it again and again. So what
I'm going to do is go in one of the services
and extract it. So I'll just paste it over ya.
After that name, this to rate product. And
I require bill context, I'll take that.
Then I require the, all of this is not required.
Even this now what's required is the product
that I want to rate. So let's take that so
that we get the product's ID, which we can
take in the server side. And then obviously
required is the rating that the user given
after that we need the token of
the user. So we need provider
after that, all this Cloudinary
stuff is not needed, even the product
thing. And then we need to import
http@http.dot. So we have that line
and then we need global variables.
And after that, the utility files
and even this GTP error handling part. Great. So
now let's save this much. So your first of all
is gonna be a post request. That's correct,
because you're gonna send body data to it.
So we have the headers also there, and the body
that we're going to send is, well, first of all,
Jason encoded, don't forget to do that. Then
we need to pass in an ID, which will be product
ID and then the rating. So let's pass
in the rating and great. We have that
And also change the API over. So we have slash
API slash rate product. Now saving this much.
We are good to go. Now, also remove all of this.
We don't need any of this in the own success. Now
let's create an API for rating the product. So
we'll go to the products model. First of all,
and here we have the comment of ratings. So we
need to change that model. We will create the
ratings property, and this ratings is going to be
an a right, many users can pass in and it'll be an
a of object. We have never used this part before.
So let me just create one. So we elaborating JS
This rating JS is going to contain the structure
of this rating that we are going have. So we
are going to have constant Mongo equal to require
Mongo. And then we are going to create the rating
schema and we'll have Mongo schema. And yeah,
we are gonna pass in the user ID, the person who
rated this. So what is their user ID so that they
can't, you know, change the rating again, if they
do change, we are going to add the logic to remove
the previous rating and add the current rating.
And then we are going to add this as a
type of string and going to require it
as true. And if you're wondering why this is
not a type of object ID, which is a thing where,
so something like this, the object ID that's
because we are getting the token from the client
side and that token is going to be a string.
Sorry, the ID is going to be a string away,
which is understood. Now we need a rating,
which is going to be a number. So we have type
number and required set to two. Now we are
not going to make a model out of this. That,
that is a key thing to note. Whenever we just
want to provide a structure, we don't need to
provide it with, uh, model. If we provide a model,
it'll create an entirely new model in our fight,
and also add that in the product model, the rating
schema. And it'll also give us the underscore ID
and underscore underscore version part, which we
don't need, right? So we will just use module dot
exports, equal to rating schema. Now we can come
over here and pass in the rating schema as the
object. So this ratings is going to be an area of
all the rating schemes that we're going to have.
And it'll be like an object which will contain
multiple objects of various users. Now we can
come to the product GS route and create a route
for that. I give you the exercise of creating
a post request route to read the product with
this, with the knowledge we have. I think it's
pretty easy for you to go ahead and use that to
read the product. And if you get stuck anywhere,
like you want to delete the products like you
want to delete an object from the products, a
I would recommend you to search it up on web, on
how to delete an object from an a in Java script.
Googling is a part of this task. So I hope you
can do it. Were you able to do it? If you were,
then you're all set with no J that's my
guarantee to you. So now we have product
routed.post/api/rate product. Then we need
to have authentication. Then we are going
have asynchronous request response, and then this
created then a try and a catch block. Then we need
to return a rest dot status of 500 Jason and send
in the error message in case there is any error
Now in the tri block, first of all, we need to
extract the ID and the rating from the user. So
we are ID rating equal to the request dot body
because we sent it from your, the body part.
After that, we are going to find the product
because we need to make changes in that
product's properties. So let's quickly
find that product. So we will not make
it a constant because we need to change the
properties and, uh, product equal to product,
find by ID. And we will find that ID, and
we're not using find by ID and delete because
that will delete the entire product. We
don't want to delete the entire product.
We just want to add or remove a rating. And why do
we want to remove a rating? We will see that logic
now. So first of all, what we need to do is run a
for loop on all the ratings that the product has.
So in case the product has something like this,
let's quickly try it out. So your is the user ID
And your is the rating. Let's say 2.5. And then
we have, again this past in, so let's quickly add
that. And your, the user ID is a bit different
and the rating is full. Now this is all, uh,
part of the ratings add on the product property.
So this objects can be accessed using product dot
ratings. Right now, what we need to
do is loop through each one of them,
checking if the user ID is matching with the ID
that we have passed in, which is this user ID.
So the user ID from request dot body, if that
is equal to this user ID, that means we've
already rated that product. So that means
we need to remove that products ratings,
correct, pretty simple to law.
So let's quickly create that
we have four led. I equal to zero.
I is less than product.ratings.link.
And then I plus plus, the reason we're able
to use length on this is pretty similar to
dot. We have product dot ratings, which is
an a, now we can access all the properties
that are there on a like length includes all
of that stuff. And then we are looping through
here. We are checking if product dot ratings at
I. So that means product properties, ratings at I.
So we will get access to one rating. And this
rating doesn't mean this rating. This rating
means the entire object aware if that ratings user
ID, which gives us access to this. For example,
when we are on zero, when we are on
one, it'll give access to this, if that
is equal to request dot user ID. So yeah, we are
checking if product dot ratings at I dot user ID,
which is this if equal to request dot user, which
is the user's ID, this is not user's ID. It was
my bad, it was the product ID, but here we get
access to user's ID using request user because of
the middleware. So if that both is equal, what we
are going to do is product dot ratings do splice
I one. Now splice is a new feature
or, you know, a different feature
from dot. This is available on basically
it'll allow us to add or delete anything
If we have access to the index. So if we
just remove this again and I'll show you,
you can see, we need to pass in the start number
and the delete count so that we can delete it off.
And we can even add products using splice, but I'm
not going to show it here. You can Google it out,
but with this, you're basically deleting the
product because we have access to their index.
So here we will start the number. So from what
number do we need to start deleting? So person I,
and how many numbers should we delete? Or how
many objects do we delete? Well, we are going
to delete only one object because we need only one
object to be deleted. And after that is deleted,
we can just break it because we are not running
it for an extra loop and wasting our time
after that, if there is any
extra rating, it'll get removed,
and then we are going to add that rating schema.
So we're gonna have rating schema equal to first
of all, the user ID and strings are not needed
like this in JavaScript. So we have user ID
as request dot user and rating as the rating.
So we can have a short time syntax for that,
which is this. We have access to this.
Now we can use product dot ratings
dot push. And as I told, we have access to all of
the methods. Push is like add in Java script. So
we are going to use push and it'll push to the end
of the I a new element. And what is that element?
The rating schema, because that's exactly what
ratings needs after that. We will use product
is equal to elevate product.save,
and we will address Jason as product.
And now we will remove all the
ratings and save this much.
Now we will copy this, make
sure it's the same over here.
Great. Now we are rating the product part,
and now we want to bind this function to rate
products. So what we can do is in the product
details screen, we can go there initialize it.
So we have final product detail screen called
product detail, screen equal to product details,
screen, uh, sorry, we don't need product details.
Screen. We need product details, services,
product details, services, equal to product
details, services, else services.
And then we're going to have final
and also push this function down. Great. Now we
have access to this product detailed services. So
we can go down in the on rating update where
I told you we are going to make some changes
here. We can pass in product
detailed services dot rate product
pass in the required context,
which we get from bill context.
Then the product, which is widget dot product,
getting it from the constructor and the rating.
This rating is from on rating update. It'll
give us the correct value of which we click
click. So if we click away, it'll give us five.
If we click on half the part, it'll give us 4.5
great value. So now if we save this much and
we've not added anything in, on saved on success,
we will open up our diva console and
a terminal to see there's an error.
Nope. We can go to the essentials by a
stainless steel. We will give it a five
and see if there's any error, nothing
at all. So now if we come back,
go in the appliances again, not appliances,
sorry, essentials, stainless steel. We
can't see anything because you're not
showing anything, but in case we show it.
So just to see if it is success or not,
we can just go in our products, more
collection in our collections and here passing
the ratings. So here we have the ratings
as rating as five and the user already given
now, in case I change it again to let's say
1.5. Let's see if we have that. So if
I just go there and refresh the app,
your let's see the, your, we have it 1.5 and it
has removed the earlier rating that we had, which
was five because of the logic that we created
over here in the product. GS file this logic.
Great. Now let's just see the ratings on
the screen. So whenever we come over here,
we should be able to see the
correct rating. So for that,
what we need to do is first of all, go to this
product dot model. And in this model's folder,
we are going to create a new model called rating
GS, and actually not rating GS, sorry, rating.dot.
And here we are going have class rating.
We will initialize the properties of string, user
ID and double rating. So we have final double
rating. After that, we will
generate a constructive for them
generate Jason serialization. And we
are that done. Now we can come over here
in the product that file and pass in a
property called final list of rating,
which can be Nu called rating. Now we need
to pass this in. So we have, this is not
required. So we have final this.id. So
this not this.id, but this dot rating,
after that, we can come away, pass in the
rating as rating and near the rating will be
a bit different. So here we will first check if
map ratings and make sure to name it as ratings
because in your Jason app or your product JS
model, you've named this as ratings. So make sure
to make that change. So map ratings, if it is not
equal to Nu, then we will do something. Otherwise
we will return null because it can be null.
Then we are gonna check a list of rating
dot from map at ratings. We are
going to check if that's knowable,
if it is knowable, then also we need to map over
this so we will get access to X and then we will
convert it to adjacent model called rating dot
from map and pass in the X value, not the map.
And yeah, we have it. This is the logic that
we need to create. So let's put some coms.
Yeah, great. So we have the rating model
created. Now we just need to display that rating.
So you are at the top. We are gonna
create an innate state function
in that innate state. Well, first of all, we
need global variables of double average rating,
which will be said to zero initially, and an
variable for my rating. So average rating is
going to show up over a year because that is
average rating. And my rating consists
of the rating that is to be shown near.
So now double, total rating is going to be in
the innate state function because total rating
is not needed anywhere globally. So it's good
to have a member function away and now we are
going to run it. So we have four equal to zero.
I is less than widget dot product dot rating
Link. And we can, this can't be question mark. It
has, could be exclamation mark. And then we have I
plus plus, so here what we do is total
rating plus equals widget product rating. I
rating, and here there has to be this here we
are basically calculating the total rating that
the product has ever got. We can't calculate
the average array because first we need the sum
and then only we can move forward
with calculating the average rating.
But even over here, we need to check
first if widget dot product dot rating
At I dot user ID is equal to provider dot
and let's have provider dot user provider
context, listen, set to false.user.id. So if
both of them match the user ID in the rating
and over year, then we need to make sure that we
change my rating. So we have my rating equal to
widget product dot rating. Actually let's
copy this one. Pretty simple logic. Don't
get scared by the complexity of code that is
senior, but just the logic is pretty simple.
Nothing else you're doing. And you're outside
of this follow loop in this fall loop,
we are putting enough condition so
that we don't have to run another
follow loop running from I zero to like
this. I plus, plus just to get the user,
we can do that over year as well. And
now we are just checking. If total rating
is not equal to zero, then average rating, which
we created as a global variable is equal to total
rating divided by vision.product.rating.link.
Basically, we are checking if total rating is
not equal to zero. So if total rate rating is
equal to zero and we perform this operation,
it'll give us an error of any end, which means
it is not a number. If it is not a number, then
we cannot divide it by anything in that. So we
thing and not. So we are checking over here. If it
is not equal to zero, then average rating will be
equal to the total rating, which is the sum of all
the ratings that we com computed over here divided
by the length of the ratings a that we created.
Now we can just take this average rating and
total rating and pass it down. So you are in
the stars. You're going to have average rating and
remove this constant. It's not a constant anymore.
Let's see. We are not seeing anything. And now
if we go down to the rating bar builder, you are,
the initial rating is going to be my
rating that the user has already filled it.
And the minimum rating can be one.
And all of that is still valid.
Now, if I restart the application
and see what we are getting till now,
I'll go to the essential stainless tee and you
can see 1.5 stars over year. And even over year,
if I make it five, go back, come back over
year. You can see five stars given. That means
the rating part is working really well. Now we
just need to add the rating part in the search.
So yeah, if I type MacBook, you can see
four stars is a constant that shows up now,
instead of doing that and just to show you, even
if we do it for stainless steel here, we have
four stars showing in fact it should be five
stars. So what we can do is go to the product,
sorry, search screen, and searched product, where
we are using stars somewhere. We can go there
and in the rating, but what is the rating going to
be like? So for this, we are going to go over here
in our be function and create the same logic that
we did in the detail screen. But instead of the,
in it state function, we are going to do it
over here. So let's just copy all of this,
Paste it in. And we don't need this. If logic
again here. And we also need to remove all of this
product part widget dot product, sorry, because
this is not a state full widget. This is a
stateless widget. And that is the reason why
we are doing this in the build function. That
screen was already in a stateful widget. So we
could use in it state. Now, instead of creating
it as a stateful widget, we can just compute
it over here because anyways, no, no set state
is happening over here. This does the job of
only displaying it. So the widget rebuild is
not going to happen ever again. So build function
is a safe place to do it, at least in this case.
So here we are going to create
a variable called double
average rating and set it equal to zero. If you
do it over a year, then you'll have to remove a
constant. And then we don't get any benefit of
using a stateless budget instead of a function.
After using this, we can take this average
rating and pass it to our stars. Now say this
much and your VC five stars. Now, again, over
your, if you had a problem with this image,
obviously you can change it to contain and it'll
contain the entire image and this will look good.
Great. So we have the ratings part completed. The
next part is the add to card feature. Whenever we
click on this, add to card, it'll add to our card
and then we need to make a UI for that as well.
All right. So to get the deal of the day, what
we are going to do is go to the product GS route.
And in here, you're going to create a ghetto for
deal of the day. If you want, you take it as an
exercise to do it on your own and scratch your
brains until you do it, it'll be really great.
But just to mention deal of the day is going to
depend on the rating. So whichever product gets
the highest rating is going to be the deal of the
day. Pretty simple. So I'm gonna call this API
deal of the day then off as the middleware
and then request responses this, and then
a try catch block just to display any error if
we get any. So I'm just gonna have this past in
Great. Now in the tribe block, we are
going have first fetch all the products.
So we are gonna get, let products is
equal to innovate product dot find,
and this should be equal to sign,
not minus and also pass the semi.
So yeah, we are just getting all the products.
Now, what we are going to do is what the logic
is that we are going to sort all of these products
based on their ratings. So we are going to take
each product's ratings, match them against their
own, and then check whoever and then sort them in
our defending order so that we get the very first
element as the best element. So suppose there are
product a and then there's product B. So product a
has a total rating of 10. First of all, we need to
calculate all the ratings of the product. A and if
the product B has a total rating of let's say 30,
so, and let's say we also have C, so C has 50.
So it'll check the total. It'll first calculate
the total points of B and C together. And then
it is going to check if 10 is greater than 30, if
it's greater than 30, then it'll just sort it out
in a defending order. So that C comes on the top.
B is the second and a is the third. Now to get the
deal of the day, we have a sorted products, a we
can just access the very first element since it's
in descending order and has the highest number of
points. Great, pretty easy. So what we are going
to use for this is products dot sort, which is
a method provided by JavaScript. It just sorts a
value, and it'll sort the value based on what we
output, but here we will get a and B, which are
two numbers. Now, if you think there will be any
confusion from your side, you can just name it.
Something like product one, product two,
but I'm just going to go forward with a and B.
And here we are gonna create a function based on
which it is going to sort itself. So first of all,
we will create a temporary variable called Ania,
and don't worry, this sorting is basically,
it'll go through all the products and then sort
one against each other. It'll done some sorting
algorithm inside of it, which we don't need
to worry about. So here we have B sum zero. So
even if products are more than two, don't worry
this a and B just symbolize product one,
product two, which keep on changing every time.
So now what I'm going to do is calculate
the ASEM for that. We are going to use
for loop. So Follet I is equal to
zero. I is less than products dot,
sorry, not products, but a dot ratings dot length.
So ratings is the model property that we created
on product. And then we are going to increment
by one. And then we are, what we are going to
do is a sum plus equals so that whatever pre
value that we have is added plus a dot ratings
at I. So we get the particular object, which
now consists of the rating as the number and the
user's ID. So now we will do rating and that's it.
We have a sum ready. Now, similarly, we have to do
the same thing for B sum so we can pass it in over
here. And we have B do ratings, rotting, and B sum
plus equals B do ratings at, I do rating. We can't
do both of them in a single follow loop because
this will run till a do ratings rotting. And this
will B do ratings, struggling. Both can defer
After that. We just need to return a condition.
So based on which it can sort, or we have not yet
provided the condition on which it should sort.
So here we are just returning that asso should be
smaller than BSO. So if asso is smaller than BSO,
then we want to return one. Otherwise we want to
return negative one. Why are we returning this?
If you over over this, you can see sorts and a in
place, this mutates, the a and returns a reference
to the same, a that means we're going to get an a,
so what we are going to do here is products
equal to this. So it'll just mutate the a
so that we can get the reference to the
same. A, that means it'll give us the same,
a sorted, but here, what does this mean? So again,
we hover over this and scroll along. You can see
function used to determine the order of the
elements. It is expected to return on negative
value. If the first argument is less than the
second argument, zero, if they're equal and a
positive value otherwise. So here we could have
done a, some minus B sum and removed all of that,
but I like to do it this way. It is like a
convention for me. So here, I'm just checking.
If Ania is less than B sum, that means that
B takes precedence over ASO B some will be
Pushed at the top. And negative one means the
opposite. That is a takes precedence over B.
And thus it is arranged in a descending order
After having that area and storing it
to products. What we need to do is just
return that, and we don't want to return
the area of the products we want to return. The
only one product. And that one product is going to
be the top most element since it's in descending
order. So we have products at zero and there we
have it. We created the API. Now you can test it
and send the client, but now you might be used to
it. I'm not doing that. It's very good for you.
If you do it after that, we can go to the home
component. Let's minimize search product deals and
admin in the home part. We have deal of the day
and home services. So first of all, let's create
an API and home services. So I'm going to copy
this, paste it in Nova. And we are going to return
just a single product, which will be a future. So
let me just have product return. And this will be
named fetch deal of day. We are going to require
nothing else, but the build context, so that, you
know, we can show snack bars and use provider.
Now we have product list. Instead of that,
we just need a product which will be product
Product equal to, and now we need to
instantiate this. So that later on,
I'll tell you why we need to instantiate
this. And we are not putting this as Nu,
but you might already have guessed why we
are doing this because we have done this
so much that we now understand the need for
it. So I'm just going to pass ant for now.
The images is going to be an empty list.
Category is going to be empty. String
and price is going to be zero plus 10 semicolon.
And you also, the quantity will be zero.
After that, we have the tribe block for response,
and we are sending response to this particular URL
so we can copy this, paste it away. And we now,
after the headers part and HTTP error handling
year, we need to remove all of this for loop.
And instead just have product equal to product
dot from Jason. We have already done this. We
are basically getting the Jason format. So we
are taking that Jason and converting it to a
product model. So we have response dot body
and that's it. And now we just need to return that
product. Now we are gonna use this function now,
so we can just copy this, go to the deal of
the day. And instead of returning all of this,
We're gonna have in it state pass in the
function as fetched deal of day, and then
create that function. So we have fetched deal of
the day, which is asynchronous and will not return
anything. We are used to the convention by now.
So we have product which can be nullable and
just a device, if you've forgotten till now.
And you're wondering why every time I use Nu
so that we can just check if it is going to be
empty. And now let's explain why we even created
this empty model. Instead of this question,
mark, as I said, this product can be Nu. So if
we just check, if product is null, so suppose
I check away a product is equal, equal to Nu.
That would mean that we need to display
a loader. That means that the data is
being fetched. So thus, we are
checking and putting a column away,
but here we suppose we don't get the perfect
deal of the day, because there are no products
only there. So the user will continuously
a loading bar. And the reason is, well,
because this wasn't initialized and it was also
nullable, but here, now it removes everything.
And instead, if the product is now, we are going
to show a loader. Otherwise, if it is empty
So we can check away. Now we can't check product
is empty because there is no function like that
created on product model and it should not be
created. How do we check if it's a product is an
empty product? Like how so here, basically we are
going to check if the product property on product,
which is name is empty, then we are going to
show a constant sized box, otherwise a column.
Now we are gonna create the such deal of the
day. So we'll have product equal to a weight and
let's use home service. So we have final home
services, home services equal to home services,
take this home services and use home services
dot fetch deal of the day, pass in the context.
And yep. Now we will call set state
so that the we build function rebuilds
and yep. Look through. So now we
have this loading bar showing up,
let's restart the application and here we are
still not seeing the correct deal of the day
because we have not bounded, but we're not getting
any errors as such. That's a very good thing.
So what we need to do is go down here. And
instead of returning so many image networks,
I'm going to delete the rest of the three and
keep one there so that I can map through them.
So you are in the children. Also, I'm going to
remove this list. And instead, what we are going
to do is product dot images dot map, and we are
going to map through them so that we can display
them in a horizontal direction. If you see, we
are displaying them in the horizontal direction,
and that's how we are going to do it. Now, I'm
going take this image network and paste it over
here and also convert it to list. Don't forget
to do that. If you don't convert it to a list,
it won't know because this will return to us
an it it, and two list just converts it to
a list because that's what a wants list of
widgets. And here we are returning a widget
in case you return something like, you know,
a string over, you can see, we get an error
because type list of string, can't be assigned
to the parameter type list of widget. So here we
are returning the image.network and yeah, we have
it. Great. Now let's restart our application. And
The correct thing is still not showing
up because we need to use E so we have
E Pastin. Now, now we save this. We can
see stainless steel bottle showing. And
if we go at the top just to display a product
image, which will be product dot images
at zero, and also put that not now so
that we can save it. And here we have it.
And we are seeing two same images because here
we have used it that way. We are product. We
are mapping through the product images again,
and again, if you want, you can ignore them,
but I'm quite happy with what I've got after that.
Whenever we click on this, we need to go to the
product detail screen that we've already created.
So what I'm going to do is wrap this entire column
with a widget known as gesture detector, and also
create a function wide navigate to details screen.
Then I'm gonna call this navigator dot push named
pass in the route name as product detail, screen
dot route name with an argument. And here we
need to pass in the argument, which will be
the product variable that we have created
at the top. So let's pass in product
and this much is enough, so we can
copy this, paste it down in the,
on top property of this gesture detector after
saving it this much, let's click away and here
we have it. We are at the right place and it's
showing everything very correctly. Super cool.
Now the next thing is to work on the card
feature. So whenever I click on this, add to card,
I wanna see it over your, the displaying
part and also this number should get updated.
All right. So now what we're going to do is close
all the other safe files, close this terminal,
and now we are going to go to the user model.
And in this user model, what we are going
to have is another property, which is card
that I commented. So in this card property,
we need to have two things. So first of
all, let's write the card property properly.
So how is this card going to be like, well,
first of all, it's an a, so let's quickly
create this a kind of thing exactly that we did
for ratings now in the rating. If you remember,
we passed in the rating schema exactly for this,
we're going to pass in the product schema, but
cart, isn't just going to contain the product
schema, right? It'll have the quantity as well.
So we have the product schema as well, as in how
much quantity do we want this product? So it's
gonna be look, something like this. So the card
a has a property of product. So let's wrap this.
So card is going to have a property of
products. So we're going to create like this
and it'll have product called product schema. And
we can just pass that in. Now we need to get this
product schema because you have not imported
it or even exported it. So here we are going
to have this kind of destructuring. So to send a
product, we are going to do something like this
comma. We are going to send the product schema.
We've seen this before to send two products. We
are going to send it in a map or an object.
So to pass in the object, we have product and
product schema. Now, whenever we use product in
some other route, so let's quickly go through
some of the routes. We have product aware. So
now to access that product, we need to wrap
it with a Colibra so that we can restructure
that particular object like we did over year.
You can see that we did this for the product
over year, the same thing we're going to have
for O so now over year, there's nothing for
product. And obviously in the product route,
we're going to have that product. But so if we
come to the user and again, call product schema,
you can see we get the import. So let's quickly
import that. And this comes in this format. Great.
Now the next property that we need is the
quantity. So here we can have quantity
and passing the quantity, how it's going to look
like now we are not going to create a separate
quantity schema. So you are just manually
type in number and required set to two.
So yeah, we have the quantity property, which
was of this structure. And we have product,
which is of the following structure.
Great. We are not passing in
product away because we can't pass in model,
right? It, we need to pass in the product schema.
We've already discussed about that. So now, if
I come to user JS the route, which we haven't
yet created, so in the routes, you're going to
create a new route called user RS. And this time
I completely remember my mistakes from previous
times, I'm going to require express, oh, sorry,
let's close the files that are not required.
So what I can have is remove models,
the O files, the file, the
admin we need just for reference
and product and product model. So yeah, I'm
going to require express, create the router, copy
the post request because that's the very first
request that we are going to need, add to card.
And then we need module lot exports for this
let's quickly rename, and then make sure to add
the middleware in the index GS, which
we've forgotten so many times or I've
forgotten. All right. So we have user router
passing the user router away. And even where
now quickly, let's go to index projects
and you require the user router. So we have
user router. And now you can see project is
expanding instead of creating so many routes
your itself. We are just using a cleaner way
of app dot use that makes a app less congested.
And this looks great. So here we are going
to have API of add to card, and this requires
oath. So let's quickly import that. So we have
cons equal to require dot slash middleware slash.
Now we're going to have, first of all, remove
all of these stuff. This is not needed.
And what do we need? Well, first of all,
we want to get the ID of the product
so that we can find the product. So we
will have constant ID equal to request dot
body. Great. Now we can have product which will
be equal to elevate product dot, find by ID.
And then we need to pass in the particular
ID that we got. Now, we also need to find
the user because you're storing all of this end
user model. And the reason we are storing the
cart property and the user model is so that we
don't need to fetch the data every time the user
clicks on that card, I can write. So we
are just going to display using provider,
which will be a very neat way of doing it in my
opinion, because we are using cart everywhere
in our application right now to continuously
post there and get from there, it's going to
be a hectic job. So instead of doing that, we are
going to save it in the provider, and that's why
we are starting it in the user model. Also, even
in that we are going to in this user.dot model,
we are going to change there. So yeah, first of
all, find the correct user. So we already know
to find the correct user. We are going to avoid
user dot, find by ID, pass in the request dot
user as the user ID. And now we are gonna check
if users card dot length is equal, equal to zero,
Right? So now we are checking if the length of the
card is zero. So if it is zero, then we need to do
user dot card dot push. And I've already explained
whenever there is an a, we need to push stuff.
And this is like, add end dot. So we are going
push to the end of the Ania, the product,
and we need to exactly put it like this. And the
next thing was quantity. And the quantity is going
to be one because the user clicked on ad to cart.
Only once, whenever the user clicks on the ad to
cart, another time the quantity will increase.
But whenever the user dot cart length is zero,
it is going to be quantity one, because user is
adding product for the very first time. Right
else? What are we going to have now? Well,
obviously you can use guard clauses away,
but I'm not going to do that. I'm going to
use nesting away. And this is very important
now. So we are gonna have four loop for
let I is equal to zero. I is less than
User dot card link and increase
I by one. So we have I plus plus,
and we, you, we are looping through all the
products and checking if the particular product
that we have over here is already there in the
user's cart. If it is already there, then we want
to increase their quantity by one. Otherwise we
need to just add that product for the very first
time, just like we did over year. So we have that
logic. So we have user dot card, I dot product
dot underscore ID. So we have user dot
card. I, so we get access to the very
cart item so that we can look at the product
because now if we come back over here,
here, we could either use quantity or product.
We are using product. And we are getting that
products ID to get that products ID we
are using underscore ID, because remember,
underscore ID is what is given by mongoose or
MongoDB. And what we are checking is is if it is
equal to the product dot underscore ID, which
is this, otherwise you could have just used
this ID and it wouldn't matter, but it's the
same thing after that, we can check this much.
And I think this is a, and actually, sorry, my
bad. You couldn't use ID over because if you use
ID, it is of the type spring. But over here, the
ID is of the type object ID because you you're
not converting it to string, right? You could
obviously do dot two string. And that's a method
allowed in JavaScript, as well. As I said, it's
very similar. So we have dot two string, and then
you could compare with ID, but you are, we are
just comparing two object ID now, object IDs, if
you don't understand. So if we go to our products
model and check, every ID is not a string. It is
an object ID. Now object ID is randomly given by
MongoDB and it's like a particular type for an ID
in Mongos. So here we are not comparing
strings. We are comparing object IDs.
That's why we're not even using equal to equal
to a layer. If we use equal to equal to, it'll
not be a valid comparison under it'll always give
false, even though both the same thing. The reason
for that is we are comparing Mongo ID or Mongo
DB ID. And that's why we are using equals great.
Now, what you want to do is if that is the case,
then we are going to create a flag at the top.
So what we are going to have here is in the else,
block, let, is product found equal to false.
So if that product, if any existing product
is found, we are going to set it to two.
And the reason why we are not setting,
you know, directly doing the stuff away
is because it is in a loop. Now, first of
all, why is this variable there? Which is
just a flag to say that, yeah, we found
the product now, what do we need to do?
So now we're gonna have, is product set to true
whenever we find it. So if that product is found,
we need to just increment its value.
Otherwise we need to add that new product
To the card. Now, if we directly add the logic for
adding to the cart wire, if that is equal to that,
then that would mean we don't have to look
forward. And if we look forward and find again,
then we are adding it again. Now that would
be really bad. So here, what we are going to
do is if, if product found, so just like
that we don't need to specify is equal,
equal to two. We can just do Fs product
found. Then we need to find that product.
That means that the product already exists.
So we need to find that particular product.
And we gonna name it with three Ts because you
already use product away. And we are going to use
product with double T, uh, in just a second. So we
have user dot card, which is an a, and JavaScript
provides us with tons of functions. Another one
of them is dot find on a, so here you can see
find calls predicate once for each element of the
IRA in ascending order, until it finds one where
predicate returns two, as you can suggest the
name itself sees it, that we are finding a product
And we are using doublet.
That's why the triplet and
a single T O over and a singlet over
year. Now, if that is confusing,
you can rename it. But to your, essentially
what we're doing is finding the product,
which matches a certain criteria. So we have
to pass in a certain criteria in the function.
You can see this is a function format. And like,
do we have single arrow operations as well? I'm
not sure if I mentioned, but you can just have a
single arrow in case you want to return something,
which is just an Lineer, which is a
shorthand for doing it even in dot, right?
So you are, when do we want to return a
product, right? Where if we find a product
whose quantity want to increase, we use dot find.
And what is the criteria to find that particular
product? Well, the product's ID should match.
So we have product with doublet, which is this
dot product. Now not to get confused. Product is
one of the products that user dot card has. We,
you can consider it like looping. So we
are looping through every card product
and finding the particular product. So find is a
short way of doing that. We could have used find
as well, but the reason we did not do that is
because we needed to use I. So we have product
product, which is the product property in the
user's cart. I could ensure it to you because
we have not added anything to cart yet, but
product. And instead of having your product,
we could have quantity. Now, I think it explains
well dot underscore ID. And we are again,
comparing the MongoDB IDs so we can just do
dot equals product dot underscore ID. Great.
Now, after having access to that product and
in case, you're wondering why we are not using
this product that we already have, and that's
because we are not storing that product anywhere.
So now we can do is product with triple T, which
is this one dot quantity and increase it by one,
because that product already exists. We found that
by looping. So if that product already exists,
then we are just going to increase its quantity
by one. Otherwise we are just going to push to
card like this so we can have your like this now
in case you're wondering, why did we have this
condition away? If user dot card dot length
is zero, then user dot card dot, push this.
Now just think about it. If the carts length is
zero, then will it run through all of this? So we
have, I, less than zero, I is equal to zero. I is
less than zero. So here, it's not going to run at
all. And that's why we are not using that. After
that we have the LS condition and here we are
just going to use user is equal to avoid user dot
say, because we updated the user's card, right?
We don't need to do anything with product.
Now. We don't really care about it,
and we're not making any changes over there.
After that. We just need to return a user.
Now, after returning this user,
you might have guessed. We need to
update the provider and our client side. So
let's quickly go over there and have that.
So before even doing that, glad I
remember it. We need to go to the user.dot
and in your add a new generate a new thing. So the
new thing that we have here is final list dynamic
of card. And now we need to generate everything.
And in case you're wondering why this is dynamic
and not map of string of dynamic. And that's
because when we get the data from our API,
it'll not know that the card property
that we extract is map does it'll
give us an error, like type list.
Dynamic is not a subtype of list,
map, string, dynamic. You know, that's why we
are using list dynamic. So here we need to add
this required argument. So we have required
this drug card. Then down here, we have
card. Whenever we create two map, I don't think
specifically we need that, but let's just have it.
And even your, the card is going to
be list of map of string, dynamic
dot from, and pass in the elements,
which will be map at card. You know
that because when we send it over, we will
have map dot card. Whenever we use from map
map card, which can be in a label dot map X and
it'll return map of string, dynamic dot from X.
Great. Now, after having that, let's
see why we are getting this error.
We need to pass in a pattern thesis over year.
And I think at the end also, let's see why we are
getting this. We need to remove that semicolon.
It just the pattern thesis and all should be good.
Make sure this card property is like this
by default, it would give something else,
I guess. And that's why manually wrote
it. Now we can go to the user provider
and here add a card functionality, which will
be by default NMP list. So now we can close this
and now where do we wanna go? Well, if you come
back over, you can see the add to card button
is present on product detail screen. So let's
go over there. And I see an error in the part,
so we can go there. And in the odd service, we
can add the empty card that we need right now
after achieving that we can go to the product
detail screen and in the services of that,
the first functionality that we want is going
to be a post request again, so we can copy this,
paste it. And now we're
gonna name this, let's say,
add to cart. And this function is going
to be pretty usable because we're going
to use this add to cart, even in the cart
screen, when we need to incremented by one.
And we here, we need the required as built
context and the product so that we can get
the products ID. After that, we need the user
provider as well. We need to send a post request
and here we just need to send in the ID, which is
product ID. We have passed in the correct head.
After that, we need to do the error handling
part. Now the error handling part is going, be
something tough. So we are going to make it very
easy for us. So as we already know, we will get
the card. If you go to the user or GS part
in the routes, we are sending user away.
Now, instead of just manually doing,
you know, something like user dot from
map and pass in the re body, instead of doing that
while Jason decoding it and all that stuff, you
know, instead of doing all of this work, instead
of updating this entire user, which will lead to
us going back to the O screen because we
updated the user's map for some time, it was Nu.
So that kind of errors we will get. You can
try it on your own. You will get it. I face
the same thing. So what I've done instead
is in the user model, again, let's go there.
Your let's go on the top, click
on this ball, bike in and create
copy with class. With this copy class, we'll be
able to only use and copy with one value. For
example, if we have the ID name, email password,
all of this typed in, and we just need to pass in
the token as, uh, sorry, card as a different
thing, then we can use copy with it'll copy
with all the other features that it has along
with this, it is similar to, you know, theme
of dot context dot, uh, you know, theme dot, dot
copy with it's doing the exactly the same thing.
So we can create this copy with function.
Now, what we can do is go to the product detail
screen and your have user provider user, which
is the current user with all its details dot copy
with now, since this is an instance of the user
class, we get access to this copy with function,
and now we need to copy with this
card and this card should pass in the
Jason decode, which is response dot body. If we
send in response dot body, we are sending in the
whole user card. We don't want to send that. So we
will just send in the card. After decoding this,
Jason, we get access to card property, and then
we are just doing that and we're gonna set, uh,
store it in a separate variable, but
now we need to update this right. User
provider is still not updated to update it.
We always used user dot set user from model.
We don't want to do that user dot set user. So
whenever we wanted to set a new user, we would do
user dot set user. You saw that user provider
dot set user, sorry, but now we can't do that
because set user takes in a spring and we don't
have a string anymore. We have a user model.
So what now we are going to do is go to the user
provider class. Let's go there and here create a
new function. So let's create void set user from
model, as the name suggests it'll take in the
parameter type as a user. And then it'll make sure
that the private variable user that we have a year
is equal to this parameter type user. And then
we just need to set notify listeners to notify
all the listeners. After that, we can just come
over here and pass in user provider dot set user
from model and pass in the correct user.
Sweet. So after that, we can save this and
let's see what we will get. So just
to see if there is any changes,
what we can do is go to the bottom bar. And in
here we can have final user card link equal to
now, instead of typing in provider dot of context,
all of that stuff. Let's first of all, import
provider, we can use a short syntax that I'm
not used till now. So we can use context.watch.
This is a short syntax for provider dot context,
and we have it and also person user provider over
here. And yeah, we have it. And now we can have
dot user dot card link. So this will Fe us the
user's card link. We can copy this, go to the
badge. And instead of passing in two, we are
going to pass in user car length. Also remove
this constant, and you convert this to a string
create, uh, if you come aware, we are getting
this error because we need to restart it.
And here we have it, zero displaying, which
is a correct card link. Now, if I click away,
click on, add to card, come back away, nothing
has changed. And that's because you have not bound
this function of card to card to our product
detail screen. So let's use that. Let's also
go down. So we are gonna create a new function
called add to cart. We will have product
detailed services dot, add to cart, pass in the
context, the product, and to get the product.
We will just do widget dot product. Great. Now
we can take this void, add to cart and go down
where we have add to cart and pass
it. The on tap this, add to cart
and after saving it, we can click on, add to cart.
You can see product validation, fail ratings,
zero rating. Let's quickly see
that path rating is required.
Let's see. Why do we need that?
So if we go to add to card,
add to card and we have cost and rate product over
a year, so we need to change that to add to card.
Always keep making stupid errors, but yeah,
we have it. Now let's click on, add to card.
Let's go back. You can see one away. And in case
we, again, type, add, click on, add to card. It
should not give us two. It should only give us
one with increased quantity. So if I click on,
add to cart, it's tell one. But if we go to our
users, let's click on refresh your fresh here.
Let's scroll down just to find the user via the
cart, the zeroth object, quantity here. You can
see two random ID generated, and then we have
our product object and we click stainless steel.
Now what do we do if we have MacBook? So let's
quickly type in MacBook. So let's quickly type
in MacBook and click on enter. And you can see in
the DAC console, we have this keyboard error. So
we are gonna restart it and try it again. It won't
happen on release version. So don't worry. Now,
if I click on enter MacBook air, let's click
on, add to card, go over there. We have two
showing up sweet. So now our cart function is
working. Let's display it away, which will be
fairly easy because we are gonna copy paste a
lot of code from searched product. All right.
So now what we're going to do is close. All the
safe files, minimize all the folders that we have
and now create a new feature called
card. Also let's minimize account
now in the card, we're going to have screens and
services. Obviously the services will
now consist of decrementing the cart,
so that's fine. And now we need cart screen.
Let's quickly build out the card screen
and display the products that we have. We are
waiting for it. So we have a state full widget
where we're gonna call this as a cart
screen and create a constant cart screen.
After that, we are going to return a scaffold
and go to the home screen to copy this app bar,
which we've already copied away. Let's paste it
down there. After that, we are going to create
global variables. Copy this, obviously copy the
function so that we can navigate the search screen
and paste it away. Yeah. After
that, we are going to import them.
Great. Now, what we want to do is after
this app bar, let's bind this to our
bottom bar so that we see the correct cart screen
and see it on the screen. So we have constant
cart screen and pass it away.
Now let's restart our
app. If we go to this card, we see the correct
thing. And it's the same thing as this one. Now
in the home, sorry, in the card screen, let's
close both of them in the body. Now we need
a single child scroll view, and I've already, uh,
told you the purpose of this single child scroll
view. After that we need a child and the child is
going to be a column and the column is going to be
children of first of all, an address box. This
address box is going to consist of the address,
no brainer. Yeah. This address and save this
much. We see the address box showing up correctly.
After that we need the subtitle for that.
We are going create a separate widget. So
in the cart we have widgets in person, something
known as card sub total, the card subtotal.dot
let's import the material dot for it. Call it as
a state, less widget and call this card subtotal
you in the stateless widget. We are going to,
first of all, have final user equal to provider
dot of context. So let's quickly add that.
And actually let's use context dot, watch,
use the user provider and then
use the user's property on it.
After that, yeah. Margin and from cons
inserts dot all. We want a margin of 10.
After that, we need a child of row. And in that
row, we are going to have subtotal with 1500.
You can always use a text span, but I'm just
showing you an alternate approach of doing it.
So we have a constant text that says
subtotal. We are going to leave some space
and not put a colon and put in a
style as textile font size of 20.
After that, we need a text which will show the
total subtotal. Now to calculate the subtotal. We
are going to do this in the build function itself.
So we have end sum equal to zero. And here we have
user dot card and we need to map through all the
elements of the user dot card so that we can get
that price and add it to the sum. So we have E
and now we can use some plus equals E at quantity.
And since this is a map, but we have used it
as a dynamic, we can use E quantity into E
product. Now, if you are wondering
why we are doing what we are doing
while we are just while we are just using quantity
E quantity and multiplying it with the product's
price, because the subtotal will be how many
products you buy. So in case of a year, let's see
we have iPhone and we have three iPhones. We
want to display 4,500. So if we click on three,
it'll be 4,500. That's what we are doing.
Multiplying quantity with products, price.
And then we are going to treat them
as an NGER because they don't know.
And obviously convert this to list later
on. Otherwise it won't do anything at all.
It will stay in an Iterable. After that,
we can take the sum, pass it in the text.
So let's copy the text. Also pass it in
the text, which has the font size of 20,
but font. Weight is font, wait, bull. And here,
the price is going to be slash dollar dollar sum.
So that will make it dollar with whatever
sum it is like 20. Now we save this much,
come away. We can't see anything
because we're not bound this widget,
but yeah, we have it. Now let's go
away and have constant cart, subtotal
and great. Also, we need to import it. So let's
quickly import it. Now, if you come aware,
you can see sub total 1019. I'm not sure about
how much did you buy that? You're getting this,
but we'll verify once we get the products
showing up. So now the next thing is this
button so well for that, we already know what we
are going to use. It's going to be custom button.
Your, the text is going to be proceed to buy pass
in the, how many items there are. You can see one
items, three gonna have dollar user.card.link.
And now we need to create this user. So we can
just come up here, take this user, paste it
in the build function, import user provider,
and also import watch from provider.dot.
And yeah, you have it. user.card.link
items. Then we need an on tap. So we have on tap.
And after seeing this much, we can
see this, but now we, first of all,
need to shrink it size and then change its
color. Let's do it together. So we have padding
rapid with padding of six, eight. And after that,
the color is going to be colors dot yellow at 600.
And now if we come aware, we see a correcting
showing up after that, we need a slide border
below which we can show this product item.
So what we are to have is a constant size box
of height, 15, then a container which will be of
the color colors dot Blackwell. And now we want it
to look very slight. You know, black 12 is having
a lot of impact so we can have dot with opacity,
not 0.8, but 0.08, which is very, very mild. And
obviously mention a height which would be one
Saving this much. We see correct things showing
up after that. We can, again, leave a space.
We have not left space over here, but now I
realize this problem so I can leave this. ER,
let's say five only. And then we want to display
the list of products for the list of products.
We are going to use ListView dot builder, get
a context and an index after which we are also
going to get an item count. So we have item count.
And now the item count, first of all, is going be
user.card.link and the item builder for that, we
are gonna create a different widget altogether.
So in this widgets, we are going to have card
underscore product dot and not dot product,
but card product. After that, we're gonna import
material dot, create a stateless widget, call it
card product. And this card product is going to
be very similar to the searched product that we've
already created. So what I'm going to do is first
of all, even convert it to state full widget.
The reason for that is we are going to click
on increase and decrease product, right?
So that state is going to change.
So we need to make sure we add that
After that we are going to go to the search
product and copy the whole thing from the search
product and then make some changes. So I'm going
to copy this entire column, paste it over here
and let's see the errors. Well,
first of all, we need to remove stars
because we don't need to display the
stars. Then we need the product name. Well,
we are going to get that from state
full widget. I mean, this is a card,
right? So we just need its index so that
we can display. So we have final index
required this dot index. And based on this index,
we can show the card products. So obviously in the
build function, we will have final product,
which will be equal to provider. And instead
of using provider again, I'm used to it. So
we can have, watch and pass in user provider
Dot user dot card, and we want to get access to
that particular product. So we're going to have
widget index. Great. Now we have that product,
but now for the ease of our using itself, what
we're going to do is pretty smart. You can see
that we have product, we are going to name this.
Let's say product card, very less descriptive,
but I know you can change it. I'm very bad at
naming. So you're, you're going to do final
product, which is equal to product from map. This
will allow us to get, you know, auto completion
and will make sure that we don't have to use
those annoying brackets because they reduce,
they increase our chance of hypos and bugs. So
yeah, we can just pass in product dot product
card. I'm a big fan of using these models
because they make my life much more easier.
So I can go to the down and we have the product
created already. And now just to see what we have
and then make certain changes more. What I'm
going to do is return the card product Ania.
So yeah, we have it. We have mentioned the index
as well. And now we are not seeing anything.
We can see list view. Builder has an error Ania,
and that error can be resolved by either wrapping
it with expanded or setting shrink up to two.
Your type is not a subtype of type it dynamic.
If we just restart our app, it won't do anything,
but it will let us know what we are doing wrong
somewhere. And the reason you're getting
this issue is if we go to the card product,
we are passed in product from product card, but
the product card that we're sending includes both
product and the quantity. We forgot to
take that into account. So we have card,
but now that card consists of an object. So
let's see we are, we have an object which has
product and there is the product object. And
after that, we also have quantity. So it passed
in this entire object, which is giving us the
issue. So here we want to specifically tell
that we have product that we have passed in saving
this much. We can see correct things showing up.
That's insane. All of these things are matching.
That's pretty cool to see. Now, the only thing
that we need to change is this button part. So
let's quickly create those buttons. So we're
going to have them after the in-stock part. Let's
close this and here in the row, just below this
image.network and column, and actually not even
in the row, because if we put it in the row,
it'll come back over here. We don't want it over
year. We want it over year. So we wanna pass this
below the row, which is in column because
we have a column first. So here we want it.
So now we are just going to have a container for
increment increment. But so here we have margin,
which will be constant edge inserts dot all
10. Then we need a child of row <affirmative>.
And that role is because we need these three
places. So you are in the children. Well,
first of all, we need main access alignment, which
is the main access alignment or space between.
And then we have a container and we have a
decoration which will be boxed decoration.
And then we pass in border, which will be border
dot all. And then the color will be colors.black,
twelves and width will be 1.5. After saving
this much, we can't see anything on the screen,
but that's fine. We are gonna have
a border radius of border radius dot
circular five. And we are just designing the
outside of this. You know, this part away are.
So now we are going to have this and then the
color, which will be colors.black twelves.
After that, we need a child in the
container itself, which will be a row.
And in that row, we are gonna have children,
which will first give the icon of this minus sign.
So we can have container again,
which will be of the width,
35 and height 32. And now we need to align this
container. That's why we and container, otherwise
we use wide size box. You can see that. So yeah,
we gonna have alignment as alignment.center
and then the child has constant. I can,
I can start to remove which size 18
let's save this much and come back away. You
can see minus sign is coming and it's looking
good after that, we need this quantity showing I
icon, but for quantity showing I icon the color
should be white. So what I can do is first of
all, wrap this container with an ankle widget,
which we will do later on because we need
to decrement after that we have container,
which just shows a text, which
will be of the quantity. So we'll
have quantity. So let's quickly go up and
have final quantity equal to product card
quantity. Let's take that quantity,
go down here, pass the quantity
and pass in dot two string because this is
going to be a number right now. If we go
where you can see two is showing up, but we need
to change its colors. So to change its color,
we can just wrap it with a decorated box
and so box, instead of wrapping it with a
Container, we are doing decorated box, and then
we can pass in box decoration. The border will be
border dot, all color as colors.black twelves with
1.5 and yeah, save it, come back away. There's no
big change as such. So now we are going to pass
in the color, which will be colors dropped white.
Now you'll see the color change, which is this
color, but we also have a bit of, you know,
this color border that we have. And then
we just need to make sure that there is no,
you know, border radius. So we can just pass in
border radius as border radius, circular, zero
Saving this much. We come back and
there's no border this. You can
see the border radius is diminishing for
this, this part. If you zoom in and see it
after that, we again need this container. Actually
let's copy this container because it's going to be
pretty similar to this. Just an I can
change will be, which will be Ikes dot, add
no, save this much. And we have, it looks exactly
like your, and it looks pretty good. And here we
are seeing the correct, you know, the product
quantity as well. Now let's just calculate what
we serve 1090. So we have one product of MacBook
and one. So we have 9 99 plus two times 20, which
is 20. So 1019. This is absolutely correct. Now,
whenever we click on this, we need to increase the
quantity. We have already created a function for
that we need to create for decreased quantity. So
let's quickly bind that, increase quantity one and
create one for decreased quantity. So we will have
final product details, services, product details,
services, equal to product details services.
And then we are gonna create a
function, void increase, quantity
Product product, and now we wanna
increase this product's quantity.
So we have product details, services
dot, add to card, and we've already
added the logic for adding to card.
You can see that we have add to card.
We passed in the product and we are its quantity.
And we've already added the feature of checking.
If the cart already exists, then we just need to
add one to this quantity. And we've done all that
stuff already. So we don't need to worry about
it as such. So we can just reuse this function.
And it's pretty cool. Now we can just go
down, use this increased quantity again.
So you are wrap this container with an INEL widget
or a gesture detector, whatever you feel better
with. I think I'll use inal. So that user feels
that yeah, there clicking something, you know,
not just a stupid button, you know,
it gives a kind of good feeling.
So yeah, we are gonna have an on tap and
then pass in the function, which will be
increased quantity pass in the product, which we
already have done. And yep. Now if we click on
this product, it is three. This is two, and it's
increasing real time. This is absolutely insane.
Now the same thing we are going to
have for decrease quantity so we can
create a services of card services. Otherwise
you can just do it in product detailed services,
but I think it's cleaner to have card services
as well because this function is only used over
year in this card services. Obviously we are
going to go to the product details services
and copy this entire file and paste it over
here. Now let's rename stuff. We have card
services. We are going to have well remove
rate to product. We don't need that.
And in Europe, we are going to have this named as
removed from card. This is going to be a required
product field. We are going to get the user
provider and then we are going to pass in the API
that is HTTP delete. This is something new.
So we, we looked at get update and post,
but we didn't look at delete. So this is the final
crude function, which will also tell you that we
are nearing to the end. We're coming very close
to the end of this application. There are just
a few features left. You can look in the times
cams below, but the point is we are using delete
away. So obviously there is no body aware and
for delete, you're not going to pass in anybody,
but we are going to use that URL format
that we had. So we have API slash remove
from cart and then pass in the product ID in the
URL and already know how we are going to access it
in the server. We are going to use requests, but
here we can worry about product ID passing it in
carefully. After that, after
that is done, good enough.
We're going to get user user. We need to copy
that card and set user from model, all of that,
similar to add to card. Now we just need
to create a different URL for this thing.
So I think I'll just copy this part and
go to user dot JS. And in the routes,
we are going to create a delete post. I'm just
going to copy this and paste it away. And this
is going be called user dot delete. And again,
we need to copy that URL. So you are copy it
past it away, and we are going to pass
in the ID. Well, the ID can be accessed
using request paras and your make sure to add
this call and don't forget it by any chance.
And here we are going to use request dot paras
as the ID. Otherwise you can just
use request per ID. I mean, both of
them are the same thing, but I just wanted
to show you another way of doing it,
which is this. After that, we are going to
find the product. We are going to find the user
and you're we are, we do not want is product
found and all of that stuff, we already know
the product is there. That's why the user is even
able to click on that. Remove from card button
Here we are going to remove, this is product found
part. Even this L block, this F block, and even
this lead variable is product found variable.
Now we are gonna check from going from zero to
card.link. I plus plus checking if user product
ID is equal to the product ID that we have,
then we are going to do user dot card
splice because you want remove it. And
as you already know, splice helps us with
that. Just to make you remember again,
what the slice will do. It'll delete the product
based on whatever you enter. So we need to
enter the start number and how many
elements do we need to delete after that?
And in case you're wondering why we are not using
find function over on user dot card dot fine. And
that's exactly for this reason we're using. I, we
want the I so that we can splice it out. So yeah,
we have, I comma one and after splicing it, we are
good to go. So if the user card's product exists
and if it is equal, then we need to splice it
out. Otherwise we just need to display the card.
And actually not this, we will splice this
out, but now the thing is this product ID
equals to this product ID. I mean the card's
product ID that while we are looping is equal
to the product ID that we found, then we need to
splice it up. But what if the quantity is one,
it'll just change it quantity to zero, but it'll
still say stay in this cart object as an area.
And it'll still display on the screen showing
that this is zero. So what we need to do to avoid
overcrowding in our database is
check your, if user dot cart I dot
quantity is equal, equal to one. So when the user
clicks on the delete button and we get called to
this, remove from cart API, then we will check if
the quantity is one, that means that the user is
just about to remove this entire product. Then we
are just going to use this user dot card splice.
Otherwise we are going to use user dot card
This line, but here instead of equal,
equal to we'll have minus equal to one.
That means user user dot I dot quantity
will be equal to user dot I dot quantity
minus one. It'll decrease its value by one.
And in case you get confused and you use user dot
card, I dot product dot quantity. Don't do that.
You know, we don't need to use that because
it'll give us the number of total products left,
not the quantity we will have in the product.
So we are essentially changing the products,
quantity over here, both of these match. So if
you decrease this products, quantity wouldn't
even matter because you're not even looking
at it. So we are just decreasing it by one.
So we are just going to have user dot card.
I quantity minus equal to one. After that,
we are going to save it and return it. Now let's
bind this function to our card per screen. Let's
go at the drop and actually in the card
product, we'll avoid decreased quantity
and use final card services, card
services, equal to card services,
take this card services and have dot removed
from card pass in the context and the product,
and then use this decreased quantity. So we can
Wrap <affirmative> wrap this
container with an ink widget,
use the on tap feature. And here we have
Decreased quantity passing the required product
and boom, we have it. Now, if I click on minus
sign, we set it to two. We set this to one, we
set this to two and the value is also changing.
If I restart the application, we should
see the same state of our application.
So if I come where one and two, 2008,
now the next thing we need to work on is
whenever we click on this, we get to an
address box form. And there we do some validations
to check. If the user has already entered the
address, if the user has already entered
the address, then we give them an input
box saying that you want to use this address or
the one that you want to newly form it. And then
we can click on the apple or Google pay, whatever
is provided and continue with that. Let's quickly
do that. All right. So now for the address
screen, I'm gonna close all the safe one again,
and here I'm gonna create a new feature
called address. This will again have
screens and services, so let's quickly create
them. And now this screen will have address
Screened or dot we're going import material dot,
create a state full widget, and then call this
address screen. After that, we are going
to call this as a constant constructor
and here we are going to return a scaffold, which
will have a simple app bar. If you come away,
this is the design of the application. So
you can see this is a pretty basic thing.
We just have a gradient. So now just to
have a gradient, what we're going to do is
go to the home screen, copy this app bar, tell
let's say year only, and then add the remaining
parent thesis by ourselves. We can do that
much after that. We will import this package
and also this plan thesis. Great. Now, whenever
I click on this, I wanna navigate over year. So
obviously we are going to call the static
constant string, route name, call address,
and we are not going to get any constructive
receiver or anything. So that's good. Now
we can copy this address. Screen, go to
the router, create a new route for it.
And we will call this address, screen, route name,
nothing in the construction. So let's remove that
and have address screen, remove this from the
construction as well, and call this as a constant
address screen. Now, whenever we go by your,
whenever we click on this proceed to buy. So let's
go to the card screen and create a function called
navigate to address. So let's copy this, paste
it here and have navigate to address. And
To this address, we are just going to pass in
address green route name. I don't think need
anything else in case we need, we have to make
that changes. So let's quickly remove that out and
here navigate to address in that on tap. We are
going to pass in the navigate to address function
here. The argument has nothing. So let's have
this much and yep. Whenever we click on this,
we come back to the screen. Great. Now, what
is this logic going to be like? I I've already
mentioned it to you. Whenever we have an address,
then we make sure that we show this otherwise. And
as the user, if they want to use this, otherwise
the form. So now we are going to just have a form
in the address screen. So for that form, let's
close the card screen and have, uh, screen dot
file where we are going to con copy all the form
content that we have and paste it in the air
scaffold, which is this body and paste it down
here. After that, we need a custom text field.
So we are gonna import that library. We also need
these controller. So let's see what controllers
we need. These four controllers. So well, let's
name them. We have flat house number building.
After that, we have area
street. Then we have pin code.
After that, we need one more, which is town
and city. So let's copy this much, pasted
down here and have town or city and import
custom button. So let's import that library
and here in the on tap, we will validate later on,
but for now let's remove that and the text is not
gonna be sign up. And actually we don't even need
this custom, but we need an apple pay button right
now quickly create all of these
custom text, field controllers and
a sign up form key. So let's quickly go on the
top and have those text editing controllers
created. So we have text editing controller.
First of all, flat building controller,
which will be equal to text editing controller.
After that we pasted three, four more times,
three more times. Actually we have area
controller, pin code controller, and finally
city controller. Now copy these controllers. So
we have flat building controller, area controller,
then the pin code controller. And finally the city
controller also dispose them off and create the
global variable.
So take them and dispose it over year. And we
going do it more times. So we have four more times
area controller or dispo pin code controller or CD
controller dot dispose. Also
create a global key, which will be
final underscore, not Nell final address
form key, which will be equal to global key.
And then we are going to have a form state. We
have already looked at it. We created this odd
screen. So let's take this address form key, paste
it in the signup form key and have that done. Now,
let's see what we are getting. This looks good
enough. Now let's create the conditional logic for
showing this address if it exists in the
first place. So what are we gonna have? Well,
first of all, get, let's get the user address. So
we have variable address equal to context.watch,
and here we need to import it. So let's get
that import provider. And this will be of the
type user provider person user away and also dot
address because we need to get the user's address.
And now we need to check before entering the form.
So we will check your, and before even checking,
let's actually add a padding to this because
you can see there's no space left from the left.
So we can wrap this with the padding widget,
save this much and you have it. <inaudible>.
Now we are going to have conditional
logic, but before that let's even add the
single child scroll view so that it's
scrollable. And when the screen size decreases,
we've discussed a lot about this, but if
the screen size discusses, uh, decreases,
it's going to be a much, much big use to us when
you use smaller screen size. You'll notice that.
So you're in the column, in the form before
entering the form, you, we are going to first have
a column. And in this column, we are going to
check if address that we have is not empty.
Then we want to display this container with
the text. So again, this will be a column
and why this is a column well, so that we can
add this text and even this or text that we have
along with the size to box away. That's why
we are having them. So we have children and in
the children, we're going to have a container
of decoration, which will be box decoration,
have border, which will be border dot, all pass
in the color, which will be colors.black 12.
After that, in the container, we will have child
and the child will be a text saying that this is
the address, and then style it out, which will be
Constant textile and phone size 18.
After that, let's see what we're getting. We can't
see anything because address is empty in case
we change the value for now. So let's say 1 0, 1
fake street and come back. You can see fake street
showing up just for designing. We are going to use
this fake address, but after we do that designing
part, we can again, come back to this address.
So you are in the chart. We're going to wrap
this with a padding so that it looks much,
much neater and better. So we have, PAing also,
we can specify a width of double dot infinity.
This looks great. After that, we
will have a size box of height 20
after that a constant text saying this is, or,
and then have a style of textile. Well, font size
18, because we want the size to be lower than
the usual, a higher than the usual size. Sorry,
because you can see this is seemingly very big.
Also after this, we, again need to leave some
space for the bottom so we can copy this size box,
paste it down here, come back. This looks
great. After that, we finally need an apple
or a Google pay button. So for that, we are going
to use this play pay plugin so we can copy this
Use dot, add dependency to add this. We need to
stop the app execution and let's read through
the documentation. You can see it only supports
Android and iOS still. Now that was the problem
in case this get gets updated in the future,
I'll add a, a video or a documentation using
which you can add it to your own app in the pin,
common below, be on a lookout for that. So you,
we have apple pay and it tells us to get started
in construction. I'm going to use a test payment
service so that I can test it out. But if you
are a business and looking forward to it, this
is a pretty well-documented thing. You can take a
look at it. I'll if I do this, and if I cover this
part, it'll be the exact same things mentioned
away. So I don't find the need to do it again.
After this, we just need to add this to our
dependency, which we already did. And here you
can see, create a payment profile with a desired
configuration for your payment, either using a
local file or loading it from a remote server, we
are going to use a local file for it and to use
the local file. We're going to go there to this
repository link is mentioned in the description
below in the assets where it is images. We are
going to copy both of these files, apple pay
Jason and GP. Do Jason, if you're not on macwas,
then don't worry. Don't have apple paid Jason,
but in case you want apple pay, it's great enough.
You can have it. It'll display on Android phones,
but I would recommend you to not use this.
We will just use GP for Android devices and
we are going to test it on Android as well.
We have not used it till now, but that's fine.
Where in the assets I've already installed
it. So I'm just going to copy it. So I'm just
going to take these files and past them in the
assets, make sure they're in the assets, not,
not in the images folder. And now what we
need to do is go to the pop spec dot file
and add these two assets. I'm just going
to copy this path and pass in apple, pay
dot Jason. If we see, let's see the name, if
it's correct or not apple paid or Jason, correct.
And we don't need to add this slash because this
is adjacent file. This is a file. This was a
folder. And we needed to include all the images
in this folder. But for Jason, we don't need to
do that. And exactly the same for GP adjacent.
If you want, you could have done assets, but the
thing is it would've loaded unnecessary assets
in a file as well in case our app gets bigger.
So that would mean it would cause the app memory
to increase. And that's why I'm not doing that.
Great. Having that and the pay plugin
install. I'm gonna get out of this form also.
And you're introduce the apple pay button. Now,
obviously I have to run this, but before that,
I need to set up the payment configuration
asset. And this is basically asking for the
payment config file that we've just created.
And then we just need to pass in apple,
pay Jason, no need to mention assets slash
images and all of that part because you are
in the documentation. It is already
written that we need to pass it
in the assets folder. Example, meaning the
name of your project slash assets folder.
So your it'll just navigate through that and
check if there is apple pay. If there is, if it is
mentioned in any other folder, it'll give us
an error and on payment result, we need to
create a function for that. So let's quickly
create that on the top. It'll be called void
on apple pay result. Yeah, we are going to get the
result and yep, that's it. Let's go down again.
Passing the result after that we need
payment items, which for now is going to be,
nullable actually, let's create it at the
top again. So it'll be list of payment item
called payment items, which will be an Mt list
for now, but we're updated later on and later on,
I mean in just some time and now let's run our
application to see what we are getting till now.
I'll go in the DVA console and see, and your
build has failed because here you can see,
this is only available in iOS 11.0 or newer.
So we need to go to our port file
and change this platform. iOS version from
nine to let's say 11. Now save this much,
open up a new terminal. And in the Amazon
clone tutorial route for root folder,
we are going to go to the iOS. And in
there we are going to run port install
here. You can see port installation was completed.
Now I can clear it, go back to the root folder
again, clear it, and then run the file. After
that, we are going to stop all of this and
let's see what we are getting now. All right. So
app has loaded up and now if we go to our card,
click on proceed to buy two items. We can
see the app will pay button let's design.
This app will be button now. So your first
of all, we want the width to be increased.
So we will have double infinity,
whatever space we get in terms of width
here, we have it. Now let's specify the style
secure. We want to apple pay button style dot
and you get a lot of values to choose from. What
I'm going to do is white. Let's see what we get in
white, not looking good. So let's try a different
thing. Let's say white outline. Let's save this
much and here we have apple pay. So let's change
its type. So we have apple pay button type
buy because we need to buy nothing else.
Let's save this much and let's restart
our application because for some change thing,
for some reason, the changes aren't showing up,
let's quickly click on, proceed to buy, and you
can see there are certain changes created. Now,
after that, we need some spacing from the top. So
what we can have is a constant size box of height,
10 given also let's increase its height.
So what we can have is over here, the height as 50
let's save this much looks good enough. Let's add
some margin from the top. Again, not just this,
you know, we have size, but a year
also, it gives us margin, which will be
constant sets dot only. And from the top 15 using
this also we have the top margin creator. Great.
So now let's add the apple pay button so we can
have constant sized box. Let's remove it from
here and paste it over here. We have constant size
box of height, 10, leave some white space, and now
we are going to have Google pay button. So we have
Google pay button. We need to pass in the payment
configuration asset as G chase. Then the on pay
result, payment result, which will be on Google
pay results, just like on apple pay results.
So we are just going to copy this,
paste it away and have on Google pay result,
paste it away and have on Google pay result.
After that we have passed in the payment
items. We won't be able to see it because
apple doesn't support viewing other pay services.
So on iPhone only Google pay button is visible.
Only I apple pay button is visible. So that's
the issue. So let's specify certain properties
that I've tried and tested on Android phone
earlier so that, you know, you can copy them.
And when we check it on Android, you can see
that if you're checking on Android already,
that's great. Let me know in the comment section,
if I got it right. So we are gonna have Google
play button style as black and type is going
to be Google pay button type.by and type buy.
After that, we already need this
margin. So let's add that margin.
And also don't forget to add a
loading indicator, which will be
just a constant centered child, widget of circular
progress indicator. Having that much done.
We have apple and Google pay buttons ready. Now,
if we click on them, nothing really is happening.
And that's because we have not mentioned
payment items anywhere. The payment item
is going to consist of the total bill in our
application. If you want, you can mention each
and every item that the payment items has, like,
you know, if we added iPhone max and everything,
you can create those payment items, but here we
are just going to store the total amount. So to
get the total amount, I think we have to use this.
So we have final spring amount and we'll call this
total amount and require it from the structor.
So let's quickly click on the bell by
and generate total amount construc. Now we
need to go to the router.dot. Also, save this,
go to the router.dot, add this line, paste it
away. And we know this is called total amount.
We need to pass it in the address screen.
So we have total amount, total amount,
and we need to treat it as a string. Yeah, we
have it. Now, whenever we use this address screen,
which is cart screen, we need to make sure
that we pass in the arguments, which is the
total price that it took us. So now we will
have, and some, and now we need to convert
this argument to some dot two string. Great.
Now we can come back over here and now we need
to pass in that like this. If we store it like
this, it'll call the function. We don't need to
call the function. We need to store the address
of this function. And that's why we are using
this kind of thing. And now we need to pass in
the sum, which will be the some that we created
over your, and we actually haven't created that.
So let's create it very quickly. Well, we can just
copy it and we can copy it from card subtotal. So
let's quickly copy this card, paste it over your,
and click close the cards up total part. And now
we need to pass in the sum, which we already did.
Great. Now, whenever we let's restart
our application, click on router.do.
And even in the, in it state, let's create that
part. So whenever we create the, in it state,
what we need to do is add the payment items,
this amount. So we have payment items dot add,
and then we will have this payment item that we
need to pass in. So the amount is widget, total
amount, and this is a string. Then we have the
label called total amount and the status is going
to be payment item, status dot, and you can see,
what is this item status like? Is it final price?
Or the bargainer can negotiate or it's not known
to us so we can have final price done and great
after having this much done, we can come over
here, click on, proceed to buy two items,
click on, buy with pay. And yeah, we have it.
The correct amount is showing your $2,008.
Yeah, we have the correct name as
well. And now if we just click on done,
we can even click on pay with passcode.
Now that is not going to happen right now
because we have not validated on
apple pay result in all of that stuff.
And that's mainly because we still need to make
one more validation. So whenever the user clicks
on this buy with apple pay or Google, what
we need to check is if the user is using this
address that they have already provided us with,
or this form, if they're using this address,
Then <affirmative> then so how
are we going to validate that?
Right? So you are basically, we are going to check
if the user has not entered in any of our forms,
anything that means everything is blank. Then
we are going to use this thing. Otherwise
we are going to ask them to validate this form.
So we are going to create a new third function.
We look into this on apple pay result on Google
pay results later on, but this we have pay pressed
and this will get us the
address from the provider.
Let's name it that only. So this address from
provider will fetch us the value from this
address that we will fetch from provider. But
for now, just for testing, we have changed it.
And here we are going to first create a
variable called string address to be used.
So let's quickly create that and have
string address to be used is equal to empty.
Then we are going to take this address to be
used and pass it in away. So we have address
to be used as empty again. So if the user
clicks on the pay button twice, we need to
make sure that we use different addresses every
time. And the preexisting value gets removed.
After that, we need to check if
the user is using the form or the
address from provider. So here we are just
checking bullion S form. And we just need to check
if all of these are empty or not. So we are just
going to use flat building controller, text.is
not empty or, or, and then just use it three
to four more times. So let's quickly copy that
paste it, paste it, paste it,
and I think paste it. Yeah.
Now save this much. And now we will use
this area controller, pin code controller
and city controller. We are just checking is
they're not empty. If any of the controllers
are false, meaning any of the controllers are
empty. Then the form is also false. And that
means we don't need to use the form here. We will
check if it is form then. So if the form is true,
then we just need to validate the form, right?
So we just use address form key, current state
validate. So if it is a form, then we need
to make sure that it validates. And if the
ations also go well, then the address to
be used is equal to dollar flat building
controller text let's have this. And I think
I pasted it twice. So let me remove it once.
So this is the layout flat building
controller text. Then we need to pass
in the area controller. So we have 1 0,
1, let's say 1 0, 1 building. Then we have
the area controller. So let's say this is some
area like wall street. And just making that up.
Then we are going to have a city
controller. So we have city controller text,
And then we are going to have an fin just to show
a pin code. So we have dollar pin code controller
dot text. After that we are going to save this
much. And this is the address we need to show,
show. Otherwise we need to throw an
exception. We can't just use, uh, you know,
a snack bar. Otherwise it'll further execute
our application, but we don't want that.
We just want to show an error on the screen.
So we will have please enter all the values.
Also, we are doing this through exception because
we are going to use this pay press on, on tap of
this function. So whenever we click on the on tap,
and if there is no exception, then the button like
this will pop up and it'll still allow. Even if
the user is not authenticated, it'll still allow
to show all of this, uh, you know, this payment
methods. We don't want that. So here we are
throwing an exception so that we get the exception
in the DB itself and the button doesn't show up.
After that, we gonna have an LZ checking.
If address from provider is not empty.
So if address from provider is not empty
also, I think we forgot a brace away. Yeah,
this is the F and LS block, but this L just stands
for this main block away. So this block away.
So we have address from provider. If it
is not empty, then the address to be used
is going to be addressed from
provider, right? If it is not empty,
then obviously we are going to take that.
Otherwise we need to show a snack bar saying
error. And this is very rare.
It's just for error handing, but
Great. We have imported that now. Let's
see what errors you're getting down, but,
and the error is there because we added an
extra brace. So let's remove that extra brace
and you all the errors go away. Now
we just need to take this pay press
and add it to the on press. So
let's go down to Google pay button
and have on press passed in. So we need to pass
in the pay press and the address which will be
from the provider. Again, we can copy this, pass
it to the apple pay button. So let's go there
And your pass it in, in the pay.
Sorry on press pass in this sweet.
So now if we see click on
buy with pay, it'll select
the address. So let's also print the address
that it is selecting. So we will have print
address to be used, and let's see what address
gets outputted. So I'm just going to restart
the whole thing. And if it's one zero and
fake street, then that would mean that
we are using the address and we have not filled
the form. So now, if I click on buy with apple
pay, you can see one zero and fake street, Austin,
that's working. Now, if I type, let's say 1 0 1,
click on buy with pay, you can see enter your
area street. And all of that, you are an exception
should come in that enter all the values. And also
you can see the apple pay button. Doesn't show up.
If you just comment this line out and the
LS condition also, it'll throw you it'll.
After showing this validation error, it'll also
show you the button. That's not what you want.
Great. So now I'm just going to enter
everything. So let's say wall street
Pin code will be, let's say thousand one and
the town will be Washington and let's click on,
buy with pay and come back over here. This is
a thing that we are using exactly what we want.
Awesome. Now we just need to create an API because
on apple pay result on Google pay result, handles
the authentication part. So these functions
will get called only when there is success.
So if the user suppose fails the success or just
clicks on X, these functions won't be called.
So we just need to work on the API part
of it so that we store the order. And
then afterwards, we just need to
display these orders. All right,
so now I'll just close this terminal. I'll
restart the application. And before I forget
here, I'm going to use address as a
correct address. So that will be context
dot, watch passing the user provider and use
dot user address. Great. Now also remove this
address to be used. We don't need that anymore.
We are pretty sure of the value that we have
now in the on apple pay result, which you're
going to copy in on Google pay result. Both
are going to have the same thing. You, we are
going check. If provider dot of user provider
Context, user address is empty.
So if the user's address is empty,
then we want to make sure that we store that
address. So for example, if we go where, and
now we don't have that box. So now if we enter in
all the, uh, addresses and click on, buy with pay,
and then click on, buy with pay, then we want
that this address gets stored. We don't want to
formally ask the user to, you know, uh,
enter the address separately. So you're
exactly what we're doing. So now we will create
a services called address services.dot file.
And also we are going to have a small.dot after
that. We are going to com copy most of the things
from admin services. So let's quickly copy that,
paste it over here. Let's remove unnecessary stuff
here. We are not going to require
any of this, even any of this.
And now in the address services, first thing
that we need to create is save user address.
This will only require the user's address and
will be from the user provider. So we need that
after that, we need to use
jtp.post called API slash save
user address. After that we need to pass in
the headers and the body will be Jason encoded,
And we need to pass in the address to
the server side. So we have this address.
Great. Now we just need to error handle this
error. And after this is success, we don't need
to show a snack bar, but we need to store this
address in the user provider. So we will have
user provider dot user dot copy with, and then
use the address. So now we will just decode this
and have response dot body pass in the address
exactly what we've done multiple times before
and here, this will return to us a user model.
So let's import that user model. And now we need
to set this user provider using the model. So we
have user provider got set user from model passing
the user model. Great. We have that created and
the data on the user address is being updated.
Now we can come in the address
screen, create final address services,
and we have not called this address services
address, change of name of the file. Also remove
these unused imports and let's call this address
services. Copy this class, paste it over here,
call this address services
equal to address services,
Copy this address services. And in the, if
condition itself, we're going to save the address.
And the address here is going
to be address to be used,
make sure to not enter provider of user
provider user address that will store
in the providers user address and not the
address from the form. If the user enters one
after this, we just need to save that data. Also,
we need to create the save user address API.
So let's quickly create both of the APIs together.
So the first one is going to be your exercise.
So in the user dot JS file, what I want you to do
is create a post request to save the user address.
All right, that's your task. You can go
ahead anywhere, how whatever you want to do
with it. I highly recommend you to do this
exercise so that you get to know how much
you're understanding. If you're not. Then
later on while we perform other exercises,
you can just know if you're understanding
or not, and then learn from it again.
Were you able to do it? I ideally hope you
were able to do it. That would be really
great to know in the comment section. So we have
slash API slash save user slash hyphen address.
Then we want then a sync request response, and
then we are going to have a try and a catch block,
and we're going have re status 500
Jason as the error with E dot message.
After that in the tri block, we
want to get the user's address. So
we have constant address equal to request body.
After that, we want to find the user so that we
can store in the user's address, property, this
user. So we have eight user it, user dot, find
by ID and find it using request dot user. After
that, we can use user dot address, which is a
property on user equal to the address we receive
from the request dot body. And after that,
we just need to save it. Don't forget to save
it. Otherwise it won't reflect in the database,
even though it will change for some time,
you know, because in the client side,
the unsuccessful person, but over year when
we restart the application, it won't be saved
because in the database it does not save. And then
we need to make sure that we send the user back.
And over here, we are just using that
address part of the user to change it.
Great. After that, we, I promised you without
testing, we are going to move on to ordering
product so that we have some self-confidence in
ourself. It's really bad. I know, but let's try
to do it since you're doing it for fun right now.
So yeah, we are going to have something similar,
a post request to order a product. And we are
going to call this basically simply order.
And from here, we are going to get the card.
So the entire card that the user is ordering,
then the total price, and then the address of
the user, so that we get to know where we are
delivering right now. We don't need the user part
of AR. So let's quickly remove all of that stuff
and now create a model for
order. So we have order dot JS.
Let's quickly create the order. So we have
constant Mongo, which is equal to require Mongo.
And then we require, well order schema,
which will be equal to Mongo. Schema
also create an order out of this, which will
be a model. So we are Mongo dot model and we
will call this order and pass in the order. Schema
also make sure to model export this order model.
And I don't think anywhere we will be
needing this order schema thing. Great.
So now we want this mongoose dot schema. Now,
how is our order schema going to look like
now? I would like to give you
this as an exercise as well,
just brainstorm and think what all things are
required and what are the types going to be in
this order. Schema. Don't worry if it's different
from mine later on, but just try it on your own.
And if both of them match according to you and you
think you'll be able to convert the code ahead,
I would, I would really appreciate that. And
please go ahead and try that on your own.
Were you able to do it? So now we are going to
have products as an a and your first of all,
we are going to have product,
which will be the product schema.
After that, we need a quantity. So we have
quantity as a type of number and it is required.
This is simply similar to the cart that we have
because cart is going to store the products.
Then we have total price and total price
we already saw is of the type number.
And it is required as well after that we have
address. So we want that. So we have type
string required set to two.
After that we have user ID and then we
want that to be required as well. User ID
will basically store who ordered this right
after that this will be of the type string
then ordered at. So the time it was ordered at,
so it'll be of the type number we are basically
going to convert everything and date, time to the
number, which will be milliseconds since epoch,
which will be from the date milliseconds
since, you know, January 1st, 1970,
and then required set to true. Everything
is required except this last part,
which is the status. So what is the status of
my order? It is going to be of the type number
and will be default to zero
visors of the type number. Well, it's mainly
because zero is pending. That means that the
user is just ordered. One will mean completed. Two
will mean received and three will mean delivered.
So zero pending means that the user has just com
placed the order completed will mean that the user
or our product has been delivered from
our side received means that the user has
tick marked it and delivered means, yeah,
both the parties have agreed and all is done.
So now we can come to this order. And in
this order, what do we need to do? Well,
first of all, create a products, temporary
variable at the top, which will be an empty a
here we will have four, let I is equal to zero.
I is less than card length I plus plus, so the
card is going to be again in adjacent format.
We're going to convert it to Jason because we
can't give, you know, like a model to our server.
Now we want to find that particular
product from which we are converting
to the product, you know, from Mongo. So
we have let product equal to a weight eight
product find by ID pass in the IDs
card. I product dot underscore ID.
Then why are we getting this product? Now, we
just need to check if the quantity is greater
than the quantity that we are asked. So if we
have the very first product, let's say iPhone,
we are, we order 20 product, 20 quantities of it.
And that much don't exist only. What do we do? So
we are just checking over if product dot quantity,
if it's greater than or equal to cart quantity,
that means that the quantity that the admin has
decided is greater than what the user is ordering.
Then the order will be successful. So we want
product dot quantity minus equal to card. I
quantity. Then we will just use products, which is
this temporary a that we created dot push, because
we now need to push to this I, this product,
the quantity, which will be card at I quantity.
That means that the order is being placed.
So we are just setting up the order
products. And now we will
just say away product.save.
And we are using this <inaudible>
product.save in the loop itself so that the,
because the products are going to keep changing,
right? So we just need to save it as soon as
the product is your and the product is accessed
using this I variable, which is in the, for loop.
After that, we are going to have this L
condition saying return, re Jason with a message
saying with the back sticks. I've already
mentioned what this back tick are.
Uh, it'll allow us fostering interpolation, which
will be product.name is out of stock. And also
this will change the status code, which will be
400 called bad request. So as do state is 400.
Jason product is out of stock. After that is
done, we need to make sure that the cart is
empty. So we are now finding the user using that
user ID. After that, we are making sure that the
user dot card is set to empty list. And then we
are just using user is equal to avoid user.save.
Now we need to create a new order. So
we have let order equal to new order.
Then we pass in the particular thing. So
that is the first thing that we need. Well,
let's see. Oops, I went too far ahead. So we need
products, total price address, user ID ordered at,
let's see if I remember them. So we have products,
total price, address, user ID, and now the user
ID, you can see, we can't pass it in like this
because the user ID is request dot user. All of
these had the same name, same key and same value,
but user ID has a bit of different and let's see
what else is there. And we have status as well and
ordered at. So we have ordered at new date dot,
get time, get milliseconds, whatever you want,
which is going to store it in milliseconds.
You can see gets the milliseconds of
a date using local time. Great, great,
great. And if you use get time, you can see it
will get us the time value in milliseconds. So
I think I'm going to use it the get time. And
then I will use order is equal to ate order, save
and rest dot Jason, the order, because
we don't really care about the user. Now
user will save. And when this says success, we
will make sure that their cart is also empty. So
now let's go back to address services. And
Instead of fetching all the products,
we are going to place the order. So
let's change this to void place order.
We are going to receive a build context. So
let's quickly add this required build context,
then required string address. And then we required
the total sum that we have after that let's remove
this product list. And now we are going to
have slash admin. Nope, we have slash API
slash order. This is a simplest URL that we have
created. So I remember it and we don't need get,
we need post after that. We need a body which
will be Jason encode, and then we need to pass
in certain things. Well, first of all is cart. So
we have user provider dot item dot user dot cart,
and this is already adjacent format or in a list
format. We don't need to worry about it. And you
have address as address and total price. Let's
convert it to a string. Total price is total sum.
If we go to our user dos, we have card, total
price and address. We have total price pass in
away. Great. After this, we need to error
handling. So yeah, we just need to make
sure that the card is empty. And we also
tell the user that your product has been,
Or your order has been placed. So let me remove
the return product list because this is wide.
And here, first of all, we will have
user user equal to user provider
dot user dot copy with, and we have
a copy with card as an empty list.
Now we will do user provider dot set
user from model pass in the correct user.
And you have it also let's show a snack bar saying
that the order has been place. So we will say
your order has been placed, saving this much, and
let's restart our application. Also in the address
screen, let's bind it all together. Finally. So
we have an address services.place, order passing
the context. Then the address will be addressed to
be used. And the total sum is going to be widget
total amount to string to fix this error. Well,
we have converted it to string and the reason
we converted it to string was actually, if we
see this widget total amount is of the type
Double. So we just need to convert
it to a double. So we will have
double dot pass pass in the widget total amount,
and this will convert it to a double format.
Great. Also, let's copy this and paste it down in
case it doesn't work, then we can obviously change
it later on. All of these functions are bound to
each other, so let's quickly see and wish our app
is now successful. Also let us just proceed to buy
two items. So I'm going to enter one zero one wall
street, call this area, what do I call this?
Now? Let's say one zero, one fake building.
Then this will be called wall street. This
will be the pin code. So let's say 1 0, 0, 0 1.
And the town or city, let's say washing 10,
I'll click on buy with apple pay and close. This
nothing shows up. Nothing is done. So now I
can click on done and pay with the passcode.
And that part is done. Nothing really shows
up. I noticed some kind of error. You can see
in this on Google pay result. We've not
set, listen to false. And even your, uh,
if you go to the on apple pay, we've not
set. Listen to false. Now let's try to run
our application. So if I click on, well,
again, enter some useless information.
We are going to call the street one zero,
zero one, and the town as Washington.
Then we can click on buy and
then click on pay with passcode.
You can see your order has been placed. This
address is showing up. That's a very good sign.
And if you go back, the cart is cleared off
and now everywhere our address is being seen.
So now, if I restart the application, you can
see this address is showing up. Even if I refresh
the browser where we can see in the orders, a
new order is placed with a total price of 2008
ordered at these many milliseconds.
The status right now is zero, and this is the
address where we want to deliver it. Great. So now
the next thing is OER quickly. Let's display the
orders that we have and when we click on them, we
want to display the orders details. All right. So
now I will just close all the other tabs again and
here in the account details. So let's go to the
account part. And in the screens part, let's go to
the account screen. And here we have the orders.
Now in the orders, we need to display stuff.
So here we have the order screen, instead of
displaying the static images, we need to display
our orders. Now that should be very easy to do
so you are in the account. We are going to create
a new folder called services at account services.
And let's give this as an exercise that we need
to fetch all the orders of the particular user. So
try it on your own and not even giving hints
for this one. So go ahead, pause the video and
do it on your own. Were you able to do it,
if not, let's do it and make sure that you
understand the logic behind this. If not,
you can ask me in the comment section below.
So yeah, we are just going to have a get request
because we need to fetch all the orders, right?
So I'm just going to go ahead and copy some
stuff from home services and it'll be a list
of products. So I'm gonna copy this one because
we are going to get all the products of the user.
I mean, all the orders of the user. So here
we can just name this as which my orders.
Then we require the build context. Then the
provider, then user provider, all of that stuff,
then import HTTP as HTTP. After
that, we need to do error handling
and then theri should be
imported from global variables.
And then the Jason decode thing. And I think we'll
have to remove this. And instead I had our own,
uh, instead of product, we will need, uh, order
from Jason and we'll have to create that model,
but we'll create that after creating
the API for our orders. So here,
the API is going to change with API slash orders
slash me. So it'll get all the orders of the user
and we don't need to pass in the UID of the user
because well, we have it in request user. So now
we will go to user dot JS because it's a
user route. We want the user orders. So yeah,
we are going to have user router dot get slash API
slash orders slash me and pass in oath, middleware
and have asynchronous request response, and then
use, try and catch block to catch any errors.
And then just send in any error with a status quo
of five and the name error with E dot message.
After that, we can just come away and, uh,
let orders equal to innovate order dot, find
pass in the required user ID and pass in request
dot user, which will be the user's ID. And after
that, we will just send in this order also
let's put cons to where, because we're doing
nothing else. So we are basically finding all
the orders with this user's ID. And the user
ID is with the request dot user. Now we should
be able to get hold of this. So let's go to the
account services. And in your first of all,
we need to create a model for the user, uh,
for order. So let's quickly go down and create
order or dart file. Let's create an order class
and define some properties of this order.
Class is going have a string of ID,
then a list of products,
which we are going to change.
So whatever product that we get, we need to
convert that into a product model as well.
After that, we need a list of NGER of quantity. So
every product that we are going to store later on
will have its own quantity. Now, instead of
storing it in a map, we are storing it as two
different list. I think it's a better way of
doing it because whenever, uh, ahead, when we see,
when we create the two map and from map functions,
you'll see that this products will get access to
only the product, because this is a list of
product. And here we also need the quantity,
right? So we are creating a separate property
for it. Then we need a string address,
then the string user ID, then the timestamp.
So let's see what we call as a timestamp
in our order GS model. So it is called ordered
at, so let's copy this and call this ordered at,
then we need final end status, and then we need
to generate a construction for this. After that,
we need to create, create Jason serialization.
And here, the two map is fine, but from map,
we need to make some changes. You can see it
takes in list of product from map of products.
And then we are mapping through each and every
one to get product from map X. So here, when we
map through the products, we have both another map
in that product and quantity. You remember that?
So if you come aware, you can see this is the
products added that it is counting. So we have map
our products, it's mapping through everything and
then creating a product from that mapped product.
So we have access to only one product. So we have
access to this whole object away. So it's creating
the product from this whole object and this whole
object consists of product and quantity, both. So
it'll give us an error. It'll give us Nu whatever
that we have, because we can't create a product
from map of an object, right? So here we need to
pass in product. And the same thing for quantity.
We, your, we are list of end from
map of products. Well, first of all,
and then we need to map through all of them. So we
have get, we get access to X and then we will have
X at quantity as a returning value. So we
map through the products and then we have X
dot, uh, X quantity return. This should be great
for us. Also, the ID should be map underscore ID,
make sure to make that change because here the
ID is underscore ID. After that, we can go to the
account services and instead of having
product list, name, we are gonna change it.
So I'm pressing option on Mac just
to grab each and everything, your,
and then convert this to well order list. And here
it didn't get selected. So let me remove this. And
here we have it order list, and it will be a list
of orders. So you are also, we are gonna have a
list of order and you are going to con have order
from Jason. And then all the logic that we have,
this will convert it to Jason. This will convert
string to convert Jason, to string. And then
this will convert this to our order model
And then return it. Then we need to go in the
orders and create and remove this temporary
list that we add. And instead of that,
we are going to have list of orders, which
will be called orders. Let's import order.
Now we will create init state remove the
implement init state functionality thing.
Then you, we are going have fetch orders, take
this fetch orders, create avoid function for it,
call it asynchronous. And now also initialize
account services. We are already familiar with
all of that stuff again and again, we are
doing this. I hope it's gonna practice. Now
we will have account services equal to account
services. Now we can take this account services,
set it to orders, and this will be equal to
innovate account services dot switch my orders.
We will pass in the build context and it
doesn't require any category. So we need
to go to our function and update it. So let's
go to our function, remove this category thing.
Also remove this product dot, do no
necessary imports and then call set
state. So that function rebuilds, and here we
will check. If order is equal, equal to Nu,
then show a constant loader. Otherwise a column
Also, let's go down here and instead of item,
count as list.link, you're
going to have orders.link.
And even here, the image is going to be
orders at particular index products at zero
images at not index, but zero. So here, what we're
doing is grabbing one particular order because we
are in a list view builder. So we are grabbing one
particular order. It's products and products can
be an a, so we're grabbing the very first element
Or the very first product, and then showing it's
very first image. Now, if we save
this much, let's see what we get.
We are getting a loading indicator. That seems
to be good. Let's see, in the DVA, what we get
when we click away, we have our orders showing up.
Now the next thing is, whenever we click on this,
we need to go to the order detail screen. And
she see the details of this order. This should
be very easy to do so let's implement it quickly.
All right, so now let's close all the safe files,
even the terminal. And in here, we are
gonna create another feature called order
details and then create a screen for that
called order detail screen. So let's create it.
Now, this order detail screen is going to
be repeated throughout our application now.
So even the admin screen, we're going
to use it. So that's pretty cool.
Now we don't wanna create a stateful budget out of
this, and we will call this order details screen.
And also here, we need to get access to the order
because we need to display an order based
on what order we get, right? Just like the
single product widget that we created. So here
we have required this dot order. Also create a
route name for this. So we have static, constant
string, route name, equal to slash order details.
Now, after this, we can take this route name,
go to the router.dot and pass it in. So we have
order details, screen, route name. So let's remove
this extra route name and here, whatever we get
should be treated as an order. And your, we
will call this order. Also, let's take this,
pass it in away and pass in the order detail
screen. After that, we also need an order. Great.
So after having this much, we need to
create the UI offer application. Now,
how do we go about it? Well, first of all,
convert this in a scaffold and here we see
the very first thing is an app bar. So we'll
go to the home screen, copy this entire app bar
and paste it over here. Now, obviously we will
also need the navigate to search screen thing.
So we will paste that also at also then
we also need to import global variables,
import search screen, and great. We have this.
Now let's save this much, go to our orders dot
file. And you are, you're going to wrap this
single product with a gesture detector. Again.
Now this gesture detector will help us
navigate to this particular order detail
screen. So you have navigator dot push named
Pass in the route name, which will be order
Detail, screen, route name pass in the arguments,
which will be orders, add particular index so that
we pass in one particular order. And this will
fetch us from the list, a particular order. Now we
can come back to orders, detail screen, and if we
click, we get navigated. Great. Now the very first
thing that we need to see is this text and this
box with order date, order ID, and order total
let's quickly set it up. So we have a body where
we are going to have a single child scroll view,
obviously, because this has a very great chance of
scrolling. Then we have a child and then a column
and column has many children. So the
first child is going to be the text
that just says view order details. So we have
constant text view order, uh, I think, yeah,
then we need to pass in style, which will
be textile of font size 22 and font, weight,
or font, weight bull. After that,
we can just see what we are getting
looking great. Then we just need to wrap it with
a container so that we can show this box with
some border. So we'll wrap it with a container
with a child as a column of these texts. And
this container will have some border like this. So
obviously we are going to app it with a container.
Then we need to pass in a decoration so that we
can have a border. So it'll be box decoration and
box decoration will have border as border dot, all
Color as colors.black twelves. After that,
we are going to have the child as a column
of all these texts so we can pass it in.
So we have children and the very first text that
we have is order date. So we have order date
as widget order created at or ordered at let's see
ordered at. And then I think this much is enough.
So let's quickly save this and see what we are
getting. All right, order data showing up.
This is correct, but we need to format this
so we can just see if so to format this.
Well, we have to use another dependency called
Intel. You should be very familiar with this
because it's a very great date format for us.
So we are gonna stop our app execution. And now,
Even though it's looking great while there are
certain changes, UNC, that it's very stick
to the left side. So let's add a padding to
this entire column and wrap this with
a padding. This is called refactoring,
and now we're not able to see the changes, but
there would be something, all right, let's run
without debugging and see what we're getting.
All right. So wraps load it up. I'll cancel the
Debu console. And here I'll go to the, my orders
and you can see some padding has been created,
but now we can also use Intel. So now we can
update format and let's see why we are not getting
anything. So we need to import Intel. So yeah,
I have imported it at the top. So I'll do date
format dot and you can see it gives us all the
methods, but we are going to use its object to
format it. And here we need to pass in a date.
So yeah, now we need to pass in the date time.
So now to create date, time from milliseconds,
we can use datetime dot from millisecond since
epoch and epoch refers to VJA milliseconds,
micro, not microseconds milliseconds
from milliseconds. Let's quickly format this
Millisecond since Och and now Och refers to
January 1st, 1970. So we just need to pass
in the milliseconds that have passed from
then, and this will convert it to daytime
and we are passing it in. Let's see what we
are getting. So here we are made 13 20, 22, 1
10 54 air. That looks great. So after this, well,
first of all, let's design the container. It's not
taking the entire available space. So what we can
pass into this container is padding, no, sorry,
width of double infinity. And it'll take in all
the available space. And now we need to make
sure that there's some bit of PAing your inside
as well. So we have constant sets dot all 10,
and now this looks good. Also, this, all of
this came in center. So the column should be
having cross access alignment of
cross access, alignment dot start.
And you, we have, it looks great after that, even
this column, the necessary column that we have
should have the same property so that this comes
away cool. After this, we need order ID. So let's
quickly create a text saying order ID and pass
in the order ID, which will be widget.order.id.
And we are going to have order total, which
will be widget order, total price. So let's
quickly go to the order model and we forgotten to
add the property of final, double, total price.
Let's receive it through the, through
the constructor. Now we will have
total price pass in the total price.
Then we are going to pass in total price
over here, which will be map at total price.
And we convert it to double and check. If it's Nu,
then we want to pass in 0.0. Otherwise the map,
total map, total price. Then we come back
over here and pass in map.order.total price.
And for now it'll not show
anything. Yep. We need to reload it.
So let's quickly come over, click on order.
And yeah, we have it order total of 2008.
So obviously we need to add a dollar
sign. So we pass in slash dollar.
Great. So we have order total showing up as that.
Now let's align all of these three together. Like
we have over here. So let's just space it out,
the least effort, the way we can do it. So I think
this much seems to be enough,
so let's space it out even more
and save it.
Yep. Let's base it out even more
and even your more, yep. This looks
good to me. So if you have any
changes, you can just make it, let's shift this
a bit away actually once face away. Yep. We,
this looks good. Now after this, we
need the purchase details, which will
show all the products with that quantity.
So we have constant after this container,
we have, we are going have constant size box of
height 10, and then we have a constant text of
purchase details. So we can just copy this text,
paste it over here and have purchase details
and save it. You, we have it resort after
this. We will obviously create a container
and then pass it in over here. And we need the
same border and the width will be same. We need
a bit of padding as well, but I don't think
we need to specify any of those properties.
So in the child government to have a column,
which will have a main access alignment
of main access alignment got start so that the
column doesn't start from the middle, right?
And now in the children, we have to remove
all of these texts because we don't have them.
And now what do we need to do? Well, we
have multiple products in that because we
have a products. I, so we need to run a four loop
displaying each and every product. So we have four
entire equal to zero. I is less than
widget.order.products.link. I plus, plus
Then we are going to return a
row which will have children.
And the first child is going to be image.network
of widget dot order dot products@i.total.total,
because we don't want to show the
price. We need to show the image.
And we are going to show the very
first image as the cover image.
Let's see what we're getting. Yeah, we are
getting it correctly. So yeah, we are just
going to reduce the height. So we have height
as one 20. The width has one 20 and save it.
Yep. Now, now this is looking better. Now
we are going to have some spacing left
and then we will leave a size box of width five,
and then we want to enter the products name.
And since this is in row, we can use
for loop again and again, over here and
make sure to not add something like this,
because these are collections in flutter.
They don't allow to add this braces and you
can only do it for one particular widget.
So after this, we need expanded and expanded
is going to have a child which will be column,
which will have children. And the first
child is going to be the product's name. So
let's quickly create that text. So we have
text widget dot order dot products@i.name
And then get the style. So we have
constant textile as font, size 17
and font weight. So we have font ways, weight as
font, weight dot bowl. After that let's come over.
Yeah, we have it also let's put the cross access
alignment as cross access alignment dot start
suite. Now we just need a quantity. So we will
pass in the required quantity, which will be
Again, another text. And we will remove all
the styling. We don't need any of that styling
and we'll just pass in quantity and we are not
getting access to this products. Quantity. If
we get access to this products dot quantity,
it'll give us the quantity of the number of
products that are left. So here we need to
get the orders, quantity, not the product,
that individual products quantity. So we have
widget dot order dot quantity. I two string.
So with this, we get the order and we have the
list of integer of quantity so that we get every
product's quantity as it is. And if you save
this much, we have two selects quickly pass in,
pass it in as a string, which will be quantity,
passing dollar sign and use string interpolation.
Now we don't need that two string method
away anymore. And now we have it look school.
Now let's just make some changes in this text.
So we have max lines as two and overflow as text
overflow dot SIS. And that's why we have wrapped
this entire column with an expanded widget so that
the text can overflow to max two lines. Otherwise
it'll just start showing.dot do over here. Great.
Having the purchase details set up. Now,
the next thing is to show these tracking.
So what we going to do is copy the
size box and this constant text
past it in, after this container
and here we are going have tracking
and past it in. Now we can see tracking again.
We are going to have a container, but in that
container, we are going to have a new widget,
which I'm not sure if you've seen it before,
but it's pretty interesting. So we have it
now instead of returning this entire column
or so instead of returning this entire
column, what we are going to do is from your,
we are going to have a widget known as tepo. So
with this step, it'll allow us to make something
like this pretty easily. You'll see that. So
the, uh, required arguments will pass in steps.
So let's define the steps that we have. Well,
the first step is the pending step. So created.
So we need a title which will be a constant
text saying pending. Then we need a content
which will be a constant text saying
your order is yet to be delivered
and then pass the trailing comas. Yep. Now
let's see how it's looking. This looks good.
And we look into these action buttons
later on because these actions buttons
should only be available to the admin, not to
the user, but we look into that in some time.
So after the steps, we need two more steps. So we
have one more after this and one more and actually
one more. So this was the pending text. Now we
need to pass in completed text. And here it'll say
that your order has been delivered. You
are yet to sign and what signing. I mean,
just the document or whatever. It asks us to sign,
to verify that we have completed the thing. Then
we need to pass and received. And here it'll be,
your order has been delivered and signed by you.
And finally it's called delivered. And this
delivered is again gonna be of the same text,
but it will not be visible at all. And
it'll just say that, yeah, your order has
been delivered and signed by you, but it's just
telling that both the parties have agreed to it
and you have it. You can see this looks cool
already. Now let's remove these action buttons.
So we can come down at the top in the stepper,
we are going to define controls builder with this
controls builder builder. You can define what the
controls are going to show up. Well, we are going
to, first of all, return context and details.
So context is the bill context and details will
tell us the current extent that
we are on and all of that thing.
So yeah, we are just going to return a constant
sized box because we don't want to see anything at
all. So you can see nothing shows up and
now we need this highlighting to be done,
right? If we have pen, the
order has been completed,
then we want to see completed pending and all of
that task. So that highlighting has to be done.
So for that, we are going to go on the
top and create a global variable called
current step. Let me quickly have current
step, and this will be equal to zero initially.
And this is why we have sta so we have made
sure that the status here is zero because
in the stepper we have to pass in the integer
value. So having anything else like received or
some text away would be very difficult to convert
again and again, and would introduce chances of
bugs. So now let's create an N stage function
and here we will have current step
equal to widget order dot status.
And now we will use this current step as
the current step for our stepper widget.
So if we go to the stepper, we are going to
have current step passed in as the current step,
save this much. Now, if active is going to be
well, a bullion value saying if the current step
is greater than zero or not. So if the current
step is greater than zero, that means that
it is active. And yeah, the current step is
not greater than zero. It is equal to zero. So
just to demonstrate, if we put in equal to,
you can see this is highlighted. So we are
gonna have something similar over here. So let's
quickly pass that we will pass in one over here,
two over here, and then this will be greater than
or equal to three. So if by chance we become three
or greater than three, it's not possible just
for error purposes, we can handle this over you.
And now we have everything set up. So now last
thing is if that part is completed. So if you saw,
even if it is completed, it's showing it's
highlighting it. So let me just quickly show
it to you. If I put equal to where and come
back, you can see, even though it is completed,
it's showing one. I don't want to show
one. I want to show a tick mark sign.
So what I can do is first of all, remove
this equal to sign and pass in state.
So state will define how our step state is going
to look like. So if current step is greater
than zero, then I wanna make sure that the step
state is complete, which is that tick mark sign,
otherwise step state dot indexed. That means the
numbering part, which is by default. If you hover
over this, you can see it is step state index.
Now we're gonna copy this for straight away,
pass one, pass in two, and your passing
greater than or equal two, three.
So having this stepper widget and
all of the order details created,
let's jump into the admin side of things. All
right. So now let's again close, all close, all
the safe files and all the features, because now
we are gonna jump in the admin side of things and
we are rarely going to use anything now from these
screens. I mean, we are going to reuse widgets,
but not any screen as such. So yeah, we are going
to create a new screen called orders, underscore
screen dot, and it's going be very similar to post
screen. So let's quickly. So yeah, we are gonna
import material dot, create a state full widget
call this orders screen, and this will show us
all the orders that are there. So we are going
have a scaffold, actually not a scaffold because
I wanna show you, or actually let's just first
change the user's type so that we get to the
admin side of things. So I think the email
over here was this, so I can type the admin.
And now if I just return a container for
now and restart the app, we see the admin.
So here we want to see the orders page, not
the card page, but all the orders. So for that,
we are going to return a grid view builder
because we are already having a scaffold away
and then we need to pass in the item count, and
now we need to create an API for that. So let's
quickly create that in the admin services.dot
file. Let's minimize all of this account features
and go to admin services, dot dot five, remove dot
FFI. We imported that by mistake and go down and
we need to fetch the list of orders. So what I can
do is copy this and paste it over here, call this
fetch all orders and similar to the product
API. We're going to have that. So let's take
it as an exercise. Please do it on your
own. And let me know if you could do it
all right. So now what we need to do is have
user provider, and this will be a list of orders.
Also, we are going to return a list of order,
and now we are going to use this admin
thing and get the orders, not products.
Then we are gonna pass in the token and
then we are going to handle the error.
And in the, on success, we are going to have
order dots from Jason, remove on from Jason.
And even here, we will name this as an order list.
So let me quickly grab all three of them and pass
in order and person or the list. Pretty familiar
with that. Aren't we, we can just copy this and
we'll use it, but for that, we need to create an
API. So let's go to the admin JS part and get all
the things. So create a route and pause the video,
create a route and let me know if you could do it.
All right. So vLab admin router dot
get slash admin slash get orders,
passing the admin middleware, then asynchronous
request response. Then we have a try
and catch block. Mary, we are
going to have rest Jason at 500
and restaurant state, sorry,
500 Jason error and E message.
Then we need to get all the orders. That should
be like the products part. You can see we have
this. So it's very going to be very similar. We
just need to replace the variable name and the
product model name. So we have a eight order
dot fine, and we need to import this order
So we can come aware and have
constant order equal to require
Slash slash middle middleware model
slash order. And then over here,
we just need to return rest Jason at all
the orders. And we have the route created.
Now, if we come aware and create the in state
function, then the list of the products part,
I hope you add, uh, stop the video and tried it
on your own. It's very, very similar to what we
have done. It's just using some logic to make
difference. And we also create admin services,
admin services equal to this admin services.
After that, we are going to take this.
So also call fetch orders function, create this as
an asynchronous function, take this fetch orders,
paste it in over year. And then we have admin
services dot fetch, all orders pass in the context
and there we have it. Also, we need to make sure
that we store it in the orders variable because
that's what it's going to return. Is it, uh,
return it to us. And that's why we have made
this as an asynchronous function. Let's mention
the function type. Great. So now we need to pass
in the item count, which will be orders.link. Then
we need to pass in the item builder. And here we
are going to get context and index, and we are
going to have final order data equal to orders
At that particular index. So it'll give us one
particular order, which we are going to use.
So we are going to have a return property,
which will be size box so that we constrain
it to a particular height. And we have height
as one 40 and the child as a single product.
We already remember that now we are using the
same widget that we created for displaying order
as well. And we are just taking in an image. So
yeah, the image is going to be ordered data dot
products, and we are going to grab the
very first product and its very first image
because product is a list. So we
have products at zero images at zero
and yep. Now we need to pass in the
grid delegate. So let's pass in grid
delegate. Now what do we want? Well, the
grid delegate should have something like,
you know, both the sides, only two products
should fill in in the horizontal direction.
So we have constant sliver grid delegate with
fixed cross access count plus and two. And yeah,
let's bind this order screen to our admin
screen, which will consist of the bottom nav bar.
So are instead of showing cartage, we are gonna
show orders, screen passing the constant array.
Also in this order screen,
we are going to check if orders is equal
to Nu, otherwise it'll give us an error.
So if orders is equal to the Nu, then we wanna
show a loader. Otherwise a grid view builder.
Now let's see diva, no error still.
Now let's restart our application.
Yeah, the products and yeah, we are not seeing
any product because you have not called set state.
So let's quickly call the set state function and
you can see if we don't call it, the builder's not
rebuilding only. Right. That's right. And
here we have the order shown again. Let's
restart. See the console come back and
yeah. Yeah. Now whenever we click on this,
we need to go to the order detail screen so
that the admin can mark as completed or not.
So what we can have is over here, the size box
should be wrapped with the gesture detector
pass in the on tap as navigator push named, pass
in the route name, which will be order details,
screen, route name, pass in the argument and it'll
be order data. Great. Now, if I click over here,
we get to the order, the task screen. Now
we need to be able to make sure that we can
make some changes, aware. We talked about, you
know, having the buttons aware so that we can
mark them as spending completed or received.
So let's quickly create them. So here our
Order detail screen itself, let's go down
to the stepper widget. I've used control F
to find a particular widget away and we have the
stepper widget here. We have the controls builder.
Now what we need to check in this controls
builder, if the user's type is adamant or not.
So again, we will go up here and actually in
the be function called final user is equal to
provider.off user provider context. And we will
also use user. I don't think we need to use user
provider to store any user data. So you, in the
step of widget we have, if user dot type is equal,
equal to admin. So if it's an admin, then we need
to show a custom button telling them if it's done,
then click on done so that we can come to the
next step. So we have return custom button
saying done and on, on tap, we need
to be able to change the order status.
So let's create an API for that. But
for now we are going to keep the on tap.
Let's keep it with an error so that
we can come back here very soon.
So we are going to do this in the element
services. So I'm just going to copy one of this
function. So, yep. And this should be
fairly easy for you two. So pause the video,
go ahead. Do it. There's no harm in doing it.
So now in the world we have change orders, status,
Accept the build context and require end status.
So we need to get the status of the product that
we have so that we can increase it by one or
otherwise. We are just going to pass in the change
order status from there and increment the
status by one so that we can set the status
to a new value and we don't need on
success anymore. I mean, we need it,
but we also need an order value. So we have
required order order with this order. We get
access to the order ID and on success
so that we can, you know, update the
thing real time. So if we click on done, it'll
be done in the database, but it'll not refresh.
So we need to make sure we call search
date and increment the value by one.
So here we have user provider. After that,
We need a response and here we need to pass
in the ID, which will be order ID. And then
the on success should be on success. You can do it
this way or you can just pass in on success a way
like this. Both of them are completely fine and
we are now return types. So we are not returning
anything. So now, uh, let's quickly create this
post request. So I'll name this change order
status and quickly copy this, go to admin or JS
and create a post route. So let's just copy this,
paste it away and call this well, let's copy it
again and past it away. So yeah, we have access
to the ID. So that is the ID. And other than that,
I think we also need access to the status, right?
I mean, we are sending the orders ID, but
we also need to send the updated status.
So we have status and pass in the status.
Otherwise, what you could have done is
incremented the value there itself by getting the
previous over year itself, by getting the previous
value of the status and incrementing it by one,
it would be the same thing, but I think we can
pass in the status, right? So here we are going to
get order ID and status. Then we are going to find
the particular ID by using of eight order find by
ID. We don't need to delete anything. So we just
need to find by I ID and after getting that ID, we
need to update it status. So we have order status
equal to the status. As I said, if you want,
you can just use order status plus equals one.
And that is completely fine too. I think this
one and that one is only the same thing itself
after that we just need to do order is equal
to eight order.save and then return the order.
All right, let's come back over here. And
in the on tap, we are going to create a
function at the top called change order
details. So avoid change order status,
and let's create a comment over saying only for
admin and like this <laugh>. Yep. So that it
grabs attention. You know, otherwise user will
get confused. You know, why are we using this
function in order details, which will only be for
the user side. We never said it's going to be for
the user side. Great. So now we need to have final
admin services created the instance of this class.
And then we are going to take this admin services
change or status pass the context and the
updated status. So the updated status is
whatever status is right now. Plus one, how do we
get the current? Well, we can ask her over year.
Otherwise we can just use current step plus
one, or both of them are the same thing.
And now passing the order and the order is
going to be widget dot order and in on success,
what are we going to do? Well, this is going
to be interesting. So in the, on success,
whenever there's on success, then we
need to make sure that the current step
increases by one. So what we need to do is
set state current step plus equal to one.
And that's it that makes our app look real time.
Now in the on tap, we just need to pass in this
change order status and then pass in the status.
Now here we could have passed in current step,
but you know, we could have done that over
there as well because current step is a
global variable here. I'm gonna make use of
this details property that the stepper widget
only gives us to find the current step that is
there. So whenever we click on this done button,
it'll take that current step and increment it
by one, which the details builder will give us,
you know, so yeah, you can see, we have the
button done button and if I click on it,
it's completed. And if I go to the
user side of the application, so
let me quickly make this as a user and update it
And then restart the application here. If I go to
the product details, you can see it is spending,
but we are not getting the option to edit.
And it has made this as a tick mark, you can try
it on your own. So we have that completed. Now we
are able to change the order status. Now the final
thing that we need to work on is showing the user,
the graph based on the category and also the total
earnings still now. All right, so now let's create
a new route for it. We are not starting with the
screen UI because this is going to take some time
the earnings part. So let's quickly create
admin router dot get, because now we don't
wanna post anything. We just need to get the total
earnings that we have had till now. So we slash
admin slash analytics pass in the admin middleware
and then have asynchronous request response
and then have a try and a catch block.
So now we will take this risk and pass
it in over here. Now we need to get the total
earnings. First of all, now to get the earnings.
First of all, we need the orders. So let's
get all the orders and have of eight order dot
find and not promise provider order.
So yeah, order dot find and pass it in
with an Mt basis so that we get all the orders now
to get the total earnings, we just need to create
a global variable or a local variable in the
function, total earnings, and well, what do
we need to do? Well, let's look at the orders
collection just so we know what we are doing.
So here we need to go through every product
that is there in order, and we need to go
through every order. So suppose have another
order like this. You can presume I have.
So we need to go through every
order. And in every pro order,
we need to go through every product that is
there and add their total earnings to this
total earnings variable. So how are we going to
implement that? Well, for let I is equal to zero,
I is less than orders length. So where we are
going to have one and then increment the I value,
then we are going to have another for loop so
that we go through every orders, products value.
So we have four. Let the for let J is equal
to zero. J is less than orders dot length,
J plus plus. And now what we need to do is add the
total earning with every orders, products that is
there, and this will not be orders dot length,
you know, because here we are already in the
orders list. So we went through every list and now
we need to go through every product that is there.
So here we will have orders at I, which will Fe
us that particular order dot products dot length,
which is this I, so that we go through every
product in this. I, now we can take this products.
So we have orders at I products, which will
give us the particular orders, products I,
and we need to fetch that particular product. So
we have at J and then to get the total earning,
what we need to do is multiply this quantity with
this product's price, right? So we have quantity,
which is one and two 10. So we have 30. So
we need to do exactly that. So we have J
quantity and we can copy this whole thing
again and have products at J product. You
can see where we have product away. And then we
need to pass in dot price. So we have dot price.
So after this, we have access to the total
earnings, but that's not it. We also need to
get the category vice products so that we can show
it in the graph. So here we are going to create
a new function for it together. And we are going
to call this function Fe category vice products,
and here get the category. And we don't need
to mention the type of error because as I told
JavaScript is a dynamically type language.
And now to make this function asynchronous,
we can pass an asynchronous over year. Otherwise
we could have created function like this,
which will be constant fit category, product equal
to this and pass in an arrow function like this
and call this asynchronous like we've created
callback functions multiple times, but let's
try an alternative syntax right now. So yes, Aing
function. And we have the category now as well.
So we need to find the category orders.
So we will have let category orders
equal to ate order dot find. And now
what do we need to find? We need to
find the orders of that particular
category. So let me minimize this.
So we need to find orders in every product
to check if their product aware is having
the category of the category that is mentioned
away. So for that, we are going to pass in a
string. Every time we did a category like this,
for suppose, if we have a way product fine,
then we need to, to pass in category like
this. But for order, we need cat products,
which is this the main area inside of that
product, which is this one area, which we can
call products. So we have this particular
product and we need to find its category.
So we have dot category and you can
see the error already showing up.
We can't use anything like this, so we need
to convert it to a string and then match it.
So we need to match it with the category and
boom, we have all the category orders. Now,
now similar to this part, we need to loop
through all the products so that we can get
their total earnings. Also, we need
to create a variable called let
earnings equal to zero. We will take this earnings
and replace total earnings with this earnings and
use category orders anywhere we see orders.
So we have category orders, category orders,
category orders, and even your category orders.
And finally, after that,
we need to return earnings.
All right, now we can take this fetch category
wise product and use that. And we need to use this
five more times, right? We
have five categories created,
so to get category wise. So let's type
it here. Category wise, order fetching.
Now we can just do eight fetch category, vice
product and pass in mobiles as the very first
category. I hope that is what we named it.
If we go back to our global variables here,
we can see we have mobiles essentials appliances.
So we just need to copy names from your,
And then we are going to save it in our mobile
earnings variable so that we can send it to
our client side. And we are going to paste it
four more times. Let's remove one more time.
And now we have essentials. So let's paste it
AER. Then we have appliances let's past that
after that books and then fashion. So let's
pass it in. And we are copying it from your,
not from the list that we created while giving the
admin the option of, you know, selecting from a
dropdown menu. And that's because we are already
matched. Then the name of the category products
over here, it's going to be called essential
earnings. Then we need appliance earnings.
And let me just name this correctly.
Alright. After that, we have book
earning books, earnings, and fashion earnings.
Great. Now we just need to send it over. So
let's create an object for that called earnings
and then it'll include the total earnings and
all these category earnings. So we can
use the shorthand syntax and pass it in
essential earnings, appliance, earnings,
books, earnings, and fashion earnings.
Now we can just use res Jason and
send this earnings that we created.
Great. So we have this admin analytics. Now we
just need to display those analytics. So what we
can do is go to the client side and close admin.
So we have a new screen now called analytics,
underscore screen.dot import the material dot
and create a stateful widget called a analytics
Screen, call it as a constant. And
now we are going to return a column.
This column is going to show the graph and the
total earnings, but before showing that let's, you
know, create an API for that in admin services.
So we'll quickly go to the admin services and
here we need to create a get request. So let's
see if we have a get request already created
and we already have that. We need to make
some changes earlier, but that's fine.
So here have now here, instead of returning
a list of orders, what we are going to return
is a map of string com dynamic. And that's
because you're not converting anything,
right. We will get that data in a map or string,
and then we will create it in a new refined
map or a string, and then get
and display those earnings.
So we have the earnings, we will require
better context. And now this will be of sales.
And for that, we are going to create a new
model. This sales variable is going to help
us plot on the graph. So for that, we can create a
new model so we can create it in the admin itself,
because this is not going to be a public model.
It's going to be only for the admin to see. So we
can create a sales model there. And it's going to
be very different from what we've already created,
because you're not going to have Jason
serialization or copy with function,
anything like that. So here we are gonna have
class sales and it'll just have a string of label
of what to display and then the total earning.
So we have final end earning and take the sales,
pass it in this dot label, this dot label, then
this dot earning. And this is not even a name
construction. And this is what we are going
to have list of order list of sales of sales.
After that, we're going also
going to store the total earning.
So now we're going to return these both
as a map sales and the total earning.
So you are, uh, let let's quickly pass in
the admin. So we will have, well, let's see
admin slash analytics passing the required
header. It's a get request on nothing else is
required. Also the total earning can be zero for
now and in on success, things are gonna be very
different. So let's remove it. So what
we are going to have is first of all,
convert the response in adjacent in a normal
format. So we are going to decode that Jason,
and we need to call this, let's say response so
that it's different from this response over year,
after that, we need to set the total earning
a total earning will be equal to rest
points. Don't use risk because the response is
adjacent format. You can't access it, but this
response is dynamic and it'll just decode that
adjacent data. And we can access total earning
on it, make sure that this total earning away is
similar to the admin route that we passed away,
which is total earnings. And we've already
made a mistake. So let's fix that after that,
we need to add to the sales variable, the
Labels and all the sales model. So we have sales
and we need to pass in the labels.
So the label's very first label
is going to be mobiles. And these labels are
basically, what's going to show up on the graph.
So that's what we are creating because we directly
need to show it on the graph. So we have mobiles
and then we have response of mobile earnings
<affirmative> and then we need to add more, but
let's quickly verify that we are going correct.
So we have mobile earnings and all of them have an
S at the last, so there's no scope of error now.
So let's quickly add these four new categories. So
we have essentials passing, essential earnings,
then we need books. So we have book earnings.
And now I'm again, confused if I named it
correctly, Nope. We need to access books earnings.
Then we have appliances. We will
access that using appliance earnings
and then finally fashion, which will
be response at fashion earnings.
After having both of these created, we need
to return a map, which will be first of all,
the sales. So we'll pass in the sales and then
the total earnings, which will be total earning,
Or you can just rename this. But I think just
to have so many variable aim is going to be
disturbing. So let's pass in total earnings
itself. Now we can go to the analytics screen,
create an in edge state function and remove the
to-do part and also create, get for, get earnings,
take this, get earnings. And we are going to
call this asynchronous and now we will finish
the data. So again, final admin services.
Admin services is equal to admin services,
create a global variable of total earnings. So
we have end total sales, which can be nullable
because the total sales can be zero.
But if we pass in Nu it can be nullable.
So we can check that way and similar thing
for list of sales. So we have earnings.
Now, what we will do is to it in a variable called
where variable earning data, which is equal to
elevate admin services dot get earnings pass in
the context. Now, this earning data is a map. If
you, however, this map string dynamic, because
the return type of this function was map string
dynamic. Now we need to set this to total earnings
or total sales, which will be earning data
At total earnings. And then earnings
will be equal to earning data
at sales. Then we need to set state and yeah,
we have it done. Now. Uh, now the thing now,
why we created this in a separate variable
so that we don't have the call, the function,
this function two times, right? Otherwise what we
would've to do is pass it in over here, like this,
then like this, remove this and remove this. And
that would be really bad, you know, calling the
function two times. So instead, what we are going
to do is earning data and then save it like this.
After that, we are going to check if earnings is
equal, equal to Nu, then we need to show a loader
and <affirmative>, and this now earnings
is not our, the sales is not the total
sales, sorry. So if either of them are Nu,
we want to show a loader, otherwise a column. Now
this column will be children. And the first child
that we need is a text showing the total sales
so that we finally have an output on the screen.
So we have total sales pass in the dollar away
So that we get total sales, variable,
and pass in the dollar sign. After that, we
are going to have a style and we are going to
call this as a constant textile of font,
size 20 and font, weight of font weight.
So now if we see the output, we can see anything
because we need to bind this analytics screen.
So let's quickly go to the admin screen and
pass in the constant analytics screen. After
that let's restart and see what we are getting.
So yeah, if I go there, we can see total earnings
as 2008. And we placed an order of 2008,
which is great. It's working now after this,
we need to show a chart. And for chart, we
are going to use a plugin known as charts,
underscore flutter. You can even search FL
underscore chart, which is a good library.
This is a very powerful library. You can see that.
And, uh, you can see the graphs are even more,
better and very customizable. But for this, we
are going to use charts under score flutter.
So let's quickly add that dependency, stop our
app execution. And in this admin create a widget
known as category products chart. So that will
allow us to have our own chart displaying.
And in case we want the graph to be seen on
other places. This can be a very reusable
thing. So your first of all, let's import
material dart, and also let's quickly run without
debugging. So we also need import of charts
underscore fluter fluter dot, dot as charts.
All right, now we can create a
stateless widget so we can call this,
let's say category products, chart.
And now we are going to return. What's
known as a bar chart given by this very plugin
charts flatter. This requires one argument,
one positional argument. So we can pass
in series list. And what is the series
list? We are going to accept that from the
constructor. So we have final list of series,
which is another thing provided by this plugin.
And it's going to consist of sales and string.
And we are going to call this CD list.
We are going to require this through the
constructor. Also import sales
away up after having series list.
That's all we can do, or we can set animate set
to true. So whenever we come on this screen, it'll
make sure that this graph animates in a vertical
direction or whatever animation has been given
to it. So here we can go to the analytics screen
and put the trail in comma also, <inaudible>
now we can use category, product screen, or
products chart and pass in the series list.
Well, it's going to be CD, right? So we have
series and then we need to pass in the ID. Well,
the ID is going to be sales. It's not
going to be outputted on the screen.
Then we need to pass in data. And we have the
data already, which is earnings. You can see,
it requires a list of sales and
we've already passed in the earnings.
After that we need the domain function. And this
domain function is what's going to show up on
the X axis. So here we are going to pass in sales
dot label. And now we need to create an instance
variable of sales, but actually we don't need
to create that domain function will already give
that. So here we are going to receive sales of
sales and other thing that is not useful for us.
And then we can ask sales dot labor and
measure function is going to be the why access.
So now we have access to earning and there we have
it. Now you can see, we are getting this error.
And this error is mainly because, because the
category products chart is going to have, well,
this chart's flatter, and this is also flatter. So
what we need to do is as charts use this, and then
our error goes away over year, but near we have to
use it like charts dot category products, chart,
not this actually charts dot series like this,
because this is our custom widget, but the CD
is provided by the plugin. Great. Now, if I come
over, we should not be able to see anything. Yeah,
we get that end of flow error. And now we need to
specify a specific height for this. So we can grab
this with a size box and specify the height.
Let's say two 50 and let's see what we get.
You can see we are getting it correctly.
So let's quickly go where, and we have that
shown as well. That means our graph is working
and it's showing us that correctly. So now
having all of this created, we can come back
to the user side and create the last function
that is logging out. And then we can test it on
Android to see if there's any bug or anything,
then we can deploy our own server. And then
I think we are good to go. All right. So we
are back in the user side of the application.
And now if I click over on the account screen,
you can see we have the log out button ready. We
just need to click on this and log out. So let's
quickly go there. Let's close all the say files
and go to our very last feature, which is the
top buttons year. We have the logout and it's
in account. So we need to go to their services
and add the logout functionality. Well, we will
avoid logout and we will require a build context,
and then we need to create it asynchronous. Then
we can have a try and a catch block in the tri
block in the catch block. We'll have a show snack
bar, obviously, where we will show E two strength.
All right. Now, what do we
need to do well to log out.
We need to understand how logged in
works. So whenever we try to log user in,
we are going to, we store their user
authentication token and share preferences.
And then based on that token, we
are checking if that token is there,
That means that the user is logged in. Otherwise
the user is not logged in. You're not storing
the user's logged in condition anywhere
in our database. We are storing that on
the user's device itself. So we need
to get access to shared preferences,
shared preferences, which will be equal
to shared preferences dot get instance.
Now, after having instance to that, we just
need to make sure that we set the string
empty so that whenever we come to this
odd service where we get the user's data,
which is when the user, just when the application
starts, we are running this functional function.
So whenever we get this user string and the
token can be now, so the token here is empty.
So it'll tell us that the token
is not valid and then it'll not
get us to the home screen. So yeah, we just need
to do a eight shared preferences. Set string
key will be Xu token, similar to what we had in
the art service, which is this Xu token or token.
And we need to make sure that it's
lowercase. So let's quickly type lowercase
and the value it's going to be an empty spring.
Great having that. We are making sure that there
is no more set string or anything. Now we just
need to make sure that we push the user on the
O screen route name right here. We just do
navigator dot, push named and remove until
O screen.name. So let's quickly have that. And
then we can set out set to false. Great. So we
are going to go to this odd screen and it'll pop
off all the other screens that come in between.
Also we can set provider to Nu
but, or empty strengths, whatever,
but I don't think there is any use case for
that because anyways, we are on back on the
main screen, it wouldn't really
matter. So if I click on log out,
no nothing would happen because I have to bind
this function. So let's quickly go by and use
account services and you need to create
that instance. So let's copy this
and our final account services. And now, instead
of, you know, creating this account services
instance as final and thus, because of that,
we need to create this as a stateful widget.
We're going to remove all of this and
convert this to a stateless widget.
And now we need to create a constructive
for that. So we can add key to constructors
and yep. We have it. Now we can just use account
services so that you know, like this, because if
we create the instance of the account services
over year, it'll become a stateful widget.
So here we have account services dot log out,
pass in the build context. And yeah, we have it.
Now, if I click on log out, we went back to
the odd screen. And if I tried to go back,
I'm not able to go back. I'll restart the
application and we are still not able to
go there. So that means our app is working
and it's completed. We have completed so
many features. I hope you learn something from
it. Now, the last thing that we need to cover
is deployment. And then after deploying it, we'll
test it on the Android device as well. So here we
to deploy it, we are going to use heroku.com. It's
a cloud application platform. You can see it over.
It allows us to host our servers over, which
will provide us with URL, which we can replace
with our, which is the IP address because IP
address will make sure that it only works locally.
When we are connected to that particular wifi
of which IP address we got. And with Heroku,
we are able to get a server where we can deploy
our server and it'll be accessible to everyone
and we can publish it out. So let's quickly sign
it up, sign up. You need to enter all of this,
the first name. So I'm gonna pass in,
run our, and then the email address.
So here we need to pass in your email address
and the primary development language I selected
as no J you can just use any other thing
you want. It really doesn't matter for now.
So now let's click on create free account. All
right. So I've logged in and here I am terms
of service. I'm not in Italy. I'll just click
on accept. If you are then select that option.
So here VR welcome to Heroku account has been set
up. Let's get started. So now we need to create a
new app. So let's quickly create a new app. We
need to enter the app name. So we are going to
name this Amazon clone, and this should start with
the lower case. So we have Amazon clone. Yep. This
is not available. So we can call this Ivan and
<affirmative> and Amazon clone R is available.
So we have United States based on this name,
you're going to get a URL. So make sure
whatever you type in is according to the URL
you wanted, and I'm going to choose a region
United States itself, and you can
choose Europe, whatever you want.
It, it wouldn't matter after that, we need
to deploy to deploy it. Either you can use
the Heroku CLI or you can connect with, get up
now to connect. I'm gonna connect with, get up.
So for that, what I'm going to do is stop this
server execution, clear off everything, and now
run, get in it, get, add, get commit M uploading
server. And then also, actually before doing that,
I would've preferred doing node under core
modules, ignoring them. So if you're familiar
with kit, what you need to do is dot get, ignore,
and ignore the node module. I've not done that,
but make sure to do it after that, we need
to set up and create a, get up accounts. I'm
quickly going to create my, get up account, your
click on new and create Amazon server tutorial.
I'm just going to repo, delete this
repository after trying it out, you know,
but now we are going to click on create
repository three when we need to make this public.
So yep. Now we need to add, get remote, add
origin, sorry, not origin. Get remote ad pass
in this URL. And I think we need to pass in
origin and then we need to finally do get
push U origin master after this. It'll make sure
that it uploads to get up so we can clear it off.
And if you're not familiar with get up and mention
the resource in the description below from where
you can learn it out. So we have our Amazon server
tutorial pass in so I can come over connect to get
up. I'm going to authorize Heroku for now pass in
my password. So after getting the URL from there,
you need to update your global variables. You are
writing and update your, remove your IP address.
And instead of that, put that, and also
before uploading, what you needed to do
was I forgot to tell you over here in
this port, you need to specify something
known as process dot ENV dot port or, or 3000.
That means that it'll look up. So when we deploy
node will give it a particular port. It'll not be
3000. It'll give it a random port. It can be 3000,
but it will not be 3000 always. So here we will
have process dot EMV dot port. So it'll take in
that port, that node gives us otherwise, if
it's not mentioned, then we can take 3000
forward. So after having done that, you have
passed it over. There's no need of this anymore,
so you can remove it. But even if you keep, keep
it, there's no worry about it. And then finally,
again, deploy it to Heroku, get the URL, and
it'll be the same URL after deploying it,
redeploying it. And then you can go to the global
variables, change our, and then our app should
work perfectly. So now I'm going to run it on
pixel five ator and see if it's working or not.
So I'm going to run without debugging and check
if there is any error in that debug console,
and here you can see, we are already getting an
error. And if you got this error and I'm looking
into it late, you can just go to the bill grade
L file. And here the minimum SDK version is 19.
So make sure to add that and now run it without
debugging. All right. So our app is built and
here we get the create account and sign in
thing. So let's quickly create an account.
I'm gonna call this R R pass in the email, let's
say R email.com and pass in R way three. Let's
say so I'm just going to click on, sign up
account has been created, then click on,
sign in and then sign in. And you, yeah,
but we are able to see the deal of the day.
We have the whole different card, and
now let's actually sort some product,
which is MacBook. I'll click on enter, and
I'll add to card, rate it with a 1.5 star
and then go to the card, proceed to buy an
item. And here we have the Google pay button.
You can see if we click away, Google pay requires
a Google account to be set up on this device.
We need to set up Google pay. You can try it
on a real device. So yeah, I'm gonna have,
uh, so here we are gonna have 1 0 1 fake street,
and it doesn't really matter if we enter or not,
because we can't place an order, but rest of the
things are working. It feels like that. No orders
are there still. Then we can click on deal of the
day. We can search products after that, we can
click on log out and we are logged out again.
So this is a bonus section in this tutorial
because flatter three has
come up. It was announced on
Google I, so yeah, we are. So what we are going
to do is see if there is any breaking changes,
I've upgraded to flatter three. If you want to
upgrade two, you can run flatter upgrade, and then
it'll show you all the necessary stuff. If
everything goes well, it'll show you like this.
Otherwise it'll also show you the suggestion of
how you can install it properly, or you can search
it on the net. So I have it here. What I'm going
to do now is open vs code and see if there is any
upgraded version or there's any B changing
break breaking code. So I'm just going to
exit via code update and open it again
and open it again. So yeah, we have it.
Let's see if you're getting any suggestion here.
You can see the flatter version is Florida 3.0 0.0
and the dot version is now 2.17. Great. So
now what I'm going to do is try and run the
application to see if it's working or not. So let
me get my I simulator and also keep track of all
the warnings that show up and everything that
shows up. All right. So our app has launched,
but we get these warnings and I've been looking
about this warnings throughout my discard server
and all of the servers I'm in. So this has nothing
to do with it. It's just that flatter when it
upgrades again to some other version, they'll
fix all of these things. But as of now, we don't
need to worry about this. This is inside flutter
code itself. So we can just ignore these for now.
Let's see if you're getting any warnings or errors
anywhere. And it doesn't seem like we do. Let's
remove all of the warnings and continue in our
application. So let me quickly remove all of these
things that have not done.
And yeah, now we don't have any warnings, so
let's close all the save files, then save all the
other file. And then again, close all the safe
files. Great. So now if I come back over here
and pass in the sign in, so let's say test 1,
2, 3, gmail.com and pass in the password as
test 1, 2, 3, click on sign in, and we are signing
in here. We are, everything looks great. And
there doesn't seem any other error. Now, in case
you don't know about flood three, it introduced
usage of material three in our application.
So you can go in the main door dot file. And
in the team data use material three. Yeah, we
have it, the option and the property and set
it to true after this, you know, it wouldn't do
anything great in our application, except this
part. You can see, this looks much better.
Even this, you know, it's rounded and it's
making it on its own. You can see the
ripple effect away. This has also changed
because of material three. And now this doesn't
really look like Amazon, but it looks cool though.
So I'm not complaining there. The proceed
to buy items. You can see it's rounded on
its own. If we increase this, it doesn't
matter. And here we have it. The icons also
seem to be a bit changed and nothing else
will really change in our application because
we are using designs from scratch, but you can
see, it looks great even the effect of a year.
So if you want, you can use this. Otherwise just
use the normal thing that we've created and we
are back to normal, but I like this better. So I'm
going to use material three and just add a comment
that you can remove. This line can remove
this line for anyone who's referring to the
source code. We can have this, and this will keep
coming until the next version of flood, but I just
wanted to know, show it to you that nothing is
changing your in our code so you can follow along
and that's it. So this was the tutorial. Thank you
so much for watching. See you in the next video.